ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. WE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BUT OUR QUE HAN
BERMAN- BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO
JUNE DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY. DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
REMOTE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SU
CHI THIS AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE JEAN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER IS
KAMLAGER NAY NHANH. LORD ALL
AROUND US THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
WE ARE BEING REMINDED OF THE
DEPTH OF OUR COMMUNION AS A
HUMAN FAMILY. FOR ALL WHO
EXPERIENCE FEAR OR ANXIETY WE
PRAY FOR PEACE OF MIND AND
SPIRIT. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE WE PRAY
FOR SAFETY AND PROTECTION. FOR
ALL WHO HAVE CONTRACTED
CORONAVIRUS WE PRAY FOR CARE
AND HEALING. FOR ALL WHO HAVE
DIED FROM CORONA VIRUS. WE PRAY
THEY ARE IN YOUR ETERNAL
EMBRACE. FOR AFFECTED FAMILIES
WHO ARE FACING DIFFICULT
DECISIONS BETWEEN FOOD ON THE
TABLE OR PUBLIC SAFETY. WE PRAY
FOR POLICY THAT RECOGNIZE THEIR
PLIGHT. FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE HEALTH INSURANCE
WE PRAY THAT NO FAMILY WILL
FACE FINANCIAL BURDENS ALONE.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE AFRAID TO
ACCESS CARE DUE TO IMMIGRATION
STATUS. WE PRAY FOR RECOGNITION
OF THE DIGNITY OF ALL. FOR OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AROUND THE
WORLD WE PRAY FOR SHARED
SOLIDARITY. FOR PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AND DECISION MAKERS
WE PRAY FOR WISDOM AND GUIDANCE.
WE PRAY FOR OPEN HEART AND
LISTENING HERE TO UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THOSE
WHO FEAR THEY ARE RARELY SEEN
OR HEARD. GIVE US THE RESOLVE
TO WORK WITH OTHERS TO MAKE A
NEW REALITY. SO THAT THOSE WHO
FACE INJUSTICES FEEL THE IMPACT
OF OUR SOLIDARITY COMPASSION
AND COMMUNION. FATHER DURING
THIS TIME MAY YOU BE A SIGN OF
HOPE COMFORT AND LOVE TO ALL.
GRANT PLEASE GRANT COMFORT GRAN
HEALING THE WEATHER FLOOR A MAN.
THANK YOU MS KAMLAGER WE ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN
US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER COOLEY. PUT YOUR HAND
OVER YOUR HEART. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
MARCH TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
SUBMIT AN IDEA ON A WILL RECORD
OKAY HENNESSY BIGGER TEM OF
THESE WAS OUT TO PARK DAWSON
SUPER THE DEATH READING OKAY IN
MOST. ROLLS ACOSTA MEMBER ROMAN
A QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY
CARRY TIME NO AND IS BIGGER TEM
DIRECT THE SORT OF A ARMS CLOSE
DOORS WERE ABSENT NINE FOURTEEN
A SYSTEM WRITTEN BY INJURE.
HOLDER MOVES AND MISS SECONDS
THE READING OF THE DAY'S TO BE
THIS WITH PRESENTATIONS TO
SINCE THERE ARE NOT IN
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE TO.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
READ AND- DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE. MISS TO THE
STATE. THERE ARE NOT. MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
ABSENCES TODAY FOR PURSE
BUSINESS A MEMBER MANGE IN DEEP
FOR MEDIC LEAVE US SOME. MEMBER
QUIRK AND WICKS. MR CALL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MY- THE YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY EIGHT THROUGH MOVE
ITEM A FOR SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
HILL FROM THE INACTIVE FILE AND
RE REFER THE BILL TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE- I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO SET
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE. PENDING RE
REFER A FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULENINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
A. B. TWENTY FOURTEEN
MAIENSCHEIN FROM JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL THE
SECOND READING FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO RE REFER
SB TWO NINETY TWO RUBIO FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE RESOLUTION. THERE IS A
RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK A RELATIVE TO WAVING
THE THIRTY DAY RULE FOR A CA
TWENTY FIVE MULLIN I ASK THAT
WE GO TO THAT ITEM NOW. IT
RESOLVER PURSUANT TO ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHT A OF THE
CURRENT CONSTITUTION ASSUME THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LIMIT TWENTY
FIVE MAYBE HEARD IN COMMITTEE
AND ACTED UPON BY THE ASSEMBLY
BEFORE THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS
HAVE ELAPSED SINCE
INTRODUCTION. AND THE JOINT
RULE FIFTY FIVE BE SUSPENDED TO
PERMIT SUCH HEARING AND ACTION
PRIOR TO BEING IN PRINT FOR
THIRTY DAYS. MEMBERS THIS TAKES
SIXTY VOTES. THREE FORCE
THRESHOLD. MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MISS
WALDRON IS ASKING. FOR AN AYE
VOTE COR CLUB IN THE ROLE. I
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS TO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON ASKING FOR AND
I MISS WALDRON IS ASK FOR AN I.
MR CALDERON. IS FOR AN I. AM IS
AT. FOUR NINE. ALL MEMBERS OF
HER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
OF REDDIT IS OUT ABOUT.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH YEAH. YEAH. I'M I'M ARE
DESIGNED ABOUT. WE WOULD NOT.
THE CLERK WILL. ALL MEMBERS ARE
OUT OF A. CLARK WAY. CLOSE REAL
TIME ABOUT I SEVENTEEN YOUR-
THE REST IS ADOPTED. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL 289-533-0820 ONE
THIRTY FOUR AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE. SEC ALL
BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ALL ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
CONTINUED AND ALL ITEMS ON
THIRD READING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN. BEFORE MOVING TO OTHER
BUSINESS WE WILL NOW TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE DO A
VOTE ON CONSENT AS ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE QUIRK READ THE
SECOND A CONSENT. SO AGO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AN ACCOLADE
OF THE STATE BAR OF CALIFORNIA.
APPLE OVER THE ROLE IN THE CAN.
FORM AND OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OUT OF A-
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS AT ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY NINE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SO WE CAN CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
FIVE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE. I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SUM
AGO TWENTY THREE NINETY SEVEN I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME LEGAL
TWENTY NINETY EIGHT AS ONE
THOSE SOME TWENTY NINETY NINE I
ONE THOSE ZERO SO WE WILL FOUR
TWO I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SO WE
GO ONE THREE AS ONE THOSE SO WE
TWENTY THREE NINETY AS ONE ZERO
WE WILL TO FIVE SO THREE SO ONE
A ZERO SUM LEGAL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY AS YOUR SO WE GO
TWENTY EIGHT OH. I SAID NO ZERO
MIDDLE TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE SEVENTY IS THERE SEVEN
TWENTY ONE OH SEVEN AS ONE ZERO
PEOPLE TO TWO SO FIVE SEVENTY
ONE THOSE ARE SOME WIGGLE
THIRTY ONE TWO I ONE THOSE ARE
AWESOME WILL TWENTY SIX I
SEVENTY ONE AS SUM PARTY SIXTY
I SO ANYWAY A ZERO SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY THREE. I SAW ONE NO ARE
AWESOME THIRTY SEVEN THREE I
SEVENTY ONE AND SUM TWENTY
THREE FOUR I SEVENTY ONE THOSE
ZERO SO WE WILL SEVEN ONE AS
ONE NO ZERO SAN CONCURRENT
SIXTY SO I SEVENTY ONE AS IN
CAN WITH SIXTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO. IT'S ENTIRELY
UNNECESSARY BUT THANK YOU
NONETHELESS. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PRO TEM. COLLEAGUES AS
YOU KNOW. THE CORONA VIRUSES
PUT US IN A DOUBLE BLIND WHEN
IT COMES TO WRITING A STATE
BUDGET. THE HEALTH CURRENT THAT
THE HEALTH CRISIS HAS GREATLY
LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO MEET IN
PERSON BECAUSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
RESTRICTIONS. AT THE SAME TIME
THE IMPACT OF A PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED UNPRECEDENTED CHANGES
IN OUR REVENUE RESOURCES AND
ARE SPENDING NEEDS. WE MUST ACT
TO ADDRESS THE CHANGES FOR THE
SAKE OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. FURTHERMORE WE MUST
ACT IN THE FACE OF LIMITATIONS
THAT SURROUND US EVERYWHERE WE
LOOK TODAY. THE EXTRAORDINARY
ACTION WE TAKE TODAY WILL HELP
US TO DELIBERATE AND GET OUR
BUDGET APPROVED BY THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION. THE COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE PROCESS WILL ALLOW
EACH O US TO DISCUSS THE
BUDGET FREELY. WITHOUT SOME OF
THE LIMITATIONS ON DISCUSSION
IMPOSED BY OUR NORMAL
PARLIAMENTARY PROCEDURES. THAT
MEANS THAT LATER ON WE CAN VOTE
BASED ON A COMMON UNDERSTANDING
OF THE PROBLEM. AND THE
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS BEFORE US.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON I WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF THE STAFF OF THE
CHIEF CHIEF CLERK. TGS STAFF.
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. R. I. T. TEAM
AND THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WHO
pIT MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
DO THIS WORK. AT THIS POINT I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MISTER
CALDERON UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY RESOLVE INTO A
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF HEARING TESTIMONY
RELATIVE TO THE STATE BUDGET.
MOST REQUIRES A SECOND SECOND
BY MS WALDRON THIS TAKES A
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT AND
VOTING ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE MOTION CARRIES
MEMBERS I AM APPOINTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AS CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE WHOLE
MR TING YOU MAY PERSON. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER FIRST LET ME
JUST JOIN YOU AT ALSO THINKING-
YOUR STAFF IN PARTICULAR MR
BRIAN NEIGHBOR MR JASON SYDNEY
MISSED RADICE TELL MS CAREY
CORN WELL AS WELL AS ONE
TORRANCE LIKE TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK ALSO- THE
RULES COMMITTEE TEAM WITH EVER
BRAVER AND ALL HER AMAZING
STAFF HAVE REALLY WORKED VERY
HARD TO MAKE SURE WE WERE ABLE
TO. DO THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
ALSO THANK CHIEF BUCKLEY AND
ALL THE SERGEANTS OR ALL THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND LASTLY WE HAVE
RICK MADE IN THE TV CREW WHO
ARE STREAMING THE SLIDE TO MAKE
SURE NOT ONLY THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN WATCH IT BUT THAT THERE'S A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT THIS
INFORMATION REACHES ALL OF
CONTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA I
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE TEAM THAT WORKED VERY
VERY HARD. TO MAKE THIS- THE
FIRST ME THE WHOLE NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS TODAY I HAVE
THE HONOR OF SITTING AT SPEAKER
WILLIE BROWN SUGAR WITH SPEAKER
WHEN WE ASKED THE COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE. THE LOOK THEY
COMMITTEE REFER WHICH AS WE
FACE FROM THE CALL TEAM HAD
DEVON. IT'S ALL COME TO GET BY
THIS TERRIBLE DISEASE. YEAH BUT
ALSO MAINTAIN A PRO. PHYSICAL
DISTANCE. TO PROTECT OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE ASSEMBLY IS HOLDING
FLOOR SO FROM FIRST TIME SINCE
WITH READ ON THE- AS WITH A-OTHER ORGAN. WE'VE HAD THE
MODIFIER BUSINESS TO ADOPT TO A
NEW ENVIRONMENT. TODAY WE ARE
BACK TOGETHER AS ONE BODY TO DO
THE BUSINESS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA JOIN TOGETHER TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE. SAVING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES OF WE
COLLECTIVELY AND COOPERATIVELY
WORK TOGETHER TO SLOW
TRANSMISSION. NOW WE MUST COME
TOGETHER TO ASSIST ALL THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO SACRIFICED
THEIR LIVELIHOODS BY STAYING AT
HOME. AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIANS NEED US THE MOST
WE ARE FEWER RESOURCES TO HELP.
THIS YEAR OUR BUDGET IS MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER WE MUST MAKE
EVERY DOLLAR COUNT WE HAVE TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET. YET
ENSURE OUR PLANS PROVIDE A
HELPING HAND TO THOSE MOST IN
NEED. BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC WITH
ALMOST EVERY CALIFORNIAN
WORKING MANY FAMILIES WERE ABLE
TO SAY EVEN A TOTAL OF FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS. SINCE ITS
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
NOW APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE MUST FOCUS OUR RESOURCES TO
ENSURE THOSE FAMILIES ARE
HOUSING ECONOMICALLY STABLE
OTHERWISE W WILL HAVE TO SPEND
SIGNIFICANT STATE RESOURCES. TO
HELP THEM DOWN THE LINE.
TODAY'S COMMITTEE THE WHOLE
PROCEEDINGS WILL BEGIN WITH THE
DISCUSSION OF THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE AT THE STATE. AND THE
OPTIONS WE HAVE IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. IT WILL ALSO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE TRADE OFF FROM THE
REST WITH CONSIDERABLY FINALIZE
OUR SPENDING PLAN. OVER THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. TODAY'S
DISCUSSIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS WILL SHAPE THE
DIRECTION. OF OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET PLAN. SO WHAT LIES AHEAD
THE WHAT CHALLENGES DO WE FACE.
HOW DO WE ASSIST CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. HOW DO WE
BALANCE OUR STATE'S LONG TERM
FISCAL HEALTH AGAINST CUTS IN
GOVERNMENT SERVICES WHICH WILL
EXACERBATE THE ECONOMIC PAIN
FAMILIES ARE NOW FEELING. HOW
MUCH ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL RISK
SHOULD OUR STATE TAKE LONG TO
AID THOSE FAMILIES. WHO HAVE NO
SAVINGS AND NO RESOURCES TO
BORROW FROM. IF WE MUST MANAGE
THIS DISEASE FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME AS SCIENTISTS PREDICT. HOW
DO WE ALLOW FOR QUICK AND
DECISIVE ACTIONS NEEDED IN
TIMES OF CRISIS. WITHOUT
SACRIFICING A DELIBERATIVE IN
TRANSPARENT DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENT. HOW DO WE ENSURE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE. TO
STAY AT HOME. I HAVE EVERY
FAITH CALIFORNIANS WILL AGAIN
RISE TO THIS CHALLENGE AND FIND
A BETTER PLACE AT THE END OF
THIS JOURNEY. TODAY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY MEMBER TO
COMMENT ON THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSALS WAS TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
ILLEGAL ANY QUESTIONS TO ASSIST
THEM WITH THEIR DELIBERATIONS.
I THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. TO LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WITH THAT I CALL ON ALL VICE
CHAIR OF OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE MISTER WE DON'T.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY EVENT IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS- WE GATHER. TO
TRY AND CRAFT A BUDGET THAT
WILL ACCOMPLISH ONE PURPOSE AND
ONE PURPOSE ALONE. WHICH IS TO
SET CALIFORNIA ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY FROM THIS
UNPRECEDENTED THAT. TO THAT END.
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I'M
GOING TO BE DIRECTED TO THE LA
ONLY DO YOU HAVE TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO ASK JUST ONE QUESTION
DOES THE MAY REVISION THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PRESENTED SET US
ON THAT PATH IN MANY WAYS I
THINK IT DOES BUT I HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS THE FIRST OF
MY CONCERNS. IS WHETHER OR NOT
THIS BUDGET SETS ON APPROPRIATE
DIVISION BETWEEN EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY ON ONE HAND AND TO
THE OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE OTHER. WHEN
WE LEFT SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WE
GAVE THE GOVERNOR OF BILLION
DOLLARS IN APPROPRIATIONS
AUTHORITY TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS AND I THINK THAT
WAS A VERY APPROPRIATE ACTION.
FOR US TO TAKE HOWEVER THE
GOVERNOR'S ASKING US TODAY TO
GIVE HIM. AN ADDITIONAL THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OF SPENDING
AUTHORITY. AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT TO GIVEN AUTHORITY. TO
SPEND THE TEN MILLION DAHLE TEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS TO COME
BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN WAYS THAT HE
SEES VINCE. AND I HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THAT MIGHT NOT BE
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO TAKE. WE
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
OVERSEE THE SPENDING OF THOSE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. WE CAN EASILY
RECONVENE EVEN IF WE'RE NOT IN
SESSION THIS FALL. TO EXERCISE
THAT AUTHORITY AND I'D LIKE TO
BE A PARTNER TO THE GOVERNOR IN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND SPENDING
THAT MONEY. THE SECOND CONCERN
I HAVE IS THAT WE ALL OF
KNOWLEDGE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO MAKE LARGE CUTS. TO BALANCE
OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR. AND I
THINK I SPEAK FOR EVERYONE IN
THIS CHAMBER WHEN I SAY. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WERE STILL
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE
SEGMENTS OF OUR SOCIETY. AND WE
DIDN'T NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CUTS WERE MAKING. OUR
INCONGRUENCE WITH OUR VALUES AS
CALIFORNIANS. NOW THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED A SORT OF CUTS IN
THE BUDGET AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE REFINING
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS I
THINK SOME OF THOSE CUTS ARE
APPROPRIATE SOME OF THEM I
THINK WE ARE GOING TO AGREE OR
NOT AND I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE FROM MY OWN DISTRICT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TO
CLOSE THE BARSTOW VETERANS
HOME. IN BARSTOW CALIFORNIA I
WAS IN BARSTOW YESTERDAY THERE
WAS A RALLY TO SAVE THE
VETERANS HOME ALTHOUGH WAS OVER
A HUNDRED DEGREES IN BARSTOW WE
HAD OVER FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
BY MY COUNT YET THAT REALLY
EXPRESSING OUTRAGE. THAT WE AS
A LEGISLATURE. WHAT CONSIDER.
THROWING NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
ELDERLY VETERANS OUT OF THEIR
HOME AND I HOPE THAT EVERYONE
WOULD AGREE THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING. THAT IS PART OF OUR
VALUES AS CALIFORNIANS. THE
THIRD THING THAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BUDGET WE PASS. SETS CALIFORNIA
ON THE ROAD TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. WE'VE HEARD SOME
EXTREMELY DISTURBING TESTIMONY
IN THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS IN OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE. THE ECONOMIC
EXPERTS PROJECT THAT IF THE
STARS ALIGNED WE COULD HAVE A
RELATIVELY QUICK ECONOMIC
RECOVERY FROM THIS RECESSION
BUT THAT FROM AN EMPLOYMENT
STANDPOINT. RECOVERY WILL TAKE
A LONG TIME PERHAPS YEARS
PERHAPS THREE OR FOUR YEARS
THAT IS EXTREMELY SOBERING WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT. THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE OUT OF WORK RIGHT NOW.
SO MY QUESTION IS THIS BUDGET.
GOING TO SET US ON THE ROAD TO
BREAKING THOSE JOBS BACK AND WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE BUDGET. THAT WE IN
GOVERNMENT CANNOT CREATE JOBS
WE LAY THE FOUNDATION BUT
INDUSTRIES AND BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA THE CREATORS OF
THOSE JOBS THOSE OF THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE NEEDED GOING
TO BE TO HIRE. OR CALIFORNIANS
BACK TO WORK. AND I HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THAT IN
THIS BUDGET. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED RAISING TAXES ON
BUSINESS OVER FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR. AND HE'S
DOING IT IN A PROGRESSIVE A
PARTICULARLY REGRESSIVE WAY. BY
DISALLOWING THE NET OPERATING
LOSS TO TAX DEDUCTION SO IN
OTHER WORDS WE'RE GOING TO
PENALIZE THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING POORLY. HE'S ALSO
GOING TO CAP THE AMOUNT OF TAX
CREDITS THE BUSINESSES CAN
TAKE. WHICH TO ME IS RENEGING
ON THE PROMISES THAT WE MADE TO
THOSE BUSINESSES WHEN WE PASS
THOSE TAX CREDITS. AND THOSE
PROMISES OF THE BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN RELYING ON WHEN THEY PUT
TOGETHER THE BUSINESS PLAN. FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND I
ALSO THINK WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE SHORE UP OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
RELYING ON THAT SYSTEM WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT SYSTEM
IS HEALTHY. WE HAVE JUST TAKEN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OF LOANS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
SHORE UP THAT SYSTEM WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A PLAN FOR
PAYING TAT MONEY BACK. BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN AND WE
FAIL TO REPAIR THAT MONEY BACK.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL DO
AS THEY HAVE DONE IN THE LAST
RECESSION. AND IMPOSE PENALTIES
ON EVERY BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR EVERY EMPLOYEE THAT THEY
HAVE. WE CANNOT ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN. THAT WAS BE PENALIZING
BUSINESSES WHOSE. ARE ARE NOT
AT FAULT AT ALL IN THIS PRICES
BECAUSE WAS ACTION OF THE STATE
THAT SHUT THEM DOWN. IT WAS AN
ACTION OF THE STATE BUT TOOK
THOSE LOANS. AT A NEEDS TO BE
AN ACTION OF THE STATE THE
REPAIRS THOSE LOANS SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION AND- IN THE BUDGET.
AND THEN LASTLY. I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THIS BUDGET SETS
US ON A PATH. TO FUTURE SUCCESS
IN OUR BUDGETS. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGREED ON THE FACT THAT
THIS BUDGET DEFICIT IS NOT A
SINGLE YOU'RE ABOUT. WE WILL BE
FACING ANOTHER BUDGET DEFICIT
NEXT YEAR PROBABLY OF SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE EVEN
WITH THE CUTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED IN THIS YOU YEAR'S
BUDGET THE YEAR AFTER THAT IT
WILL BE EVEN WORSE PERHAPS AS
MUCH AS SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST MERELY
KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
THIS YEAR BECAUSE IT'S JUST
GOING TO BE HARDER FOR US NEXT
YEAR. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING DOING A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT ALONG THOSE LINES FIRST
OF ALL HE'S PROPOSING OVER TEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF INTER FUND
BORROWING SO WE'RE BORROWING
MONEY FROM RESTRICTED FUNDS
PUTTING IT IN THE GENERAL FUND
AND PROMISING TO PAY IT BACK
LATER WITH INTEREST. FOLKS THAT
IS JUST KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD. ANOTHER THING THAT IS
PROPOSING IS. FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS A BUDGET DEFERRALS.
WHICH JUST MEANS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO PAY THE BILLS THAT WE
HAVE. DO THIS YEAR ONE DAY INTO
NEXT YEAR SO THAT WE CAN TELL
EVERYBODY. THAT THEY WERE NEXT
YEAR'S BILLS INSTEAD OF THIS
YEAR'S BILLS. OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
JUST GOING TO CREATE. A BIGGER
PROBLEM FOR US NEXT YEAR. I
THINK WE NEED TO BE THE ADULTS
IN THE ROOM HERE. AND THE FACE
THE FISCAL REALITIES. THAT
EXISTED THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. BUT
AS I LOOK AROUND THIS ROOM. I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE A DEDICATED.
GROUP OF PEOPLE HERE. THAT WANT
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM FOR
CALIFORNIANS MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SOLVING
THE PROBLEM WITH YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR. WE
WILL NOW RECOGNIZE OR TWO
WITNESSES. FOR THEIR OPENING
STATEMENTS WE'RE HONORED TO
HAVE MISSED KEELEY BALSER.
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OF COURSE OUR LA-
MR GAVE. PADDOCK AND WE WILL
START WITH HIS BOSS WERE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. SORRY ALL RIGHT I'LL
START OVER I'M GOOD AFTERNOON I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY MY NAME IS KEENLY
BOTHER AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE- FOR IT GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM I AM HONORED TO BE
PRESENT HERE TODAY WITH YOU AT
TO PRESENT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL AT THIS
HISTORIC CONVENING AB. OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE.
JUST A FEW SHORT MONTHS AGO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC OUTLOOK
WITH SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
THAN IT IS TODAY. WE HAD AN
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT LEVEL
WE HAD A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF CONSECUTIVE JOB
GROWTH AND ONE OUT OF SEVEN NEW
U. S. JOBS WITH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ENTER PRUDENT
FISCAL MANAGEMENT FOR MANY
YEARS. STRUCTURALLY BALLOT
THIRD IN AN ACTING STRUCTURALLY
BALANCED BUDGETS AND BUILDING
UP RECORD RESERVES CALIFORNIA
IS ON A MUCH STRONGER FISCAL
POSITION THAN INTO RANGE OF
PRIOR RECESSIONS. BUT SINCE
THEN OVERNIGHT THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY ALTERED OUR
LIVES. AND HAS CAUSED A GLOBAL
ECONOMIC CRISIS. THE US IS
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING A
RECESSION THAT IS EXPECTED TO
BE WORSE THAN THE GREAT
RECESSION. CALIFORNIA PERSONAL
INCOME IS ALSO PROJECTED TO
DECLINE THIS YEAR AND IS NOT
EXPECTED TO RETURN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN LEVELS UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. ONE HALF A
TRILLION DOLLARS LESS THAN WHAT
WAS PROJECTED IN JANUARY. ONE
OF THE MOST ALARMING ASPECTS OF
THE EARLY MONTHS OF THIS
RECESSION ARE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
LEVELS ESPECIALLY AMONG LOWER
WAGE WORKERS. WHICH IS
AMPLIFYING THE WAGE DISPARITY
THAT EXISTED BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC IT. SINCE FEBRUARY
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS INCREASED UP
FROM THREE POINT 9% IN FEBRUARY
TWO FIFTEEN POINT 5% IN APRIL
AND FURTHER INCREASES ARE
EXPECTED LATER THIS QUARTER.
JUST FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT IN THE GREAT RECESSION
IT TOOK THIRTY EIGHT MONTHS. TO
REACH PEAK UNEMPLOYMENT'S
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION-
WHICH WAS TWELVE POINT THREE
PERCENT. SO THE STATE HAS
REACHED THIS NEW RECORD PEAK
AND JUST TWO SHORT MONTHS. THIS
IS AN UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE
FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE FACING THE GREATEST
HARDSHIPS IN OUR STATE LOW WAGE
WORKERS. STUDENTS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND SENIORS.
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC IS HAVING A MASSIVE
IMPACT ON STATE REVENUES. SINCE
JANUARY REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE FORTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS LOWER. AT THE
SAME TIME THE STATE IS
EXPERIENCING AN INCREASE COSTS
IN CASELOADS IN THE STATE'S
CORE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. AND IS ALSO
EXPERIENCING AN INCREASE COSTS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO RESPONDING
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
OVERALL COMPARED TO OUR JANUARY
ESTIMATES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS PROJECTED TO FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS OF NEARLY
OF OVER FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN EACH YEAR IN THE MULTI YEAR.
DESPITE THIS AT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL THAT WAS PUT
FORTH ON MAY FOURTEENTH-
PROPOSES TO BALANCE THE BUDGET.
IT ADDRESSES THAT THE FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT AND IT REDUCES THE OUT
YOUR DEFICIT THAT DOES NOT
SOLVE THEM BY IT BUT IT REDUCES
THEM BY APPROXIMATELY 60% IT
DOES THIS BY ALSO PROTECTING
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S CORE
VALUES IT INVESTS IN WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION IT
CREATES A NEW FUNDING
OBLIGATION FOR SCHOOLS TO
ACCELERATE THE RECOVERY. OF OUR
OF SCHOOL FOR FUNDING. IT
PRESERVES CHILDCARE SLOTS IT
EXPANDS ACCESS TO CHILDCARE TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS. IT ALSO
MAINTAINS OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAM
OUR FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
ANTICIPATION THAT MANY
DISPLACED WORKERS OFTEN RETURN
TO HIGHER EDUCATION. AB WHEN
THEY'VE LOST A JOB. AND THEN
FINALLY THE BUDGET SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIANS FACING THE
GREATEST HARDSHIPS- LAST YEAR
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. WE WERE ABLE TO
EXPAND THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT THAT PROVIDES ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS TO WORKING
FAMILIES WITH INCOMES LESS THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND INCLUDING A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR AB AT A CREDIT
FOR WORKERS WITH CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX THAT IS
MAINTAINED IN THIS BUDGET- AS
ARE THE GRANTS. AT LEVELS THE
CURRENT GRANT LEVELS FOR BOTH
CAL WORKS AND SS I SS P. WE
ALSO PRIORITIZE IN THIS BUDGET
AB PROTECTING THE CURRENT
ELIGIBILITY OF THE STATE'S
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND ALSO AS- AT
THE COVERED CALIFORNIA MARKET
PLACE. THE EXPANDED SUBSIDIES
THE HISTORIC EXPANDED SUBSIDIES
THAT WERE ENACTED LAST YEAR TO
SERVE CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN AT
THE FACT FOR A FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIX OR SIX 100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. I DON'T THINK
I'VE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE TO
SWITCH LIGHTS ON. I AM I AM
CURRENTLY ON LET'S SAY SLIDE.
SORRY TH NERVOUS. AND THE
BALLOT SOLUTION SLIDE IF WE
COULD GO THERE THAT BE GREAT.
THE MAYOR REVISION PROPOSES
BALANCE POLICE AND. OUR RIGHTS
TO MEET THE CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENT OF A BALANCED
BUDGET THE MAY REVISION DOES
PROPOSE I'M SOLUTIONS IN SIX
CATEGORIES FIRST AT THE VERY
FIRST ITEM IS CANCELING
EXPANSIONS THAT WERE- PROPOSED
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET. I'M AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE NUMBERS
PRODUCED BY THE LA- AND BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
BIG DIFFERENCES WE'RE DRIVING
OFF OF THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THAT'S HOW WE
TYPICALLY REVISED- IN THE MAY
REVISION IS OFF OF THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL SO THE FIRST SET OF
SOLUTIONS ARE REDUCTIONS- ARE
RELATED T CANCELING EXPANSIONS
OF PROGRAMS THAT WERE PROPOSED.
IN JANUARY THIS CATEGORY ALSO
DOES CANCEL SOME EXPANSIONS
THAT WERE PROPOSED IN TWENTY
NINE THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT THAT HAD NOT STARTED YET
BUT GIVEN THE VERY CHANGED
CIRCUMSTANCES- WE THINK THAT
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE MERITED
THIS TIME. WE ALSO PROPOSING TO
USE THE HISTORIC RESERVES THAT
THE STATE HAS BUILT UP OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. I'M ABOUT
SEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE RAINY DAY FUND
THE OVERALL RAINY DAY FUND IS
ESTIMATED TO BE SIXTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION AND SEVEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION OF THAT IS
PROPOSED TO BE USED TO THIS
YEAR. AND SOME ADDITIONAL
RESERVES IN THE SAFETY NET A
RESERVE FUND AS WELL AS
RESERVES- THAT WERE PART OF THE
PUBLIC. SCHOOLS AS A RESERVE.
AND THERE IS ALSO AB PROPOSAL-
TO DO SOME INTERNAL BORROWING
THESE THEIR BORROWING AND
BORROWING THAT WE DO FOR M.
INTERNALLY AND WE HAVE DONE IN
PRIOR. DOWNTURNS FROM SPECIAL
FUNDS IN FACT LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ACTUALLY PAID OFF ALL OF
THE INTERNAL BORROWING THAT HAD
HAPPENED FROM PRIOR RECESSIONS.
BUT THIS BUDGET DOES RELY ON
SOME BORROWING- BECAUSE THE
MAGNITUDEOF THIS CRISIS IS SO
GREAT WE ALSO PROPOSE SOME
TRANSFERRED SOME FOR SOME
SPECIAL FUNDS- AS WELL AS
DEFERRALS IN THE AREA OF
SCHOOLS AND I WILL TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE DEPTH. ABOUT
THE SCHOOL FUNDING PROPOSAL IN
A LITTLE BIT. FINALLY I AM WE
ALSO PROPOSE SOME NEW TIME
LIMITED REVENUES- THE REVENUES
THE TWO MAJOR PROPOSALS- THAT
TO AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED- WERE ARE
THE- SUSPENSION OF NET
OPERATING LOSSES. AND ALSO THE-
CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF TAX CREDIT
THAT CAN BE TAKEN IN ANY ONE
GIVEN YEAR TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. BOTH OF THESE CAN ALSO
BE SEEN BY SOME AS BORROWING
BECAUSE AND FOR ALL OF THESE
TAX CREDITS WOULD CONTINUE TO
STAY. ON THAT THE COMPANY'S
BALANCE SHEETS AND WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE USED IN FUTURE YEARS
BUT THEY ARE SUSPENDED IN THE
NEXT THREE YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY. CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT THE STATE IS CURRENTLY
FACING WITH ITS BUDGET. THAT'S
ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
ON THAT WERE ALSO PROPOSING TO
STRATEGICALLY USE THE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT WERE PROVIDED
EARLIER THIS YEAR FROM THE
CARES ACT PRIMARILY- AND THOSE
ARE ALSO BEING USED TO- HELP TO
SOLVE THE BUDGET AND ADDRESS
SPECIFICALLY COSTS. RELATED TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN RECESSION
OUR COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND THEN FINALLY- THE BUDGET IS
BALANCED ON A TRIGGER A TRIGGER
THAT ASSUMES THAT ADD THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING BUT IF
THE FUNDING IS NOT PROVIDED. IT
DOES- THE PROPOSED BASE
REDUCTIONS TO PROGRAMS. I JUST
WANT TO TAKE  LOOK AT A MINUTE
TO TALK ABOUT THESE REDUCTIONS
THESE ARE THESE ARE THESE ARE
REAL REDUCTIONS THEY HAVE REAL
IMPACTS TO TEACHERS STATE
EMPLOYEES. STUDENTS AND SENIORS.
BUT THEY ARE NECESSARY GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE REVENUE
SHORTFALL AND IN THE ABSENCE OF
FEDERAL FUNDS. TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET WHICH IS A RECORD
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT.
INTO A BIRDS THE ADDITIONAL
UNCERTAINTY THAT COMES. WITH A
CASH CRISIS. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MUST PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO AVERT
THOSE REDUCTIONS. I'M MOVING ON
TO THE RAINY DAY FLY READY DAY
FUND SLIDE- THE MAY REVISION
AGAIN IS BALANCED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR BUT IT DOES HAVE A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT TO DO REMAIN
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
INCLUDING SIX AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED AN
ESTIMATED DEFICIT IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO NEARLY TWELVE
BILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND OVER SIXTEEN BILLION
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
AND WITH OUT ACTIONS PROPOSED
IN THE ME REVISION THESE
DEFICITS WOULD BE OVER FORTY
BILLION IN EACH OF THOSE YEARS.
GIVEN THE FISCAL CRISIS FACING
THE STATE AT THAT MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO ALLOCATE ALL OF THE
RAINY DAY FUND OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. BUT WE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT A ONE YEAR PROBLEM
THOSE RESERVES ARE PROPOSED TO
BE USED- OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. MOVING ON TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDING ALLOCATION FIVE THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IS ALSO VERY
FORTUNATE WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE
TO HAVE NEARLY TEN BILLION
DOLLARS- FROM THE FEDERAL CARES
ACT THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
TO DIRECT IN THE MAY REVISION-
AND THESE FUNDS MUST BE USED
FOR COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
COSTS. ATTHE FIRST ALLOCATION
IS FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION FOR
OUR K. TWELVE STUDENTS TO
ADDRESS THE LEARNING LOSS- THAT
HAS BEEN HAPPENING WITH THIS
THE CLOSURE OF OUR SCHOOLS-
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN THE
FAMILY'S HIT HARDEST. ONE POINT
THREE BILLION FOR COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND OTHER HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND THEN
FINALLY FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR CITIES- TO ADDRESS
THE COVERT NINETEEN RELATED-
COSTS IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AS WELL AS PUBLIC
SAFETY. MOVING ON TO THE SCHOOL
SLIDE. THE MASSIVE DECLINE IN
REVENUES- OF OVER FORTY ONE
BILLION IS CAUSING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY ACRE
CONSTITUTIONAL GUARANTEE TO
DECLINE BY NINETEEN BILLION.
THE MAY REVISION MITIGATES THIS
DECLINE IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
WAYS IN THE SHORT TERM AND
PROPOSES A NEW OBLIGATION TO
SCHOOLS TO ACCELERATE THE
RECOVERY OF SCHOOL FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY THE MAY REVISION
IS PROPOSING TO ESTABLISH A NEW
DEDICATED. FUNDING SOURCE OF
ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES ANNUALLY
UNTIL SCHOOL FUNDING REACHES
40% OF THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUNDS. CURRENTLY K. FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY
38% OF GENERAL FUND. THIS WILL
HELP THE SCHOOL FUNDING RECOVER
MORE QUICKLY AND WILL BE
CRITICAL TO STABILIZE IN AND
MAINTAINING THE PROGRESS THAT
THE STATE HAS MADE OVER THE
PAST DECADE AND IMPROVING
STUDENT OUT IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR ALL STUDENTS. FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR THERE ARE ALSO
SEVERAL AT THEIR PROPOSALS IN
THE MAY REVISION THAT HELP TO
MITIGATE AD THAT DECLINE IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE. THE FIRST
ARE THE TEMPORARY REVENUES THAT
I JUST SPOKE ABOUT THEY PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AND BENEFIT TO
THE SCHOOL FUNDING. TO SCHOOL
FUNDING ALSO AT THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS OF FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION THAT WILL BE
ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR WE TOOK AB HISTORIC
SURPLUSES AND WERE ABLE TO MAKE
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
BOTH HERS AND STIRRERS. I'M BE
FOR HALF OF THE STATE AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ABOUT TWO POINT
THREE BILLION OF THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THE ON BEHALF OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR LONG
TERM. LIABILITIES THE BUT THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
ACCELERATE THAT- SAVINGS AND
PROVIDE MORE IMMEDIATE RELIEF
IN BOTH THE BUDGET YEAR AND
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE. I'M ALSO
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL RESERVE IS
BEING USED TO MITIGATE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THEN FINALLY-
DEFERRALS ARE BEING INSTITUTED
DEFERRALS HAVE ROUTINELY BEEN
USED IN PRIOR RECESSIONS- THEY
DO ALLOW DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN
PROGRAMS BUT DO REQUIRE
DISTRICTS TO GO. OUT ON THE
MARKET AND BORROW OR USE OTHER
FUNDS THAT THEY CAN ADD TO MAKE
THOSE PAYMENTS- BUT WE WOULD
THINK THAT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE DECLINE IN THE GUARANTEE
THAT THESE DEFERRALS ARE
NECESSARY- FOR PROGRAMS TO BE
MAINTAINED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND TO A JET AND ESPECIALLY
SINCE SCHOOLS ARE FACING. LARGE
CHANGES IN AND CHANGING AND
ADJUSTING THE CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION TO DEAL WITH THE
NEW REALITY OF A COVERT
NINETEEN WORLD. MOVING TO THE
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY- THIS
BUDGET PROPOSES REDUCTIONS TO
NEARLY ALL ASPECTS OF GOVERNOR
STATE OPERATIONS OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL
IS CANCELED- CONTRACTS THAT ARE
NOT THAT ARE NOT DEEMED
NECESSARY ARE HALTED IN ALL
ONLY ESSENTIAL VACANCIES ARE
BEING FILLED. THE COVERT
NINETEEN THE PANDEMIC HAS
DISRUPTED STATE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS FORCING THE STATE TO
FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO ADOPT TO
ADAPT AND DELIVER CORE SERVICES.
AND THIS BY- A REVISION
PROPOSES TO USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RETHINK THE WAY
THE STATE DELIVERS MANY
SERVICES AS WE RETURN TO NORMAL
TIMES. I HAVE SPECIFICALLY
LOOKING AT WAYS TO RETHINK
OFFICE SPACE AND SHRINK THE
STATE'S REAL ESTATE PORTFOLIO
OVER TIME AND ALSO BRING YOU
MORE SERVICES ONLINE I'M TO
INCREASE CONVENIENCE TO THE
PUBLIC BUT ALSO CREATE GREATER
EFFICIENCIES AT THE STATE. JOB
CREATION SIDE ENTREPRENEURS WHO
RUN SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND WHILE THE FEDERAL
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED OVER SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN A COMBINATION OF
GRANTS AND LOANS INTO THE STATE.
WE ESTIMATE THAT ONLY ABOUT
SEVEN AND A HALF PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUR MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS PROGRAM. TO HELP FILL
THAT GAP THE MAY REVISION DOES
PROPOSE A HUNDRED MILLION%
DOLLARS FOR ADDITIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS FOR THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT WERE NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION- PROGRAM. I WOULD WE
ALSO PROPOSED TO MAINTAIN A TAX
CUT THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
JANUARY- BUDGET TO- ELIMINATE
THE MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX FOR
NEW SMALL BUSINESSES. BUT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO SUPPORT JOB
CREATION AND ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WALK
WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK. AND SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF GOOD PAYING JOBS
SPECIFICALLY AROUND SMALL
BUSINESS RECOVERY INCREASING
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE STATE
AN INCREASE IN OUR INVESTMENTS
IN HUMAN AND PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. DEFICIT SLIDE
PLEASE. I'M GONNA WRAP IT UP
HERE AND THESE ARE REALLY
UNCERTAIN TIMES FOR PEOPLE AND
HOUSEHOLDS DO THAT DUE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
RECESSION THE EFFECTS OF THE
RECESSION ARE MASSIVE ON PEOPLE
AND THE STATE'S BUDGET. AND IN
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE STATE'S
HISTORY WE KNOW THAT THE NILE
AND DELAY. LIMITS BUDGETARY
CHOICES. AND THE EXTRA CASH
CRISIS THAT INJECTS MORE
UNCERTAINTY RIGHT WHEN PEOPLE
NEED. THE GOVERNMENT THE MOST.
DUE TO PRUDENT FISCAL
MANAGEMENT THE STATE IS FACING
THIS CRISIS IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TO CONTEND WITH THESE
CHALLENGES. BUT BALANCING THE
STATE'S CURRENT SPENDING NEEDS.
AND HOW TO PAY FOR THEM WILL BE
DIFFICULT. THIS YEAR AND THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. AND EVEN UNDER
THE MAY REVISION DEFICITS
REMAIN. THE BUDGET ENACTED THIS
YEAR NEEDS TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS TO REDUCING THE
STRUCTURAL SHORTFALLS TO AVOID
THE FINANCIAL THE YEARS OF
FINANCIAL DISTRESS THAT PRIOR
RECESSIONS HAVE BROUGHT TO THE
STATE. FINALLY I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT ONLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THE CAPACITY TO
REALLY MITIGATE THE MOST
DIFFICULT REDUCTION STATES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE TO BALANCE THEIR
BUDGETS. IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. AND CALIFORNIA HAS
REQUESTED ONE TRILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERALLY FOR ALL STATE. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE
NATION TO MAINTAIN CORE
SERVICES OF GOV THE COURT BACK
FOR SERVICES OF GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO MAKE PRUDENT FISCAL
DECISIONS BUT GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE CRISIS. FOR
THE STATE AND THE ENTIRE
NATION. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MUST TAKE ADDITIONAL ACTION.
AND I WILL AND ABOUT HERE TODAY
AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MR PANIC. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
EXPRESS MY THANKS TO THE
SPEAKER INTO THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR FOR INVITING OUR OFFICE
TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
IMPORTANT HEARING. IT AS A
REMINDER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. IS YOUR
NONPARTISAN FISCAL AND POLICY
ADVISER. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT JUST TO POINT OUT
THAT IN RECENT WEEKS IF YOU
WERE TO GO TO OUR WEBSITE AT
THE LA- DOT CA DOT GOV YOU
WOULD SEE THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED TO NEW LANDING
PAGES ONE IS DEDICATED TO OUR
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
ANALYSES. AND THEN THE OTHER
ONE IS OUR NEIGHBOR VISION
ANALYSIS. AND I'D ALSO JUST
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO REMIND YOU THAT WE ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUAL
BRIEFINGS TO YOU. ON THOSE OR
ANY OTHER TOPICS THAT MAY BE OF
INTEREST TO YOU. TODAY IT
WOULD. BE NICE MY REMARKS INTO
TWO BROAD CATEGORIES. THE FIRST
IS I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE A
SOMEWHAT DESCRIPTIVE OVERVIEW
OF HOW ARE OFF HOW ARE OFFICE
VIEWS THE GOVERNOR'S NAY
REVISION. AND THEN SECOND-
OFFER SOME SUMMARY OF- ELADIO
COMMENTS IN AND OUR ASSESSMENT
OF IT. SO HOPEFULLY WE HAVE THE
SLIDE DECK AND IF YOU MOVE TO
THE FIRST PAGE. I'LL GET RIGHT
TO IT HERE WE HAVE THE
TRADITIONAL SUMMARY OF THE
GENERAL FUND CONDITION AND THIS
IS PRESENTED. REFLECTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISIONS SO
THIS IS INCLUSIVE OF THE FORTY
ONE BILLION DOLLAR DECLINE IN
REVENUE SINCE JANUARY DECLINE
IN THE REVENUE ESTIMATE SINCE
JANUARY THAT- THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE JUST MENTIONED. AND
THEN IT ALSO INCORPORATES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED- CHOICES
AND THE CHOICES HE MAKES TO
PROPOSED TO CLOSE TO THE BUDGET
GAP THAT RESULTS FROM THAT
DECLINE IN REVENUE. MOVING TO
THE NEXT PAGE SLIDE TO- THIS
SLIDE ILLUSTRATES BOTH THE
BUDGET PROBLEM AND THE VERY THE
GOVERNOR'S MIX OF PROPOSED
SOLUTIONS. FOR HOW TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET PROBLEMS. IF YOU
LOOK AT THIS TABLE AT THE FAR
BUT THE FAR LEFT THE LARGE
COLUMN REPRESENTS THE FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE BUDGET FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET PROBLEM. AND THEN AS YOU
MOVE RIGHT ACROSS THE SLIDE THE
SMALLER BARS REPRESENT HOW WE
CATEGORIZE THE DIFFERENT
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS FROM THE
GOVERNOR. TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
BIT OF- PERSPECTIVE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS THE FAR UPPER
RIGHT HAND CORNER HAS USE
FEDERAL FUNDS WE COUNT ABOUT
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION IN
THAT CATEGORY AND THAT'S THE
SMALLEST BAR ON THIS
PARTICULAR. PRESENTATION OF THE
MATERIAL AND IT'S ABOUT 7% OF
THE TOTAL SOLUTIONS. THE
LARGEST BAR ON HERE IS THE
ADJUSTMENT TO K. FOURTEEN
EDUCATION SPENDING. AND IT
REPRESENTS ABOUT FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OR 28% OF THE
TOTAL PROPOSED SOLUTIONS. I'LL
SPEAK TO THAT I'M IN A BIT MORE
IN A MOMENT. THE NEXT SLIDE
PAGE THREE. IS REALLY THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT IS ON THE
PREVIOUS TABLE BUT IT'S JUST
THE NUMERICAL BACK UP SO I
WON'T SPEND TIME ON THIS SLIDE
BUT I WANTED TO PROVIDE IT. FOR
YOUR REFERENCE. SO MOVING ON TO
PAGE FOUR REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE QUE
THIS IS FOR A DECADE TELL
KINDERGARTEN TO TWELFTH GRADE-
EDUCATION PROPOSAL IN
PARTICULAR. SO IS- AS WAS
MENTIONED TO ME A REVISION DOES
PROPOSED TO REDUCE THE LEVEL OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING TO THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE- AND THIS WOULD
ABSENT ANYTHING ELSE THAT WOULD
RESULT IN ABOUT A SIX BILLION
DOLLAR YEAR OVER YEAR DECLINE
IN FUNDING FOR THE- K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. FROM THE CURRENT YEAR
TO THE BUDGET YEAR. HOWEVER THE
NAY REVISION DOES INCLUDE
VARIOUS OFFSETTING. PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD MITIGATE THE THOSE
REDUCTIONS I WAS ALREADY
MENTIONED BUT THESE INCLUDE THE
USE OF ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND ALSO THE USE OF DEFERRALS
WHICH ENABLE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SPEND IT AT A
LEVEL HIGHER THAN THAN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE.THE NET
EFFECT OF THESE ADJUSTMENTS ARE
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CHANGES FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
ACTUALLY K. TWELVE SPENDING IS
RELATIVELY FLAT FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR TO THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES THIS
NEW SUPPLEMENTAL OBLIGATION
THAT WOULD BE PAID TO THE
SCHOOLS OVER THE SUBSEQUENT
YEARS. THE FIFTY GOING TO PAGE
FIVE. THIS SLIDE SUMMARIZES THE
CORVETTE NINETEEN RELATED
FUNDING. BOTH THE AMOUNTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN EXPENDED AND
IN ADDITION THE PROPOSED AMOUNT
OF SPENDING IN THE MAY REVISION
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THIS TABLE
THE TOP PORTION SUMS TO ABOUT
TWO POINT TWO BILLION THOSE ARE
THE FUNDS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN EXPENDED AND THEN AT THE
LOWER HALF OF THE TABLE THIS IS
WHAT IS PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION. THE DIRECT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES FOR THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION- WERE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION AND INITIALLY
WE HAD VERY LITTLE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT THOSE. PROPOSALS
ENTAILED. ALTHOUGH WE RECENTLY
RECEIVED A FINANCE LETTER THAT
PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
LIMITED INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE.
AND THEN YOU'LL SEE HERE THAT
THE GIRL IS PROPOSING THIS
COVERT NINETEEN CONTINGENCY
FUND THAT WOULD BE A TWO POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLAR FINE. AND
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
USE CONTROL SECTION LANGUAGE
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
EXPENDITURES FROM THAT FUND. SO
MOVING ON TO SORT OF THE LA-
ASSESSMENT OF THE PACKAGE AND
THE SITUATION TO BEGIN WITH. I
WOULD NOTE THAT ON MAY EIGHTH
OUR OFFICE PUBLISHED A- SPRING
FISCAL OUTLOOK. AND YOU KNOW
THIS IS ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL FOR OUR OFFICE WE
TYPICALLY PUBLISH AN OUTLOOK IT
IN NOVEMBER BUT USUALLY NOT ONE
IN THE SPRING BUT GIVEN HOW
MUCH HAS CHANGED SINCE JANUARY
WE FELT THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATED
ASSESSMENT OF THE BUDGETARY
BASS LINE. FOR YOU EVEN IN
ADVANCE OF RECEIVING THE MAY
REVISION. AND CONSIDERING THAT
THERE IS SO MUCH UNCERTAINTY
OUT IN THE ECONOMY AND IN IN
THE WORLD IN GENERAL WE
DEVELOPED OUR- SPRING OUTLOOK
OR FISCAL OUTLOOK USING TWO
SCENARIOS. ONE WE WERE CALLING
THE U. SHAPED RECESSION WHERE
THERE'S A DOWNTURN IN AND IN
THE COMING MONTHS THE ECONOMY
EXPERIENCES A STRONGER KIND OF
MORE ROBUST TYPE OF RECOVERY.
AND IN THAT SCENARIO THE STATE
WOULD BE FACING AN EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET PROBLEM.
THE OTHER SCENARIO WE
CONSIDERED WAS SLIGHTLY
PESSIMISTIC IT'S WHAT WE CALL
THE L. SHAPE SCENARIO WHERE THE
ECONOMY WOULD GO DOWN AND THEN
HAVE A MORE PROTRACTED KIND OF
A SLOWER TYPE OF RECOVERY. AND
IN THAT IN THAT SCENARIO THE
BUDGET PROBLEM IS THIRTY ONE
BILLION. NOW IN BOTH OF THESE
SCENARIOS THE MAIN DRIVER OF
THE BUDGET PROBLEM IS A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN
REVENUES. IN ARE YOU SHAPE
SCENARIO IT'S A TWENTY SIX
BILLION DOLLAR REVENUE DECLINE
FROM JANUARY ESTIMATES. AND IN
THE- SHAPE SCENARIO IT'S A
THIRTY NINE BILLION DOLLAR
REVENUE DECLINE FROM THE
JANUARY ESTIMATES. AN IMPORTANT
THING TO NOTE ABOUT THAT IS
THAT THE THIRTY NINE BILLION
DOLLAR REVENUE DECLINE IN OUR
BILL SHEA SCENARIO IS ACTUALLY
QUITE SIMILAR IN THE BIG
PICTURE TO THE GOVERNOR'S.
FORTY ONE BILLION DOLLAR
REVENUE DECLINE IN THE MAY
REVISION. AND AS THE DIRECTOR
OF FINANCE JUST MENTIONED THE
MAIN DIFFERENCE IN OUR-
ULTIMATE BUDGET PROBLEM
ESTIMATES HAVE TO DO WITH HOW
WE MEASURE THE STATE'S
EXPENDITURE BASE. SO MOVING TO
THE NEXT PAGE. YOU KNOW WHETHER
YOU. THINK THE STATE INYO
DEFINED IT AS A THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET PROBLEM
OR A FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
PROBLEM PROBLEM. THE MAIN
MESSAGE OF OUR SPRING OUTLOOK
WAS THAT. WE THINK YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER USING A MIX OF
PROPOSALS A MIX SOLUTION TO
CLOSE THIS BUDGET PROBLEM. AND
IN FACT THAT'S WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING. HE
PROVIDES. A PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES A PRETTY WELL BALANCED
MIX OF SOLUTIONS FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER. THE WE THINK THAT YOU
MAY WANT TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO THOSE TWO SO
THAT THOSE PARTICULAR
COMPONENTS BETTER REFLECT YOUR
PRIORITIES. NOW A COUPLE OF
SPECIFIC. POINTS I WOULD WANT
TO MENTION HERE. ON THE
PROPOSED REVENUE SOLUTIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING THAT THE
STATE AUGMENT ITS REVENUES BY
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION THE TWO
MAIN COMPONENTS OF THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH SUSPENDING THE NET
OPERATING LOSSES FOR BUSINESSES
FOR THREE YEARS AND PUTTING A
LIMIT ON THE TAX CREDITS THAT
CAN BE TAKEN. IN IN THOSE IN
THOSE YEARS. NOW INSTANCE SUMS
IN ONE SENSE THIS IS PERHAPS
MORE APPEALING THAN A BROAD
BASED TAX INCREASE BECAUSE
GENERALLY IT'S VIEWED AS SORT
OF AN ACCELERATION OF TAXES
THAT WOULD BE PAID ANYWAY. SO
IT'S NOT REALLY VIEWED IN SOME
SOME ANALYSES WOULD SUGGEST
IT'S NOT AS BURDENSOME AS A
BROAD BASED TAX INCREASE. ON
THE OTHER HAND. THE CORPORATION
TAX IS KNOWN FOR BEING VERY
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT. AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THE SOLUTIONS RELY
ON THE REVENUE FROM THIS SOURCE
IT BECOMES MORE RISKY TO RELY
ON THAT SOURCE OF REVENUE. IN
ADDITION WE THINK THAT THE MAY
REVISION MIGHT ESTIMATE THESE
THEREVENUE THAT WOULD COME
FROM THESE ACTIONS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT TOO HIGH. SO COULD
BE SOMEWHAT OPTIMISTIC IN OUR
JUDGMENT. WHEN IT COMES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SPENDING
REDUCTIONS WE THINK SOME ARE
PRETTY WELL TARGETED OTHERS
HOWEVER ARE RELATIVELY BLIND
THERE HAVE KIND OF A AN ACROSS
THE BOARD QUALITY TO THEM. SO
I'M THINKING OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGET AND YOU JUST-
BRANCH AND EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION ALL OF THOSE ARE
SUBJECT 210% REDUCTIONS WE
THINK YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
A MORE TARGETED APPROACH IN
SOME OF THOSE AREAS. MOVING TO
PAGE EIGHT I WANTED TO COMMENT
ON THE MULTIPLE YEAR- BUDGET
OUTLOOK HEARD BUDGET CONDITION
AND A KEY MESSAGE AARON IN FULL
AGREEMENT WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THAT THE KEY MESSAGE HERE IS
THAT UNDER ANY SCENARIO THE
STATE WOULD APPEAR TO BE FACING
IS KIND OF A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
THERE'S AN ONGOING BUDGET
PROBLEM. AND WELL THE GOVERNOR
DOES MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS
FRONT IT WOULD REDUCE THE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM OVER THAT.
FOR OVER THE FORECAST YEARS. IT
STILL WOULD LEAVE THE STATE
UNDER THE UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROJECTIONS IT
WOULD LEAD TO STAY WITH A LARGE
DEFICIT IN THE FINAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. NO PART OF THIS IS
BECAUSE OF THAT LARGE
SIGNIFICANT NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
OBLIGATION THAT WOULD BE TO THE
SCHOOLS. THAT WOULD ADD TEN
POINT ONE BILLION TO THE STATE
SPENDING THROUGH IN THE YEARS
OF THE- OF THE OUTLOOK HORIZON.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE SOME COST
SHIFTS IN THE BUDGET SOME OF
THESE INCLUDE CHANGES TO THE TO
THE- PENT SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENTS THAT YOU PROVIDED LAST
YEAR IN THE BUDGET. AND THEY
THAT THE CHANGES THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING ESSENTIALLY HAVE THE
EFFECT OF ACHIEVING SOME
SAVINGS IN THE NEAR TERM BUT AT
THE EXPENSE O CREATING HIGHER
COSTS OVER THE LONGER TERM AND
THAT WOULD CONTRIBUTE TO. A
LONGER TERM STRUCTURAL ISSUE.
NOW WHEN IT COMES TO FEDERAL
FUNDING WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR POLICY MAKERS
TO CONTINUE TO PURSUE- FEDERAL
AID AND TO THE EXTENT WE GET IT
THAT COULD HELP THE PROBLEM-
BUT IN IT'S ALMOST CERTAINLY
THE CASE THAT EVEN IF. FOURTH
EVEN IF FEDERAL ASSISTANCE IS
FORTHCOMING. IT WILL LIKELY BE
LIMITED TERM IN NATURE ONE OR
TWO YEARS AT THE MOST. AND IN
THAT CASE. THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE ONCE AGAIN FACED WITH A
STRUCTURAL ISSUE WHEN THAT
FUNDING BEGINS TO PHASE OUT. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WE THINK
YOU'LL WANT TO BE KEEPING IN
MIND AS YOU CONSIDER THE BUDGET.
FINALLY ON THE LAST PAGE OF MY
PRESENTATION I WANTED TO.
PROVIDE A WORD ON THIS THE
ISSUE OF LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
AND OVERSIGHT. YOUR NECK
JANUARY BUDGET THE GOVERNOR HAD
A LOT OF PROPOSALS AND HE'S
MADE CHANGES TO MANY OF THOSE
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISION.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME HE'S ALSO
RETAINING SOME BIG SIGNIFICANT
POLICY CHANGES INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF A NEW DEPARTMENT
AND THE SIGNIFICANT
REORGANIZATION OF EXISTING
DEPARTMENTS. NOW SOME OF THESE
IDEAS MAY HAVE MERIT. BUT THEY
ARE SIGNIFICANT COMPLEX MULTI
YEAR UNDERTAKINGS IN MANY MANY
INSTANCES. AND CONSIDERING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WAS ON RECESS
FOR PART OF THE SPRING. AND YOU
ARE UNABLE TO HOLD THE SAME
LEVEL OF HEARINGS THAT YOU
WOULD IN A NORMAL YEAR. WE
THINK IT'S REASONABLE THAT YOU
WOULD CONSIDER DEFERRING ACTING
ON THOSE ITEMS MAYBE INTO THE
POLICY PROCESS OR EVEN A
SUBSEQUENT BUDGET YOU. YOU HAVE
A FULLY CONSIDERED THEM. AND
THEN LAST WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PROPOSALS FOR THE COVERT
NINETEEN SPENDING. WE HAVE SOME
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
DEGREE OF LATITUDE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING FROM
THE LEGISLATURE. WE APPRECIATE
THE NEED FOR THE STATE TO. BE
NIMBLE AND ITS RESPONSE TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. BUT
THE PROPOSED USE OF THE CONTROL
SECTION PROVISIONS RISK
UNDERMINING THIS THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY AND ITS
ABILITY TO FULFILL ITS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION. AT A
MINIMUM WE THINK YOU MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER AMENDING THE
LANGUAGE AND SOME OF THESE
CONTROL SECTION PROPOSALS. AND
WE REALLY DO VIEW THIS AS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE IT
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE CORE ISSUE
OF THE BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN
THE EXECUTIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT. AND FOR
THAT REASON WE THINK IT
WARRANTS YOUR ATTENTION. SO
WITH THAT I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AS APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU. BUT MISSED PRODUCT OF
FIRST LET ME JUST START OFF BY
SAYING NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE
GOING TO MEMBER QUESTIONS
MEMBERS WILL EACH BE ALLOWED A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES INTO FOUR
MINUTES WILL INCLUDE THE TIME
TO MAKE YOUR STATEMENT AS WELL
AS THE TIME TO GET YOUR
QUESTIONS ANSWERED SO MY ADVICE
WOULD BE IF YOU WERE GOING TO
DO A STATEMENT AND A QUESTION
TO START WITH YOUR STATEMENT.
AND THEN ALLOW ON THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS ALLOW THEIR QUESTIONS
TO BE ANSWERED MEMBERS WHO ARE
AFTER DEATH PLEASE RETURN MY EX
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT AT THEIR
DESKS IN THE BACK PLEASE LET US
SERGEANT NOTE THAT YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO BE GETTING ME THAT-
THOSE NAMES IN ORDER- I'M GONNA
DO MY BEST TO RECOGNIZE PEOPLE
AS YOU RAISE YOUR HAND A RAZOR
MIKE I AM WOULD ALLOW MISTER
OBERNOLTE- THE OPENING REMARKS
AS WELL AS IN THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THAT HE MAY HAVE. I
HAD A COUPLE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. IF I COULD START.
BY THE FIRST QUESTION IS I WANT
TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO THE COMMENTS THAT
MISTER PATRICK I JUST MADE
REGARDING LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND TO BE CLEAR WE HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST WITH THE
GOVERNOR. BUT ALSO THE
GOVERNOR'S ASKING FOR
EXTRAORDINARY ABILITY TO
ALLOCATE. SOURCES OUTSIDE OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I'M
WONDERING THE SPECIFICALLY THE
CONTROLLING WHICH IS SECTIONS
ELEVEN POINT. EIGHTY SIX ELEVEN
POINT NINETY AND THE MAY
REVISED WHAT. DOES THE
DEPARTMENT SEEK TO ACCOMPLISH
THERE THAT YOU DON'T FEEL COULD
BE ACCOMPLISHED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. YES SO I
MEAN AND SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO THE CONTROL SECTIONS AROUND
THE FEDERAL FUNDS- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE'VE
BEEN HAVING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS. WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE. STAFF ABOUT HOW TO
MODIFY THOSE TO INSURE THAT
THERE'S OVERSIGHT. THERE'S BEEN
SO MUCH CHANGE IN THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE ESPECIALLY AROUND THE
CORONA VIRUS RELIEF FUND- IT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD AND
FLEXIBILITY INCLUDING THE WEEK
OF THE BUDGET RELEASE THERE WAS
EVEN NEW- GUIDANCE THAT STILL
HAS NOT BEEN MEMORIALIZED IN
ANY KIND OF WRITTEN FORMAT.
THAT WE COULD UTILIZE THE
CORONA VIRUS REALLY FUNDS TO
ACTUALLY- MATCH THE FEMALE AT
THE FEMALE AS THE STAFFORD ACT
EXPENDITURES SO. GIVEN THAT WE
WEREN'T REALLY COMPLETELY SURE
ABOUT HOW WE WOULD ALLOCATE
THOSE MONIES WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE GUIDANCE FROM THE U. S.
TREASURY THAT'S VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT WHAT HOW IT NEEDS TO BE
SPENT- WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WAS OF SUFFICIENT
FLEXIBILITY. I THINK WE'VE
ALREADY LOOKED AT MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A NOTIFICATION
PERIOD PROP- AT NOTIFICATION A
BUILT IN TO THOSE AFFECTS. SO
THAT THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
WHAT THE FINAL OUTCOME IS THAT
THAT THAT THAT ONE PIECE- THE
CROWN OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT'S HAS SUCH A
DIFFERENT ARC THANMANY
EMERGENCIES. YOU KNOW A-
EARTHQUAKE A FLOOD TIRES WITH
EXPERIENCE THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THEY USUALLY ARE HAPPENS
OVER THE PERIOD OF THE DAY ARE
YOU DAYS OR- A COP WEEKS THIS
IS A DISASTER AT THAT THAT
SPENDING MUCH LONGER AND SO I
THINK THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH IN A LOT OF GOOD
CONVERSATIONS. OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS ABOUT HOW AND AS- HOW
THAT THE HOW THIS IS DIFFERENT
AND HOW IT FRANKLY IT IS STILL.
REALLY THE SAME. EVERYTHING
THAT THE GOVERNOR- THE ACTIONS
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN AND ALSO
WHAT I HAVE ARE. AND HAITIANS
THAT PROVIDE. ALL BASED ON
STATUTE AND SPECIFICALLY THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT THEN HE
CONTROL. SECTIONS THAT ARE
EMBEDDED IN THE BUDGET THE
ANNUAL BUDGET ACCESS GOVERN.
THE WRITTEN Q. THAT WE MAKE.
ALLEGED WHICH ARE ALL OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWED. BUT WE ALSO
HEAR AND UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH YOU KNOW AND
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT MORE
EXECUTIVE ACTION HERE THAN
MAYBE AND PRIOR LONG
EMERGENCIES. LIKE OF LIKE THE
DROUGHT FOR EXAMPLE THE DROUGHT
EMERGENCY DID LAST FOR SEVERAL
YEARS- BUT IT WAS IT WAS STILL
MORE GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED
THAN THIS EMERGENCY IS. SO A
LOT OF REALLY UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I THINK ARE
CAUSING A LOT OF- GOOD. DEBATE
BUT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD MAINTAIN
THAT THE POWERS OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACTOR
ABSOLUTELY FUNDAMENTAL. TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH BEEN ABLE TO
TAKE ACTION SWIFTLY TO. PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND- PUBLIC SAFE.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT AND THAT THE DEBATE AND
BALANCE THAT I THINK- WILL HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
ON. AS WE PUT TOGETHER THIS
BUDGET THANK YOU VOTE I AGREE
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
THAT THIS IS THE START OF A
DISCUSSION. AND I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR THAT WE
WANT TO PRESERVE OUR ABILITY.
TO EXERCISE OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE ARE EXPECTED
TO. ABA A SECOND QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU REGARDS THE TITLE
TWELVE LOANS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
RECENTLY TAKEN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SHORE UP OUR
STATE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM. SO WHAT IS THE
DEPARTMENT'S THINKING ABOUT HOW
THOSE LOANS ARE GOING TO BE
REPAID I KNOW THAT THE CARE IS
ACT MAKES THOSE LOANS. FREE FOR
THE TIME BEING WHICH IS YOU CAN
WHICH IS HELPFUL BUT IT DOES
NOT HELP US PAYING THAT ACT AND
SO I'M WONDERING WHAT HOW THE
YEAH I KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE TRACKING VERY CLOSELY AND
THAT. WE'RE VERY CAN ABOUT- AND
THE NUMBER OF UNEMPLOYMENT.
PEOPLE ON A PLANE EMPLOYMENT IS
REALLY AS- AT NUMBER- SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE HAS NOT SEEN
BEFORE. UNDERTHE LAST
RECESSION WE DID HAVE TO TAKE
OUT MULTIPLE TENS OF BILLIONS
OF LOANS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WE DID THAT. AND
WE DID REPAY THAT- OVER TIME.
AND THOSE INTEREST COSTS- WOULD
IT WORK OUT BORN BY THE STATE.
LATE CHECK A CLEAR THOUGH
WITHOUT GOING INTO COLLOQUY
RIGHT AND THAT HAS A WE
REPEATED. THE STATE REPAIRS
RIGHT AT THE EMPLOYERS OF THE
STATE RIGHT- FORCED RIGHT PAY
THE PRINCIPAL THE SAME TIME.
THERE IS A MECHANISM IT'S
CALLED THE FOOD THAT. THAT IS
THAT AS- BUSINESSES THAT. THE
NUMBER OF YEARS IN WHICH THAT
THE LOAN IS OUTSTANDING- ONE
THING THAT WAS IN THE CARE IS
ACCESS. THAT THE EXTENSION OF
THE INTEREST FREE UNTIL
DECEMBER IS ABSOLUTELY HELPFUL.
WE WOULD LIKE A MUCH LONGER
PERIOD OF INTEREST FREE LOANS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THIS TIME GIVEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY. STRESS ON ALL
AND EMPLOYMENT SYSTEMS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA- WE WILL
BE WORKING THERE IS A DELAY IN
TERMS OF THE TIME IN WHICH IT
REQUIRES THE STATE TO PAY BACK-
WITH INTEREST THOSE LOANS- BUT-
THAT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT.
THAT THAT IT WILL BE EITHER ON
THE GENERAL FUND OR IN YEARS
PAST THE STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND ABLE TO MAKE
SOME OF THOSE INTO. BY THE-
PAYMENTS THE SOME AT. FIND I'M
SO THOSE WILL BE TYPES OF
THINGS THAT THE STATE WILL BE.
WITH FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL. AND
ALSO BE MINDFUL OF THE IMPACT
ON BUSINESSES AROUND SO THAT
THAT'S THE INTEREST AND THE
PRINCIPAL. AND THE PRINCIPAL IS
IT'S ALL IS ALL A PART OF THAT
THE TAX THE TAXES ON BUSINESSES
THAT THAT SUPPORT THAT PROGRAM
RIGHT SO DOES THE STATE INTEND
TO PAY THAT BACK OR IS THE
INTENT WELL THERE IS A-
PROPOSAL IN THE MAY REVISION.
DO THAT AT THIS POINT POINT
WE'RE TAKING LOANS AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO MAKE-
UNEMPLOYMENT PAYMENTS FOR- BUT-
AND WE WILL BE ADVOCATING FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF INTEREST.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE DEBT
THAT WILL BE- TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WERE HOPEFUL OF
CONTINUING. SHARES FOR THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIRST AND
WHEN ASKED DOCTOR ARAMBULA TO
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
CARE TANG AND MEMBERS I WANTED
TO START MY COMMENTS OFF TODAY
BY RECOGNIZING THE INCREDIBLE
LOSS OF LIFE THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS AN INCALCULABLE
LOSS AS THE NEW YORK TIMES HAS
CALLED IT IN SUNDAY'S PAPER. AS
A DOCTOR I KNOW THAT EVEN ONE
LIFE IS A LIFE IS ONE LIFE LOST
IS ONE LIFE TOO MANY. NEARLY
OVERNIGHT WE LEARNED THAT WE
HAD TO CHANGE OUR BEHAVIORS.
AND TO DO THAT WE DID IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WOULD
MINIMIZE FURTHER LOSS OF LIFE.
I AM PROUD THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
TOOK DECISIVE ACTION TO FLATTEN
THE CURVE AND THAT WE AS THE
STATE AS WELL AS OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TOOK SWIFT ACTION
TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS. IS THAT NOW WE
SHOULD BE THE ENTRUSTED PEOPLE
BY THE PUBLIC TO HELP TO
PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE. THE
FORESIGHT AND THE ASSISTANCE
THAT IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES EMERGE STRONGER
THAN EVER. THE HARSH REALITY IS
THAT ARE THE THIS PANDEMIC HAS
QUICKLY ERODED OUR RESERVES. IT
IS DECIMATED OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. IT IS FORCED HARD
WORKING PEOPLE OUT OF A JOB. IT
IS CREATED REALITIES FOR OUR
WORKING PARENTS WHO ARE NOW
FORCED TO HOME SCHOOL THEIR
CHILDREN HOME. IT IS
EXACERBATED DISPARITIES AND
INEQUITIES. THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS HAVE
ALREADY FELT. LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS I HEARD IN THE LA L. FROM
FINANCE AND MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT OUR
RESPONSE HAS BEEN TO THE COPA
NINETEEN CRISIS. AND WHAT WE
LEARNED EARLY ON IS THAT WHILE
RESPONSE WAS NECESSARY RECOVERY
WILL BE VITAL. NOT ONLY MEDICAL
RECOVERY FROM COVERT NINETEEN
BUT ECONOMIC RECOVERY THAT WILL
HELP US MOVE FORWARD AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. AND GET OUR
BUSINESSES BACK ONLINE AND OUR
CHILDREN BACK IN THE CLASSROOM.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT AS
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES THAT MY
PRIORITIES WILL ALWAYS BE IN
PROTECTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AMONG THEM THE
CHILDREN THE DISABLED
IMMIGRANTS AND OUR ELDERS. I AM
PROUD THAT IN RECENT YEARS ARE
PAID AS PRIORITIZE THE
EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE FOR
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
FIRST FOR HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
KIDS NEXT HEALTHCARE FOR ALL
YOUNG ADULTS IN THIS YEAR.
BILLS ARE FOR THE INTEL WILL
PRO HAVE ALSO HELPED US TO
STRENGTHEN CAL WORKS. FOR
FAMILIES. AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO INVEST IN
OUR HEALTH CARE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTING TO BRING MUCH NEEDED
DOCTORS AND NURSES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND INCREASING
PREVENTATIVE HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS THAT IMPROVE HEALTH
CARE OUTCOMES. ALL OF THIS WORK
HAS CREATED RESILIENCY IN OUR
STATE AND WE CANNOT LOSE THAT
RESILIENCY. MEMBERS AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW MY HOME DISTRICT IS
ONE OF THE POOREST IN THE
STATE. WE ARE BLESSED WITH A
CAN DO ATTITUDE A RICH
DIVERSITY OF CULTURES AND THE
BEST PRODUCE IN THE WORLD. BUT
WE ARE STILL RECOVERING FROM
THE LAST RECESSION AND FROM
DECADES OF BUILT IN
DISPARITIES. IN MANY WAYS WE
ARE NOT ONLY THE GEOGRAPHIC
CENTER OF OUR STATE. BUT WE ARE
ALSO THE EPICENTER OF THE
ECONOMIC AND MEDICAL WELL BEING
OF OUR STATE. AND THAT IS WHY I
URGE US TO LOOK FOR RESILIENCY
THAT WILL CARRY US THROUGH THE
REVENUE LOSSES- PART OF
AGENCIES. THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES BADLY. I OR JUST
SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT WILL UP
LIFT ALL WORKING FAMILIES SUCH
AS THE INCLUSION OF KELLY ITC
IMMIGRANTS. FOR OVER DOLE AND
SMALL INVESTMENTS. BEHIND WHAT
MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE CARE OF
ALL OF OUR FAMILIES IN THIS
BUDGET THIS IS A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL AFTER ALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MR
MCCARTY. SIX THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MISTER BUDGET CHAIR YOU
KNOW THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT
VOTE DIFFICULT CHOICES BUT
THERE ARE LASTING IMPACTS WE
MUST GRAPPLE WITH THIS KIT
PANDEMIC HAS GREAT HISTORIC
TIME FOR A PUBLIC EDUCATION ASK
US TO RETHINK WHAT ARE MOST
WHAT ARE MOST CRUCIAL ELEMENTS
OF OUR ECONOMY OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AS THEY IMPACTS SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FROM CHILD
CARE PRESCHOOL K. TWELVE AND
COLLEGE AND WE KNOW THAT RE
OPENING OUR SCHOOLS IN CHILD
CARE CENTERS ARE CRITICAL TO RE
OPENING OUR STATE ECONOMY AND
THAT'S THE QUESTION I'LL GET TO
IN A BIT. THESE THINGS ARE
LINKED TOGETHER AND THE MAY
REVISE WE SEE PROP AND EIGHT
DOLLARS DROP FROM EIGHTY ONE
BILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR TO
SEVENTY BILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THIS MEANS THAT A ONE TIME
LEFT IN OUR BUDGET WILL ONLY BE
THE ANY WHAT'S THE TO PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS SO WE ASK THE
QUESTION IS THIS BUDGET ENOUGH
TO RE OPEN ARE CAUGHT. AND OUR
K. TWELVE THIS IS HAS BEEN WE
WORKING OVERTIME TRYING TO MAKE
IT WORK FOR STUDENTS FAMILIES
AND TEACHERS FACULTY. AND WE
HAVE TO GET CREATIVE FACT.
OPENERS SO WHAT THE ALONG
RECOVERY. THE NEW NORMAL. OF
NEW TO SET A- DISTANCE. AND IN
PERSON AS WELL. AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY KIDS
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. 20% OF OUR
KIDS YOUR TWO THOUSAND KIDS
NEARLY 10% OF OUR STUDENTS. ARE
MISSING A WALL THEY HAVEN'T
APPEARED ONCE. DURING THIS
DISTANCE LEARNING PERIOD. WE
KNOW THESE NUMBERS ARE GREATER
IN SOME OTHER URBAN DISTRICTS.
THE LEARNING LOS BLOCK GRANT
THE BUDGET IS POSITIVE WILL BE
HELPFUL WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
FIX THAT TO MAKE SURE IMPACTS
ALL DISTRICTS AS WELL. WE ALSO
KNOW AS DR GRANT WILL MENTION
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON HOW. MORE
REVENUES COULD COME IN TO HELP
UR SCHOOLS WE NEED MORE MONEY
NOW OUR SCHOOLS. NOT LESS. BY
COMPARISON THE LAST RECESSION
THE FEDERAL ABOUT. HAD ROUGHLY
75% MORE MONIES FOR OUR SCHOOLS
OUT IS THIS CARE ACT SO WE NEED
MORE RESOURCES CUTS. WERE WE-
WHAT THIS WOULD MEAN IF TRIGGER
PULL. FIFTY THOUSAND. TEACH
WOULD LOSE THEIR COULD SLIP ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CLASSIFIED WORKERS
WOULD LOSE THEIR JOBS. AVERAGE
CLASS SIZE WOULD INCREASE BY
TWENTY PERCENT. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND CAN'T HELP OUR
ECONOMY REBOUNDS. ALSO NOTED
THERE'S NO PLAN THIS BUDGET TO
HELP REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE HAVE TO
CLOSE THEM AGAIN WE JUST DON'T
KNOW. AS FAR AS EARLY EDUCATION
THIS BUDGET UNFORTUNATELY THE
MAY REVISED ESTIMATES OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS ON CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL. IT'S A TOUGH CALL
BUT THE RIGHT CHOICE I WILL
KNOW IN THE MAY REVISED TO
REPURPOSE MANY OF THESE
DOLLARS. FROM ONE TIME DOLLARS
FOR EASY- INFRASTRUCTURE THE
PRE SCHOOL EXPANSION TO PROP UP
THE EXISTING CHILD CARE SLOTS
BUT ONE THING WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REJECT AND
THAT'S THE CUTS. TO RATES FOR
BOTH CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. THESE SANDERS FAMILY
BASED PROGRAMS CENTERS WERE
BARELY AFLOAT BEFORE BECAUSE OF
THE NINETEEN. AND WITH THESE
RATE CUTS IT REALLY WILL BE THE
DEATH KNELL TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND THAT MEANS PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR JOBS FOR LONELY WOMEN
WOMEN OF COLOR AS WE KNOW. THE
WHAT IS THIS MEAN TO RE OPENING
OUR ECONOMY. WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN TO HAVING PEOPLE GO BACK
TO WORK THEY'RE BOTH RELATED.
OUR COLLEGES ALSO- FACE TOUGH
CHALLENGES. WE HAVE INCREASED
COST OUR CAMPUSES AT A TIME.
WHEN REVENUES ARE DECREASING
WE'VE SEEN REVENUE CUTS AND
HOUSING AND PARKING SO IT'S A
DOUBLE DOUBLE WHAMMY FOR OUR
CAMPUSES. SO GO BACK TO OUR
REALITY CHECK ON THIS ON THIS
BUDGET. AND MY QUESTION IS WHEN
I WOULD ASK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND LA TO ENTERTAIN.
WITHOUT OPEN SCHOOLS STABLE
CHILD CARE AND ACCESSIBLE
HIGHER EDUCATION CAN WE
REASONABLY REOPEN CALIFORNIA
AND SEE AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
GONNA MISTER BLOOM. START WITH
BARBARA YEAH YOU HAVE TO THE
SCHOOLS QUESTION IS ONE THAT
THAT REALLY KEEPS ME UP AT
NIGHT I HAVE SMALL CHILDREN
MYSELF AND THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS THAT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DOCTORS.
RECOMMEND TO KEEP US ALL SAFE
YOU KNOW ARE ARE HARD TO REALLY
WRAP YOUR HEAD AROUND IN AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT-
BUT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
WITH THAT THE SCHOOL FIELD- TO
PUT FORTH GUIDANCE- TO HELP
REOPEN TO RE OPEN AND GUIDE THE
RE OPENING OF SCHOOLS THIS
FALL- THE FOUR POINT. BILLION
IN FEDERAL FUNDS IN IT THAT WAS
REALLY DESIGNED TO HELP TO
ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY THE
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION THE
NECESSARY STEPS THAT SCHOOLS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A TO
REOPEN SAFELY ENTERTAIN
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL CLICK
CLEANING PROTOCOLS- AND OTHER
AYE AYE GUIDANCE THAT'S REALLY
NECESSARY TO KEEP ALL OF US
SAFE SO- THAT'S I AM YOU KNOW I
THINK WE ARE WE AGREED. THAT
THAT THE SCHOOLS BEING OPEN IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE GOING BE GRAPPLING
WITH- WITH THEIR LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS LOCALLY
AND WE HOPE TO GIVE GUIDANCE
THAT'LL TO PROVIDE A AND HOW
THEY CAN DO IT SAFELY AND
ALLEN'S ALL OF THOSE THINGS BUT
IT'S WHAT THE REALLY BIG
STRUGGLES- AT. THIS PANDEMIC IS
COSTING IT IS ACT ON SCHOOLS
AND THEN THE ENTIRE THAT HAD
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS.
WORK SO THAT. HOW WE REALLY TRY
TO PRIOR. THE SLOT WELL AND
THEN GUIDANCE THE CHILD
FACILITIES AS WELL THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISTER BLOW
UP AND JUST A REMINDER THAT WE
HAVE FOR ME IT'S IT'LL- FOR
YOUR STATEMENT AND A QUESTION.
YOU HAVE. YOUR I'M NOT. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIR MEMBER.
IT'S OFTEN THAT ARE BUDGETS ARE
NEXT OF OUR VALUE AND APHORISM
HAS NEVER BEEN APPARENT NO MORE
IMPORTANT THAN NOW AS WE SEEK
TO ADDRESS THE BUDGETARY FALL
OUT OF A PANDEMIC THAT IS A
HEALTH ECONOMIC SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS. LET
US BEAR IN MIND THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS ITS ROOTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WARMING
CLIMATES CONSTRAINTS ON HABITAT
AND BIO BIO DIVERSITY LEGAL AND
ILLEGAL TRADE IN WILD ANIMALS
HAVE ALL PLAYED A ROLE. SO I'M
FRUSTRATED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES. NOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT TOUGH CUTS ARE NEEDED AND
WE ALL HAVE TO DO WITH LESS.
BUT WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS
EIGHTY FUNDING OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS AND WE CAN'T FORGET
THAT IN THESE PERILOUS TIMES TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN CRISIS. HAS
BEEN HARDER ON THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY SUFFERING FOR EXAMPLE
WITHOUT ACCESS THOSE WITHOUT
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER AND CLEAN
AIR. THE MAY REVISION CONTAINS
NUMEROUS FUND SHIFTS AND LOANS
IN ORDER TO RELIEVE PRESSURE
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE PROPOSAL'S
PLACE US IN A POSITION WHERE WE
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN CLEAN
AIR OR WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
AND A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
THIS IS PLANTING THE
SUPPLANTING OF GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES. WITH EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
ACCOUNT. THIS ACCOUNT IS FOR
THE REMEDIATION OF AIR
POLLUTION. NOT TO FIX OUR
GENERAL FUND CASH FLOW PROBLEM
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THE PROPOSED
ROLLBACK OF THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND WHICH
EARMARKED IN MARCH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR A
VARIETY OF CONSERVATION
EFFORTS. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COUPLING THIS ROLL BACK WITH
THE SHIFT OF EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FROM THE WILD
LIFE CONSERVATION BOARD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND IN THE FACT THEY'RE SAYING
WE EITHER GIVE THIS MONEY THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD OR
WE GET THIS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND- WELL
I THINK THE F. W. CERTAINLY
NEEDS ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
TAKING FROM ANOTHER SISTER
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTING
COMPLIMENTARY WORK IS SIMPLY
NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH AND
FINALLY WHILE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO BECOME
RESILIENT TO THE CHANGING
CLIMATE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING A THIRTY THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION BASELINE.
REDUCTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND A
REDUCTION TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT WHICH IS A
PROGRAM TO BRING GETTING TO
BRING OUR GROUNDWATER TABLE
BACK INTO BALANCE. I WORRY THAT
THESE FUNCHESS AND REDUCTIONS
WILL HAVE AN OVERALL REGRESSIVE
IMPACT ON ALL OF OUR CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL EXPENDITURES
EFFORTS AND SUCCESSES. MEMBERS
I SHARE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WILL BE EXPRESSED ABOUT
OTHER AREAS OF OUR BUDGET. AS
WE APPROPRIATELY FOCUS
ATTENTION AND BUDGETARY
RESOURCES ON IMPORTANT ISSUES
LIKE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
EDUCATION PUBLIC SAFETY AND
HEALTH. I HOPE THE AT THE ADMIT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
HEED THIS CALL ABOUT THE MANY
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED ABOUT THE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO DO ON
BEHALF OF THE HEALTH. AND
INDEED THE FUTURE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S RESIDENTS
AND IT'S NATURAL RESOURCES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH OTHER
MISTER COOPER. MEMBERS SEVERAL
ISSUES IN THE PURVIEW OF BUDGET
SUB FOR RESEARCH POLICY AND
PROCESS CONCERNS THE MAY
REVISED CONTAINS A NUMBER O
PROPOSALS TO CREATE NEW STATE
DEPARTMENTS REORGANIZED
EXISTING STATE DEPARTMENTS IS
PROPOSALS IN X. NEVER GET
POLICY CHANGES. THE
LEGISLATURE'S NOT HAD
SUFFICIENT TIME TO CONSIDER
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSALS FOR
TOO MUCH AUTHORITY THE NEW
DEPARTMENT WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
LEGISLATIVE INPUT AND OVERSIGHT
FOR EXAMPLE THE DV UP THE ONLY-
RECOMMENDS THAT GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE CHANGES
PROPOSALS ARE BEST CONSIDERED
THE LEGISLATIVE POLICY PROCESS
FOR A CLOSE EXAMINATION OF ALL
THE CHANGES. ADDITIONALLY THE
LA- RECOMMENDS NOT APPROVING
FUNDING TO LEGISLATURE MAKE A
DECISION ON THE MERITS OF THE
PROPOSED POLICY CHANGES GIVE
THE DEPRESSED PERIOD OF TIME WE
FACE TO THESE PROPOSALS IT
MAKES SENSE TO CONSIDER THEM
THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE AND NOT
TO RUSH THROUGH THEM. WHILE THE
STATE PLACE ORDERS HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN SLOWING THE
DISEASE AND SAVING LIVES. THE
SAME DAY PLACE ORDERS AND
CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR BAD
PEOPLE TO CARRY OUT. EVIL DEEDS
ON OUR CHILDREN AND WOMEN.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
PROTECTIONS AGAINST CHILDREN.
I'VE ALSO AN INCREASE BUT IS
EQUALLY EVEN MORE CONCERNING IS
INCREASE OF INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN. THE INCREASE
IN REPORTS OF ONLINE CHILD
ABUSE IT SHOULD BE A TO STAY
HOME ORDERS RESULTING IN YOUNG
CHILDREN SPENDING MORE TIME
ONLINE IN FALLING PREY TO ALL
AYE PREDATORS. THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR MISSING EXPLOITED
CHILDREN RECEIVE AN ASTONISHING
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION REPORTS
THROUGH THE CYBER TIP LINE LAST
MONTH ALONE A 3% INCREASE OVER
THE SAME PERIOD LAST YEAR AND
YET THE MAY REVISE THE LEADS
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN TASK FORCES.
THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A MOMENT
VIOLENT SEXUAL CRIMES AGAINST
WOMEN CHILDREN OR DIFFERENT
ONCE THEY'RE VICTIMIZED THEIR
TRAUMA RARELY IF EVER GOES
AWAY. THE BILL THE
VICTIMIZATION. FOR A LIFETIME
YOUR CHILDREN MY CHILDREN ALL
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN ARE NOT A
NEW TO THESE PREDATORS. OUR
CHILDREN YES NOW MORE THAN
EVER. WE CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT
ABANDON THEM AND LEAVE THEM. TO
BE PREYED UPON. NOW THE TIME
NOT TO CUT THROUGH THE PROGRAMS
THAT THE PROJECT THAT PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN FROM ONLNE
PREDATORS. I STRONGLY URGE YOU
MY COLLEAGUES THE GOVERNOR TO
RECONSIDER THESE PROPOSALS AND
MAKE THE RIGHT CHOICE TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN. HEALTH
CARE SIR SHOULD BE TOP PRIORITY
ESPECIALLY DURING PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. PLANNED PARENTHOOD
SERVES THE FIRST AND SOMETIMES
ONLY POINT OF CONTACT. INTO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHICH IS
CRITICAL IN HELPING SPOT THE
SIGNS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS. BUT ON A
PLANE OVER TWENTY PERCENT. MORE
MORE PEOPLE RELYING ON CLINICS
LIKE PLANNED PARENTHOOD FOR
THEIR HEALTH SERVICES. IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALONE PLAYER
PLAYER WHO PROVIDES OVER TWO
THIRDS OF ALL PATIENTS
RECEIVING PUBLICLY FUNDED BIRTH
CONTROL AND HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I REPEAT TWO THIRDS.
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC TO FIFTY SIX
RESULT IN ONE BILLION LOS. IN
WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE SERVICES
FORTY PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO CUT BACK ON
SERVICES OFFERED MAYBE THE
FORCING THE CLOSE OUR DOORS.
RELEASED PATIENTS GO. ACTUALLY
WE HAVE TO SPEAK MORE THE
VISUALS RELYING ON THESE
PROGRAMS. MEMBERS IS RESTORED
TIMES REQUIRE A STORE NEAR YOU
MEASURES ALLOWING LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY IS NOT ONE OF. AS LA-
POINTS OUT IT IS TROUBLED BY
THE DEGREE OF A FORTY THE
MINISTRATIONS REQUESTING. THE
LEGISLATURE DELEGATE. FURTHER
DELAY- STRONGLY URGES
LEGISLATURE THIRTY SECONDS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN A FORTY.
I CANNOT AGREE MORE ENERGY TO
JOIN ME REJECTING THE
SIGNIFICANT POLICY PROPOSALS
AND CUT TO THE HEALTH THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN. AND
MOST VULNERABLE. THANK YOU NEXT
WILL GO TO DOCTOR WEBER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER SPEAKER
AND MR VICE CHAIR- I'M HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT- SUB FIVE. OF
WHAT I WANNA SAY ALSO IN
ADDITION TO THAT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS EVERYONE
IS SAID THESE ARE VERY UNUSUAL
TIMES AND UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
THINGS ARE REALLY BAD WHEN AS
WE OFTEN SAY WHEN AMERICA
CATCHES A COLD. OF THOSE WHO
VULNERABLE GET PNEUMONIA AND
THE RECOVERY IS MUCH GREATER
AND SO AS A RESULT WE WANT TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
OUR BUDGET AND HOW IT AFFECTS.
ALL OF US GENERALLY BUT SOME OF
US MUCH MORE A PROFOUNDLY I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S THOUGHTFUL
LEADERSHIP IN BOLD VISION ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE MAY
REVISIONS INCLUDE CRITICAL
PROPOSALS THAT CONTINUE THE
TRAJECTORY OF IMPROVING PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES FOR THE STATE
INCLUDING THE CLOSURE OF TO
PRISONS AND REALIGNING THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
DJJ TO THE COUNTIES. WITH THE
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS LIST
OF CAPITAL OUTLAY NEEDS WITH
CDC ARE. AND A DECLINING
POPULATION OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS. CLOSING PRISONS IS
NOTONLY PRACTICAL IS
PHYSICALLY FISCALLY NECESSARY.
THIS COMMITMENT TO CLOSE A
PRISON HOWEVER SHOULD BE
REFLECTED IN STATUTES. AND THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE PROVIDED
WITH A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN ON
FUTURE CAPITAL PROJECTS. SO YOU
WON'T FIND OURSELVES FUNDING A
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND THEN
DISCOVERING THAT WE'RE CLOSING
THE SAME PRISON WHERE WE BUILD
NEW. NEW OF ROOFS OR OR
BASICALLY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THESE PRISONS. WE HAVE ASKED
FOR THIS FOR THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WE'VE ASKED FOR A LIST.
AND THE STANDARDS BY WHICH WE
WOULD CLOSE A PRISON WE HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE THAT LIST AND WE
HAVE YET TO KNOW WHAT THE
STANDARDS WOULD BE. IF WE WERE
TO ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT CLOSING
A PRESENT. THE ALIGNMENT OF DJJ
TO THE COUNTIES IS ALSO AN
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED LAST
YEAR. WHILE KEEPING YOU'VE
pIMPORTANT. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROCESS IS DONE
CAREFULLY WITH STAKEHOLDER
INPUT. THE PROGRAM IS OFFERED
THAT IT WILL BE OFFERED IS
ROBUST. AND THAT'S STATE
OVERSIGHT IS MAINTAINED SO THAT
THE JUSTICE THAT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE RECEIVE IS NOT DEPENDENT
UPON WHERE THEY LIVE AT THE
GEOGRAPHY. BUT BASED ON WHAT
THE STATE STANDS AT ART WE
INSURE THAT KIND OF ROBUST
OVERSIGHT AND ROBUST
PARTICIPATION PROGRAMMING TO
EVERY CHILD. WHO UNFORTUNATELY
IS AND THE ROLE OF THE JJ. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PRACTICALLY CAREFULLY RESULT
REALIZE IT DOESN'T RESULT. IN
MORE OF ARGUES BEING CHARGED AS
ADULTS RATHER THAN STATE ONCE
AGAIN GETTING THE CARE AND
SERVICE THAT WE BELIEVE ME.
THIS IS NOT BEEN THOUGHT OUT WE
HAVE NOT HAD DISCUSSIONS WE HAD
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS LAST YEAR.
THAT WOULD NOT FRUITFUL DID NOT
PROVE TO GIVE US THE ACTION WE
NEED AND NOW BEING ASKED IN IN
A MATTER OF MINUTES A SUBURBAN.
BASICALLY MOVE ALL OF OUR THE
DIGITAL JUSTICE DEPARTMENTS TO
THE COUNTY WITHOUT A PLAN WITH
ANY DIRECTION AS TO WHAT IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE. AND THAT
BRINGS US GREAT CONCERN. TO
PROTECT LEGISLATIVE. THE FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS WE HAD IN. WE'VE
OFTEN TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT IS SO ESSENTIAL AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN AS WE HAVE
REDUCES TO. THE PRISON
POPULATION WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
CORRECT AND SOMETIMES THESE.
WERE POSES COME OUT OF. OUT OF
THE BLUE IS AS A RESULT OF THAT
WE DO NOT HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF CONFIDENCE. IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE SPOTTED OUT
CAREFULLY NOT JUST FINANCIALLY
THE PROGRAMMATIC LATE. WE ARE
CONCERNED OF COURSE ABOUT THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL. WE
HAVE NOT BECAUSE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL THE COULD NOT DO
INSPECTIONS BECAUSE IT DID HAVE
STAFFING. SO LAST YEAR WE
FOUGHT TO BASICALLY- STAFF
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL.
AND THEY'VE NOW HARD TO STAFF.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
GET RID OF ALL OF THE STAFF AND
REDUCE THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL. WHICH WE FIND TO BE OF
GREAT CONCERN AS WE TALK ABOUT
CLOSING PRISONS. MORE LIKELY
WOULD GIVE THAT TO AND THEN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. SO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE THINGS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE A HOUSING FOR
PRISONERS LEAVING. AND A NUMBER
OF OTHER THINGS THAT ARE STILL
IN PLACE. I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT OUR COURTS TO LOOK ONCE
AGAIN FUNDED ADEQUATELY. AND
THAT WE DO NOT GET RID OF MUCH
OF THE THINGS THAT REQUIRE
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN THE
DEPENDENCY COOL INSTEAD OF THE
YEAR. OF WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
THINGS IN THE SYSTEM BUT WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
PUBLIC SAFETY. TEL AND IS KNOWN
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE. IN TRYING
TO GET INTO REHABILITATION DOES
KIND OF A THAT IMPORT. WE
CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF THAT IN
THE- OF SIMPLY. A REDUCING THE
BUDGET AND HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
PUSH TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE INCLUDED. IN THE
CUTS. IN THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
ONE THING BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES WAS LA A FOR COMING IN
PRESENTING- BEFORE US MY
QUESTION IS JUST REALLY QUICKLY
ON- THE RATE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE YOU LOOKED
INTO SEEING IF THERE'S GOING TO
BE ANY TYPE OF A REBOUND. AS WE
CAN AS WE BEGIN TO REOPEN THE
ECONOMY PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK.
IF YOU LOOK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING TO BE ANY ANY
REBOUNDING- AND THAT RIGHT AND
EMPLOYMENT RATE TO SEE A DROP-
AND THEN ALSO GIVEN THE CURRENT
SITUATION THE BUDGET AS IS
BEING PROPOSED THAT IN THE MAY
REVISED- IF THE BUDGET WERE TO
PASS AS IS- WHAT WOULD YOU
EXPECT THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE-
TO BE. BEYOND THAT IF EITHER OF
IT THAT I'M BY BOTH OF YOU TO
ANSWER- BUT JUST WANTING IF
THERE'S BEEN ANY THOUGHT INTO
WHAT THAT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE. AS
WE RE OPEN AND THEN WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AT THIS BUDGET
WOULD PASS AS IS. IF THE FATHER.
YES SO WE DO ASSUME THAT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS GOING TO
DECLINE- THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE YEAR I'M OUR FORECAST
ASSUMES THE PEAK THIS QUARTER-
ADD THE SECOND QUARTER OF THE
AT TWENTY TWENTY BUT WE DO
ASSUME THAT IT THAT IT STARTS
TO DECLINE I'M GOING FORWARD AS
THE ECONOMY RE OPENS- OUR
FORECAST DOES NOT ASSUME A
SECOND WAVE IN THE SECOND SET
OF CLOSURES- WE DID WE DID DO
AN EXTENDED SHUTDOWN OF
SCENARIO- BUT THAT IS NOT WHAT
THE BUDGET IS BASED ON- SO I DO
THINK THAT- YOU KNOW WE HOPE
THAT AS THE RE OPENING
CONTINUES- THAT. THAT MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO RETURN
TO WORK- AND WE DO ASSUME- AN
18% OVERALL UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR THE ENTIRE TWENTY TWENTY
YEAR BUT WE'RE ASSUMING THAT
THERE'S A THERE'S A PEAK- THIS
QUARTER- I HAVE OVER TWENTY
FOUR PERCENT- SO IT IS VERY
BLEAK- THAT THOSE ARE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS OF WE HAVE
NOT SEEN IN MODERN HISTORY AND-
AND THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY TO JUST THIS LAST
MONTH THERE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
MIL AND- IF PEOPLE WHO LEFT THE
JOB MARKET THERE'S NOT JUST
PEOPLE WERE FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE. ESSENTIALLY
DROPPED OUT OF THE WORK FORCE
AND ARE NOT NO LONGER LOOKING-
SO THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA THAT EVERYONE IS LOOKING
AT AND REALLY UNDERSTAND- THE
TRUE IMPACT ON EMPLOYMENT AND-
MOTHERS UNCERTAINTY WE DO
ASSUME THAT IT'S GOING TO GET
BETTER. FROM WHERE IT IS TODAY.
AND IN THE- LA OWES ANALYSIS I
WOULD THINK THE MOST COMPARABLE
WOULD BE THE L. SHAPE SCENARIO.
IN THAT CASE WE ALSO THINK THE
SECOND QUARTER THE ONE WE'RE IN
NOW WOULD BE THE PEAK
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. IN THAT IN
THATTHAT IN THIS QUARTER WOULD
BE EIGHTEEN PERCENT- AND THEN
BEGIN TO GRADUALLY TRANSITION
DOWN AND BUT- STILL BY THE END
OF OUR FORECAST PERIOD. WE
WOULD BE STILL AT. DOUBLE DIGIT
10% UNEMPLOYMENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- YOU KNOW A COUPLE
OF IT IS. FOR IS YOU KNOW
DIFFICULTIES WITH IT IS THAT
THE DATA COMING IN. YOU KNOW
ONCE A MONTH AND ITS REPORTING
ON THE PRIOR MONTH SO THERE'S A
LAG. ONE THING WE'RE KEEPING A
VERY CLOSE EYE ON. THE WEEKLY
NEW UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
NUMBERS. AND KEEPING OUR EYE
ON- HOW MANY- TOTAL PEOPLE ARE
STILL ON UNEMPLOYMENT.
INSURANCE BENEFITS AND TO THE
EXTENT WE START TO SEE THOSE
NUMBERS COME DOWN THAT WOULD BE
SOME REASON FOR OPTIMISM. AND
THERE ARE I MEAN I THINK ONE
THING WE'RE FACED WITH AT THIS
TIME IS THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE ECONOMY. COULD HAVE SOME
SOMEWHAT OF A THIRTY THREE A
REBOUND AS AS THE- SUMMER
MONTHS GO ON AND IF YOU BEGIN
TO RE OPEN WE COULD SEE SOME
JOB GROWTH NUMBERS. AND SO THE
TREND MIGHT LOOK MORE FAVORABLE
BUT STILL THE- UNDERLINED LEVEL
OF UNEMPLOYMENT COULD REMAIN
YOU KNOW DRAMATICALLY- HI SO.
THOSE ARE THE ITEMS WERE
WATCHING. AND WHAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT IT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WE'RE NEXT GOING TO
GO TO A MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. JOB AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IS OF COURSE
THOSE OF ITS CENTRAL AND- I
JUST WANTED TO TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF KEY BUDGET ASKS THAT
I THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE THAT DON'T GET LOST IN THE
SHUFFLE- IN PARTICULAR THE
WILDFIRE RISKS ARE STILL WITH
US- I'VE SUBMITTED A TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR REQUESTED
BUDGET SUB THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING GRANTS TO
PURCHASE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WITH THE QUICK MEANT. TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES IN HIGH IN
VERY HIGH FIRE HAS A SEVERITY
ZONES IN BACKCOUNTRY AREAS-
NUMBER TWO- AS WE LOOK AT SOME
OF OUR HEALTH CARE ISSUES WE
CAN'T FORGET THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITH RARE DISEASE- INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF TWO MILLION FOR
PROJECT BABY BEAR BROUGHT US A
LOT OF SAVINGS AS WELL AS THE
NEW HOLDER GNOME SEQUENCING FOR
CHILDREN OF RARE DISEASE WHICH
SAVE MONEY AND THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL TWO
MILLION IN PLEDGING TO OPEN TWO
SITES AND UNDERSERVED AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA TO TREAT AT LEAST A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MORE CHILDREN.
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CURRENT
CRISIS WE NEED TO LOOK AT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND AMONGST
THOSE TWO- OR THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. CALIFORNIA'S
PRISONS ARE OVERCROWDED AND
UNSANITARY MAKING THEM RIGHT
FOR THE SPREAD OF A PANDEMIC.
IN FACT EIGHT OF THE TOP TEN
BIGGEST US CORONA VIRUS HOT
SPOTS OUR PRISONS AND JAILS.
BUT DON'T THINK THAT AN
OUTBREAK BEHIND BARS WILL
REMAIN THE- A SIGNIFICANT
SEGMENT OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION IS AT RESTORING A
DISASTER OPENED THAT MIKE WITH
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE SERVING SENTENCES IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. AND THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE. THEY ARE AT RISK
GOVERNOR NEWSOME CORRECTLY
INCLUDED THOSE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED MOM VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. UNDER NUMBER TWO
OF HIS SIX KING INDICATORS
SLATED FOR PRIORITY FUNDING
PEOPLE HIT HARDEST BY COLD WITH
NINETEEN WHICH WAS ALSO IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORT.
WELL THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ORDER THE RELEASE OF PRISONERS
ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST THAT'S
SMALL SLIVER AND OVERALL
POPULATION HAD JUST WEEKS
REMAINING ON THEIR SENTENCES.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA BY THAT
TIME COLE BUT NINETEEN CASES
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED IN TEN OF
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY FIVE
PRISON. NOTHING SIGNIFICANT THE
SIGNIFICANT HAVEN'T GONE TO
PROTECT THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
TO THE VIRUS. INCLUDING THE
ELDERLY PREGNANT WOMEN PEOPLE
WITH UNDERLYING CONDITIONS IN
THE CORRECTIONS OFFICERS WHO
ARE EFFECTIVELY FIRST
RESPONDERS ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THE PANDEMIC. OVER TWENTY OF
THE STATE'S PRISONS EMPLOYEE AT
LEAST A THOUSAND STAFF THAT
MEANS THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING IN AND OUT EACH DAY. AND
IT BASICALLY ARE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE'VE DEPRIVE
THOSE WE INCARCERATE OF ACCESS
TO BASIC HEALTH CARE AND
VIRTUALLY EVERY SANITARY
PRODUCT RECOMMENDED. TO COMBAT
THE DISEASE AT THE END OF THEIR
SHIFT THE STAFF IS RETURN HOME
TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. SO THIS CRISIS
BRINGS INTO FOCUS THE SERIES
START THAT NATIONAL NATURAL
DISASTERS PANDEMICS PS PS AND
OTHER DISASTERS CAN INFLICT. ON
THE CARS RATED POPULATION AND
JUSTICE OPERATIONS WE CAN'T
STRESS ENOUGH THE IMPORTANCE
THE FOR A ONE TIME. WITH NINE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. THREE LONG TERM
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE DISASTER
READINESS PLAY AND FOR STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. TO
BRING TOGETHER RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO COLLABORATE
WITH CDC ARE AND DEVELOPING
NEEDED SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENTS
INCLUDING PLANNING ON EXACTLY
WHICH PRISONS WOULD CLOSE. IS A
NECESSITY THIS IS BEEN ISSUE
FOR YEARS THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION FOR THE
BENEFIT OF BOTH REDUCING
POPULATION AND EIGHTEEN
CORRECTIONAL STAFF PLANNING.
EVEN AFTER CA NINETEEN HIT
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS REMAIN
SEVERELY OVERCROWDED. AND WE
NEED TO WORK ON THE COSTLY
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE TO FREE
UP STATE FUNDING FOR CRITICAL
REENTRY AND THIS IS CARLA THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NOW THAT'S WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MISTER BROWN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PAYING
MEMBERS. MANY OF US. ON THIS
FORUM SERVED OUR DISTRICTS
DURING A TIME OF INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR. MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUSES HAVE BECOME
THE NORM ALLOWING US TO FRANKLY
NOR THE DIFFICULT DECISIONS
IMPOSED ON MANY OF OUR
PREDECESSORS. MOST OF US ALL
THE FOR ELECTED IN TWENTY
TWELVE. I WAS REVIEWING SOME OF
THESE DOCUMENTS BACK IN TWENTY
TWELVE. NONPROFIT NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND REVENUES RESOURCES
THIS WAS JUST UNDER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR BUDGET. NEARLY
FOUR BILLION TODAY JUST A FEW
YEARS LATER IN THE TIME WE'VE
BEEN. MR BLOOM SAID ARE
SPENDING IS A REFLECTION OF
VALUES. MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
MONICA. THAT'S TRUE HIS
REFLECTION I USE BUT- THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE WITH
DIFFICULT BUDGET YEAR TO MAKE
SOME DIFFICULT BUT PERHAPS GOOD
REFORM. I CONSIDER THE PROPOSAL
PUT BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE BY
THE GOVERNOR AND FINANCE TO
REPRESENT A WORST CASE SCENARIO.
IT MAKES CUTS THAT ARE PERHAPS
MORE PAINFUL THE NECESSARY
WHILE OFFERING LITTLE. IN THE
WAY OF CREATIVE REVENUE
GENERATION CONSERVATION ORDER
FOR. I WAS LOOKING OVER A
SECTION OF THE MAY REVISE THAT
ACTUALLY DEALS WITH THE WATER
BOARD. WHERE THEY'RE ADDING
TWENTY POSITIONS SINCE JANUARY.
THESE ARE DECISIONS MEMBERS WE
NEED TO TAKE A HARD LOOK AT.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. IT'S HARD
TO IMAGINE HOW MOST OF US COULD
EXPLAIN RETURNED OR DISTRICTS
AND TELLING OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE RESPONDED TO THE
BIGGEST HEALTH CARE CRISIS IN
MODERN MEMORY BY CUTTING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
HEALTHCARE. IN OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION. WELL WE ADDED TWENTY
POSITIONS OF THE WATER FOR.
CUTS TO FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS MEDI CAL
BENEFITS MEDICAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS STATE FAIRS OUR SCHOOL
SIMPLY DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL ROLE ALL THESE HAVE
PLAYED IN OUR CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE. AS A CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE I VIEW IT AS PART OF
MY RESPONSIBILITY TO THIS BODY
AND TO MY FELLOW MEMBERS TO
UTILIZE THE INFORMATION
EXPERTISE AT MY DISPOSAL TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
MINIMIZE THE MOST PAINFUL CUTS
INCLUDE THIS BUDGET. I SPENT
THE LAST FEW WEEKS IDENTIFYING
SEVERAL WRIST REASONABLE AND
MEASURED REVENUE GENERATING
OPPORTUNITIES JUST WITHIN OUR
COMMITTEE JURISDICTION. THESE
REVENUE GENERATION PORTLY DO
NOT ADD TO THE TAX BURDEN ON
THE MIDDLE OR WORKING CLASS.
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THESE
ITEMS TODAY. AS MANY BE AWARE.
THE NUMBER OF TEENS USING E.
CIGARETTES HAS SKYROCKETED IN
RECENT YEARS I PLEDGE TO LAST
YEAR ALONG WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS FOR TO RE
EXAMINE HOW THE STATE TAXES YOU
CIGARETTES AND AMENDED MY BILL
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE TO
CREATE PARITY BETWEEN THE TAX
ON REGULAR COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES. AND THE CIGARETTES.
IN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH
SOME OF THE EXPERTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION I WAS
ENCOURAGED WHEN THE GOVERNOR
SAW ABOUT YOU IN THIS ENDEAVOR
AND PROPOSED AN EARLY VERSION
OF THIS FOR TAX IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET. WITH A VALIUM
ADDITIONAL TIME. AND IN. THE
LA- ANOTHER SIDE FOR THE
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL BE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. WE KEEP
THE FIRST IN THE NATION TAX OF
NICOTINE CONCENTRATION WHICH
FOCUSES THE PUBLIC POLICY ON
THE ADDICTIVE ELEMENT OF THESE
PRODUCTS. FOR PROPOSED THAT THE
TAX RATE IS SET AT TWO FORTY
PER FORTY MILLIGRAMS RATHER
THAN THE GOVERNOR'S TWO DOLLARS.
WE ALSO UTILIZING COMMENCE OF
FORTY MILLIGRAMS INSTEAD OF
TWENTY MILLIGRAMS AS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
AVOID REWARDED YOU CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURERS. WHO CREATE SO
CALLED LIGHT VERSIONS OF THEIR
PRODUCTS. UTILIZING THIS NEW
FORMULA IF YOU COULD WRAP UP.
OKAY THIS PROPOSAL LOAN MEMBERS
WOULD RAISE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY MILLION PER YEAR LIKELY
INCREASING OVER TIME. IN
ADDITION TO THAT PROPOSAL WE'VE
IDENTIFIED NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ELIMINATE GAP OF TAX
SUBSIDIES WE HAVE IDENTIFIED.
UP TO TWO BILLION IN SPORTS
WAGERING REVENUE AND SIMPLY BY
TAXING CALIFORNIANS TO WIN THE
LOTTERY SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION
A YEAR THIS CERTAINLY WON'T
SOLVE OUR BUDGET CRISIS MEMBERS
BUT GIVEN THE INCREDIBLE
IMPACTS OF CORONAVIRUS ON THE
BOTTOM LINE THESE PROPOSAL WILL
PROVIDE US THE FLEXIBILITY TO
RESTORE FUNDING AND MAKE
INVESTMENTS WHERE WE NEED THE
MOST THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. MISTER MALL. THE
BILL OF. MAYBE LATER PERFECT-
DOCTOR WHAT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON
JUST A COUPLE OF AREAS IT
APPEARS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND PREVENTION YOU KNOW
DOING SOMETHING SO SOMETHING
ELSE USUALLY SOMETHING REALLY
BAD DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THIS CASE
SPENDING MORE MONEY IN THE LONG
RUN THAN THAN THIS. IN THE LONG
RUN THAN THAT AND THEN THE
SHORT TERM SAVINGS REPORT. AND
FOR ALL THE TALK OF SCIENCE
THESE DAYS WE APPEAR TO BE
IGNORING PURE SCIENCE. IN FAVOR
OF POLITICAL SCIENCE. IT FEELS
LIKE WE JUST DUSTED OFF THE
PLAN FOR THE LAST RECESSION OR
USING THE SAME PLAYBOOK. WE
MADE HUGE MISTAKES. AND WE PLAN
TO REPEAT THEM. THEY'RE ALSO
FEELS LIKE AN OVER DEPENDENCE
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WITH
AN UNPREDICTABLE
ADMINISTRATION. IF YOU'RE AGED
COURT AND DISABLE THIS BUDGET
IS DEVASTATING IT HITS THOSE
WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD IT AND WHO
HAVE THE SMALLEST VOICES. THE
GOVERNORS MAY REVISED
ELIMINATES THE M. S. S. P.
PROGRAMS AND SEE BASS PROGRAMS
MS AS PEACE SERVICE TWELVE
THOUSAND OF OUR OLDEST POOREST
MOST FRAIL SENIORS. WILL
PROVIDING VALUABLE SERVICES TO
HELP KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOMES
RATHER THAN GOING INTO NURSING
HOMES SAVING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND CERTAINLY KEEP
THEM HAPPY HEARING CLOSER TO
FAMILY. THE SEA BASS OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
PROGRAM PROVIDES LOW INCOME
ELDERLY OR DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERVICES. THAT MAXIMIZE
THEIR THEIR INDEPENDENCE AND
PREVENT THEM FROM BECOMING
INSTITUTIONALIZED. THESE FOLKS
ARE SEVERE COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT
LIKE ALZHEIMER'S DEMENTIA AND
DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY. THIS
BUDGET ALSO CUT SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM SO MORE
SENIORS WILL GO HUNGRY. SO
WITHOUT CRITICAL SERVICES AND
FOOD MANY SENIORS WILL HAVE TO
GO IN A NURSING HOMES. WERE
NEARLY 40% OF THE CLUB DEATHS
FROM COVERED NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA OF HAPPENED. AND
YEAH NURSING HOMES ARE WAY MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THESE PROGRAMS
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR PER RESIDENT. AND TO
ADD INSULT TO INJURY BECAUSE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM FUNDING THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO WOULD WATCH OVER THESE
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITHOUT FAMILY MEMBERS.
REPRESENTED AS A SENIOR SENIOR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE HORRIFIED.
THEY'VE BEEN REACHING OUT IN
SOME OF BEEN WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING HAVE BEEN ASKING IS THIS
THE FUTURE. NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT DIABETES. FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE DIABETES AND
46% OF ALL ADULTS ARE ESTIMATED
TO HAVE EITHER PRE DIABETES OR
UNDIAGNOSED DIABETICS. DIABETES
CAN COST STROKE HEART DISEASE
AMPUTATION END STAGE RENAL
DISEASE BLINDNESS AND DEATH.
AND NOW THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE CUTS THE DIABETES
PREVENTION PROGRAM. ACROSS THE
STATE LESS THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND THRE'S A
FEDERAL MASS. PARTICIPANTS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO DEVELOP TYPE TWO
DIABETES BUT IT APPEARS THAT
THE STATE WOULD RATHER JUST ADD
TO THE OVER THREE POINT SIX.
BILLION DOLLARS COST. OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR THE OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEDI CAL
RECIPIENTS WHO ARE DIABETIC.
THIS IS NUTS. THE BUDGET ALSO
CALLS FOR THE ELIMINATION OF
OPTIONAL MEDICAL SERVICES
DENTAL PROCEDURES TO TREAT GUM
DISEASE AND REMOVABLE
APPLIANCES TO REPLACE MISSING
TEETH. BUT I ACTUALLY WHICH IS
SO IMPORTANT A WOUND CARE TO
PREVENT HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
AMPUTATIONS. OPTOMETRIC
SERVICES TO HELP WITH THE
VISUAL THE CLIENTS THAT HAPPEN
WITH DIABETES. THIS IS REALLY
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ALSO
CUTTING NURSE ANESTHETISTS SIR
AND THAT'S WHAT THE SERVICES
WHICH WILL SERIOUSLY AFFECT
MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE NO
ANESTHESIOLOGIST. OR ONES THAT
ACCEPT MEDICARE. AFTER PUSHING
SO HARD FOR THE PASSAGE OF PROP
FIFTY SIX AND REBUILDING OR
MEDI CAL PROVIDER NETWORK WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THE MONEY
SOMEWHERE ELSE THAT WILL
DEVASTATE PROVIDER NETWORKS. SO
WE WILL HAVE ELIGIBILITY WITH
FEWER PROVIDERS AND SERVICES
AND I CAN PRETTY MUCH GUARANTEE
IN THE LONG RUN GO ACROSS THE
STATE AND WAY MORE MONEY. THAN
THIS ADMINISTRATION THINKS IT
WILL SAVE AND PEOPLE WENT UP IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS. WE KNOW WHAT
PREVENTION WORK WE KNOW
PREVENTION WORKS ACROSS THE
BOARD WITH THERE'S HEALTHCARE
WILDFIRES HOMELESSNESS DRUG
ADDICTION I COULD GO ON. IT'S
REALLY THAT SIMPLE SAY THESE
PROGRAMS AND YOU SAVE LIVES AND
MONEY CUT THESE PROGRAMS AND
COSTS WILL INCREASE IN LIVES
WILL BE LOST. WHEN I HAD A
QUESTION PROMISED TO MAKE IT AS
A STATEMENT WHEN I AM REALLY
FRUSTRATED WITH IS THAT. BUDGET
LIMóN IT'S A LOT OF PROGRAM HE
LIMóN IT SOME DOESN'T PUT THEM
ON. I BUT- FOR A RAINY SO OF
THIS IS HARD WHAT POLICY WORK
THAT WE DID HERE AND SOME OF
WITH LAST YEAR SIGNED BY THIS
GOVERNOR. GOING AWAY. NO POTS
THIS IS WRONG. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER LOW THE
MISTER PATTERSON AND THE MISTER
LIVING HELLO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HAVE BUDGET CHAIR TING AND
COLLEAGUES- ONE THIRD OF. ECHO
APPRECIATION TO YOU MISTER
BUDGET CHAIR OF FOR A BEING IN
THIS POSITION GIVEN YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN YOUR A
BACKGROUND- WE ARE VERY PROUD
TO HAVE YOU IN THIS CAPACITY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT- I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE AT NO TO
ASSEMBLY AS ANOTHER COLLEAGUE.
SAY MENTIONED- BEING IN THIS
INSTITUTION WHEN THIS HAPPENED
BEFORE AT APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO TO WHICH I WAS A
STAFF MEMBER AND THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO WHICH THIS
OCCURRED AND- HAD SEEN THE CUTS
AND THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS AS
A LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS. PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT EXISTED WAS
THAT THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY SERVE SIX
YEARS AND THE TERMS AND HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE I WORK NOW WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO THINK LONG
TERM SO WE DON'T HAVE TO KICK
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD AND WE
CAN THINK ABOUT. THE VESTED
FUTURE THAT WILL HAVE AN IMPACT
ON SIMILAR YOU SEEN. HOPE THAT
WE WILL GET FROM THE
MINISTRATION THE WHOLE OTHER
SUPPORT FROM IN FEDERAL
MINISTRATION AND AS ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK
COMMONLY SAYS HOPE IS NOT A
STRATEGY. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON WHAT WE CAN AMONGST
OURSELVES AND I'M VERY PROUD TO
ALSO HERE ARE REPUBLICAN VICE
CHAIR STATE EARLIER THAT WE
MUST PROTECT THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE. I THINK ABOUT THIS
THE COMMUNITY THAT I RESIDE AND
REPRESENT SILICON VALLEY ONE OF
THOSE. WEALTHY READ IN THE
STATE AND IN THE COUNTRY. HOME
TO APPLE. MOST PEOPLE. IN THE
STATE ONE OF MY VALUE COMPANIES
THE WORLD. AND YET THE
CUPERTINO. SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IT'S ON THE BRINK OF COLLAPSE.
SIX STRAIGHT YEARS OF BUDGET
CUTS. SIX STRAIGHT YEARS. NOW
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE IN WHICH
YOU LIVE IN RESIDE IN A TALE OF
TWO COMMUNITIES. NOW WE ALWAYS
SAYS THINK OKAY. THE CALGARY
WILL COME AND SAVE THE DAY I
THINK THAT OFTENTIMES. AND AS I
SIT HERE WITH THIS START
PROJECTIONS WE QUICKLY REALIZED.
THERE IS NO CALORIE. MEMBERS WE
ARE IT. HOW ABOUT HEALTHCARE.
THERE'S THIS. NOTION OF- THE
IMPORTANCE OF HELPING THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN. WITH RESPECT
TO AN ELIMINATION OF A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR MEDI CAL. A
ROMAN NAVIGATOR PROGRAM WHICH
WILL ASSIST THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE GETTING THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED AND IN FACT
CLOSE 290% OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO NOT UTILIZE THIS PROGRAM.
FAIL TO COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION 90% AND YET WITH
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS CUT WE
LOSE AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION. FROM THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS LAW. NOW IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC YOU WOULD THINK
THAT WE WOULD NOT WANT TO LIMIT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE BUT
INCREASES. SO MEMBERS WE MUST.
FOCUS NOW AND HELP IDENTIFY THE
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTS TO HELP
REWRITE THE RULES OF ECONOMY TO
MAKE SURE IT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
REVENUE MEASURES MUST
CONTINUALLY BE ON THE TABLE
YOU'VE HEARD FROM SOME
COLLEAGUES ABOUT REFERENCING TO
OTHER RECORD MANAGERS. AND
AGAIN THINK ABOUT THIS NOTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA DREAM. TO
WHICH IT IS POSSIBLE AS A
FOURTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN.
WELL MY GRANDFATHER NO COLLEGE
EDUCATION WORK AT FRANK THAT.
WAS IT WAS IT FOR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL. ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL YOU
SEE THIRTY SECONDS. AND THEN
THE CREEK SIMILAR OPPORTUNITIES
AND NOW THE MILLENNIAL
GENERATION IS FEELING THE BRUNT
OF THIS. TO WHICH I MYSELF
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
COMMITTEE THAT I REPRESENT. I'M
APPROACHING FORTY YEARS OLD
LIVE IN A THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
CONDO WITH MY BROTHER WHO'S THE
SENATE A POLICE OFFICER. I'LL
NEVER BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO LIVE
IN MY COMMUNITY DON'T FEEL
SORRY FOR THE POLITICIAN THINK
ABOUT THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
TRYING TO ACCESS. SHE PROGRAMS
THAT'S OUR OBLIGATION THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE HERE WE MUST FIGHT
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DO NOT HAVE
A VOICE WE MUST FIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE. THAT CENTERS HERE. AND
WE MUST ALSO FIVE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE
REPRESENTATION HERE. AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE WIDE DIVERSITY OF A
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS. THAT'S WHY
WE'RE ALL HERE I KNOW THAT WE
LIVE UP FAMILIES EACH AND EVERY
DAY BECAUSE- LEAD WITH OUR
HEART. AND AS WE LOOK AT THIS
BUDGET IN CLOSING. THIS THINK.
OF LONG. ACCESS THIS WILL HAVE
NOT THE SHORT TERM BUT LONG
TERM. CAN WAKE UP EACH AN EVERY
DAY THING. WE DID THE BEST THAT
WE COULD. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU. MISTER PATTERSON THE
MISTER LEVINE AND THEN MISTER
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
OUR- ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH THE
DOCTOR WOULD. WITH ALSO MEMBER
LOW. HE TALKED ABOUT THE
CAVALRY. WAITING ON FEDERAL AID
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT COME. AND
WHILE WE WAIT FOSTER YOUTH
RESOURCE FAMILY SENIOR CITIZENS
ARE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
DIRECTLY NOW BEARING THAT
BURDEN. IF THIS FINANCIAL AID
DOES NOT MATERIAL. MATERIALIZE
WHAT IS THE PLAN BE WE SPEAK
JUST A MOMENT FOR AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR HOSPITALS ARE HOSPITALS
STEPPED UP. PROVIDE THE
CAPACITY FOR THE COLD LAKE BEDS
AND FOR THE TREATMENTS AND AS A
RESULT THE- CASH FLOWS AND THE
RESOURCES OF OUR HOSPITALS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE CRASHED.
JUST IN MY COMMUNITY FOR
EXAMPLE COMMUNITY MEDICAL
CENTER IS FACING A LOSS OF AND
I HAD TO CHECK THE FACTS ON
THIS BECAUSE IT'S DONE TO ME.
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS PER
MONTH LOS VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IS FACING ALMOST
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH
IN LOSSES WE HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE HEALTH ON THE
WELL BEING OF OUR HOSPITALS
BECAUSE OUR HOSPITALS TAKE CARE
OF THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
OF OUR INDIVIDUALS. I ALSO
STAND HERE IN AND JOIN WITH MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE. MISTER
GIBSON. TO BESIEGE THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO PAY ATTENTION
TO MLK HOSPITAL IN HIS DISTRICT
IT WILL COLLAPSE. IF IT IS NOT
RESCUE. PLEASE LISTEN. AND THEN
FINALLY THE WHOLE QUESTION
ABOUT THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
REALLOCATION OF ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROP FIFTY
SECOND FUNDS. MET MEMBERS THIS
IS ONE OF THE MOST I THINK
ASTOUNDING. ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION. AND SO I'M
HOPING THAT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE THOSE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WELL FIRST OF
ALL EXPLAIN WHERE DID YOU GET
THIS IDEA. OF RATING PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDS AND WHAT ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL JUSTIFICATION.
BEHIND THESE CUTS WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO MEMBERS. IT COMES
TO THIS BODY TO HAVE ONE VOICE
A STRONG VOICE THAT SAYS. THIS
IS NOT A BLUEPRINT THAT WE CAN
BE PROUD OF HERE. AND WE'RE
ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
HEAR US. AND TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES. IN A BUDGET
THAT MISSES THE MARK
SUBSTANTIALLY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER LIVING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU TO HIS BOSS LAWYER TO MISS
MISTER PACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET STAFF TO THE FINANCE
STAFF IN IN LA STAFF. THIS IS
NOT A NORMAL BUDGET. SO THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK.
AND YOUR TIRELESS DEDICATION TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A FOUR MINUTE PERIOD TO
ASK QUESTIONS THOUGH I KNOW
THAT THESE QUESTIONS CANNOT BE
GIVEN THE RESPECT THAT THEY
DESERVE WITH THAT TIME FRAME.
AND SO I DO ANTICIPATE ANSWERS
AT A DIFFERENT POINT IN TIME OR
WRITTEN THAT CAN GIVE US THE-
IN THAT WE DO NEED. I ANY
ANALYSIS THAT I THINK ALSO IT'S
REQUIRED DURING THIS TIME.
EARLIER THIS YEAR I INTRODUCED
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY SIX WHICH
WOULD HAVE ELIMINATED EIGHTY A
FUNDING. AND REPLACE THAT WITH
AN A STUDENT ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING THIS WAS ADOPTED IN SB
ONE SEVENTEEN THIS YEAR BUT IT
IS NOT ADOPTED IN THE REVISED
AS IT IS PRESENTED- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT ATTENDANCE
NEXT YEAR A HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS THAT MAYBE IF A CHILD
IS SICK THAT CHILD SHOULD NOT
BE COMING TO SCHOOL. PARENTS
WORK SCHEDULE OR SIBLING SCHOOL
SCHEDULES IT WILL BE HARD. FOR
PEOPLE TO MAINTAIN THE
ATTENDANCE THAT THEY WOULD WANT
THEIR CHILDREN TO HAVE. AND OF
COURSE WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE'VE
LOST SOME KIDS WE NEED TO FIND
THEM AGAIN. NONE OF THIS
SHOULD- PENALIZE A CLASSROOM
THE FUNDING THAT THE CLASSROOM
NEEDS AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS MOVED TO. AN ENROLLMENT
BASED FUNDING MECHANISM- NOT
JUST NEXT YEAR BUT REALLY- FOR
TIME- IN PERPETUITY IN THE
FUTURE. ALSO ON A. YEAH I
CONTINUE THE CONCERNS WE'VE
HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ESCONDIDO AND OTHERS ABOUT THE
SAFETY OF PRISONERS- IN OUR IN
OUR PRISONS WE NEED TO HAVE
AGREED UPON WRITTEN PLANS WITH
THE PRISON FACILITIES AND OUR
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
ABOUT WHAT TO DO IF THERE IS A
SURGE OF INFECTION WE KNOW THAT
OUR LOCAL HOSPITALS CANNOT DEAL
WITH BOTH AN INFLUX OF.
PATIENTS FROM OUR PRISONS IF
THERE IS ALSO A SIMULTANEOUS
SURGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES SAN
QUENTIN FOR EXAMPLE- IN PINE BY
WHERE I LIVE- WOULD GO TO THE
HOSPITAL WHERE MY CHILDREN WERE
BORN WHICH HAS FOURTEEN I SEE
YOU THAT'S- THAT'S HARDLY
ENOUGH IT WITH THE LOCAL
POPULATION LET ALONE- WOULDN'T
OPERATE COULD COULD DO. PRISON
OF FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE WE KNOW
IN CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS OVER
NINE HUNDRED HAVE BEEN INFECTED
WITH OVER FIFTY HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN IN. IT'LL ACOSTA
STATE WILL. NOT ON THEY CAN
DEAL. WE ALSO CONCERN FROM
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN ABOUT
EDUCATE FUNDING A PARTICULARLY
HIGH EDUCATION AS ARE UNDER OR
UNEMPLOYED THEY MAY NEED TO
SHIFT THEY ME I HOPE THAT THEY
WANT TO I SPEND TIME TRAINING
OR GOING BACK TO SCHOOL AND
THAT COULD HAVE INCREASED
DEMAND ON A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION OR OTHER SKILL
BUILDING CENTERS FOR LEARNING
AND WE NEED TO BE MAKING
TARGETED INVESTMENTS TO
ANTICIPATE THAT NEED TO WELL TO
PROVIDE THE REBOUND THAT OUR
ECONOMIES SO DESPERATELY NEED.
THIRTY I ALSO HEARD FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ABOUT- THE HOLD UP
OF FEDERAL FUNDS. AND THEY NEED
IF THEY'RE SMALLER COMMUNITIES
THEY NEED TO GET THOSE FEDERAL
FUNDS SHOULD WE BE RIDING THIS
MIGHT BE FOR THE LA- RIGHT INTO
THEIR A FORMULA TO GET THOSE
FUNDS TO THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND LASTLY. WHEN
WE'RE CUTTING SO MANY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS ARE WE MAKING OUR
INVESTMENTS WISELY. SO WITH
OUR- PET PAYMENTS ARE WE
SUBSIDIZING IN AREAS FOR
RETIREES THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
STATE AND FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR
AND WE MAY NEED TO HAVE SOME
VERY DEEP ANALYSIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE STRETCHING EVERY
DOLLAR. AS FAR AS IT WILL GO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISTER
FISHER MISSED MEDINA AND MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHIP.
IN MY ROLE AS A CAPACITY OF THE
A TEAR OF TRANSPORTATION IN
THIS BUDGET I'VE SEEN AT A COST
SHIFTING IS GOING TO OCCUR
PROPOSED A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE IS
INTERESTING COME ACCOUNT ON
TITLE. NINETEEN MONEY. NOW WE
LOOK AT THAT POSSIBILITY. IT IS
THE AUTHOR OF AC AC A FIVE.
THAT WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
WE MADE A PROMISE TO THE TO THE
PUBLIC THAT WE WOULD USE
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS FOR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES NOT
BALANCE THE BUDGET. AND SO THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY GOING TO BE QUESTION.
ALSO AS THE AUTHOR CO AUTHOR OF
SB ONE WE INITIATED A HUNDRED
MILLION OR HER MILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS WITH CALTRANS. INTO
THAT BILL WILL CALTRANS CAME
BACK. WITH TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS- TO SHOW
THAT THEY COULD AND WOULD BE
PART OF THE PROCESS. KNOWING
THAT YOU KNOW FOR EVERY DOLLAR
WE SPEND ON TRANSPORTATION.
SAVES US TEN DOLLARS DOWN THE
ROAD. THE DUGGAR GATES AT A
RAPID PROCESS AND DOESN'T HAVE
A GRADUAL DECLINE IT HAS A CLIP.
WHEN I SEE THE SHOT BEING
UTILIZED IN THE LAST CTC
HEARING. A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS FOR
SAFER STREETS VERSES THE
SHOPPER MAINTENANCE IT GIVES ME
PAUSE AND WONDERING WHAT DO WE
HAVE TO DO TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE TOLD FOUR YEARS AGO THIS
BODY THAT WAS A SEVENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT PAVEMENT
MAINTENANCE. BUT THEY MEANT TO.
AND THAT WE MADE ALL OF THE
EFFORTS TO PASS SB ONE AND THEN
DEFEAT SB- THE- PROPOSITION SIX
THE PUBLIC DID THAT. SO THAT ON
ITS OWN MERIT TELLS US THAT WE
NEED TO BE STEWARDS OF
TRANSPORTATION MONEY LIKE WE
PROMISED. SELECT COMMITTEE FOR
THE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. AND
I'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR ALMOST
EIGHT YEARS NOW. THE POPULATION
IN THIS BUDGET I SEE. A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CUT. I'M
ALSO GETTING REFERENCE FROM
FROM OF PROVIDERS OF ADULT
DAYCARE HOMES THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SUFFER 14% CUTS. NOW
REMEMBER WE THE MIND IS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO SAVE. MONEY AND I
WOULD IN THE GENERAL FUND. NOW
THOSE FOLKS WERE ABSORBED IN
ADULT DAY CARE OR ADULT. GROUP
HOMES AND NOW WE'RE GONNA CUT
THOSE GROUP HOMES. TO BE ABLE
TO. OF BOUNCE THE BUDGET. HOW
DO WE TAKE CARE OF THESE FOLKS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
UNDERPRIVILEGED. THE I. D. V.
POPULATION HAS VERY LITTLE.
HELP AND WE NEED TO HELP THEM
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND NOT
KEEP CUTTING AND BALANCING THE
BUDGET ON THEIR BACKS.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE THREE TO
FIVE YEAR OLD FUNDING. WILL BE
ELIMINATED. FOR THE EARLY
INTERVENTION. KNOWING THAT THAT
IS THE MOST AN INFLUENTIAL
STAGING MOST BENEFICIAL STAGE
OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES
FOR BLOSSOMING. WE'RE CUTTING
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR A LOT ABOUT
COST SHIFTING. COST SHIFTING SO
WITH THE ID POPULATION OF WERE
UNDER FUNDING- CUTTING THE
ADULT GROUP HOMES. AND THOSE GO
OUT OF BUSINESS WE'RE GOING TO
GO IN TWO THIRTY SEVENTH
INSTITUTIONALIZED CARE WHICH IS
DRAMATICALLY MORE EXPENSIVE SO
WE'VE GOT TO BE VERY CAREFUL
WHERE WE ARE CUTTING. IN ONE OF
THE BUDGET HEARINGS MISTER KING
PRODUCT CAL WORKS A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR ASSUMPTION. THE
CAL WORKS WILL BE HITTING BEING
HIT. WITH THIS BUT NO REAL.
EVIDENCE YET. BUT IF THE
MONEY'S NOT USE WILL BE
STAGNANT JUST ROLLED OVER. BUT
ON UTILIZED IN THIS BUDGET. OF
THE PRESENCE. WELL SAID WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BE HAVE A BIT OF
VERY THAT IT PLAN AND THE
HOSPITAL'S TAKING A FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CUT WE
COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON ABOUT
WHAT IS FOUR MINISTRY NOT
ENOUGH HERE BUT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORT THE ID POPULATION I
PERSONALLY THANK YOU SO MISTER
MEDINA MISTER MATHESON THAN
THIS BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. I I'D LIKE TO TALK
TO TALK ABOUT ONE OF OUR CORE
VALUES EDUCATION. AND I WANT TO
THANK. THE CHAIR OF FROM
SACRAMENTO THE CHAIR OF SUB TO
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP- MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN JOSE AND
MARIN. TALKED ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM IT WAS A DREAM
THAT THAT I WAS FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THE DREAM THAT MY FATHER
AND MOTHER WHEN THEY CAME FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA THE CALIFORNIA
AND IT TAUGHT ME AND MY THREE
SIBLINGS THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION. IT IS A DREAM THAT
CANNOT DIE IN CALIFORNIA. AT
THIS TIME BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS SO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF-EDUCATION. IMPORTANCE AS A THE
CHAIR OF SUB TO STATED THAT
SCHOOLS NEED MORE MONEY NOW NOT
LESS AND ALONG WITH MORE MANY
THEY NEED MORE FLEXIBILITY.
FLEXIBILITY IN CLASS SIZE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE LENGTH OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR. I NOW WANT TO
SHIFTED TO. PARTICULAR IDEAS
THE FIRST IS CAL BRIGHT COLLEGE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. TWELVE
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN HOW BRIGHT COLLEGE WAS
ALLOCATED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AN ON GOING GOING FUNDS
AND A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME ZONES THAT COULD BE
SPENT OVER SEVEN YEAR PERIOD.
SINCE THEN THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLR IN ONE TIME
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN TOUCHED
COPYRIGHT REPORTS HAVING FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS CURRENTLY BUT
ONLY SEVENTY THREE HAVE GONE
THROUGH ORIENTATION AND TO THE
ACTUAL PROGRAM WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED A
CUT TO EXISTING FUNDING I THINK
WE NEED TO GO MUCH DEEPER.
DURING THIS TIMES WE SHOULD
ELIMINATE FUNDING TO CALIBRATE
ENTIRELY ELIMINATING CALIBRATE
WOULD MEAN TWENTY MILLION AN ON
GOING SAVINGS PLUS A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION IN ONE
TIME SAVINGS I WOULD ALSO SAY
THE THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT I
INTRODUCED THE IDEA OF DOING A
NOT IT. WOULD SAY THAT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS BECAUSE THE I THOUGHT
IT WOULD NOT BE NEEDED TO
PLACES WHERE THIS MONEY COULD
BE BETTER USED. PART TIME
FACULTY IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FACING A SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET CUT.
AND THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. BESIDES CARD RIGHT I
WANT TO MENTION THAT YOU SEE
ARE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO HEALTH CARE AND PRIVATIZING
FUNDING FOR THE UC OUR SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE A COMMUNITY BASED
MEDICAL SCHOOL GLAD TO SEE THE
ELEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO THIS
SCHOOL THE SCHOOL. IN SUCCESS
IS IMPORTANT TO OUR REGION WILL
HELP CULTIVATE FUTURE DOCTORS
AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF
ABOUT MY SUGGESTION OF
ELIMINATING CALIBRATE ALL
TOGETHER. THANK YOU- I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
HAPPENED- WITH THIS PANDEMIC
THAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING. TO WATCH IS THE-
THE AMOUNT OF INNOVATION THAT'S
HAPPENED WITH ONLINE LEARNING
AND DISTANCE LEARNING IN FACT
THE CSU JUST RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
MAINTAIN THEIR DISTANCE
LEARNING POSTURE INTO THE FALL
FOR A LOT OF COURSES. I'M SO
I'M YOU KNOW I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ESPECIALLY THE CALIBRATE. UNITY
COLLEGE I WAS REALLY-
ESTABLISHED UNDER THE PROMISE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE VERY
BUSY. WORKING GOING TO SCHOOL
AB WORKING AND RAISING FAMILIES
AND OFTEN CANNOT ACCESS SCHOOL
DURING THAT REGULAR EIGHT TO
FIVE EIGHT TO SIX A TIME PERIOD
IN AND REALLY NEED THE CHANCE
TO HAVE A MORE SELF PACED- I
PROGRAM AND ONE THAT THEY CAN
ACCESS IN THE EVENINGS AND ON
WEEKENDS. AND SO THAT WAS
REALLY SOME OF THE NOTIONS
BEHIND AN ONLINE COLLEGE. THAT
IS DEDICATED AND REALLY HAS
EXPERTISE- AND THAT'S- YOU KNOW
OUT. THAT THAT'S WHERE AND THAT
PROPOSAL CAME FROM- BUT I DO
THINK THAT. AS WE HAVE WE AS
WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAD TO GO
ONLINE OVERNIGHT ALL OF OURS K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS HAD TO GO ONLINE
OVERNIGHT. ALL OF THOSE THINGS-
HAVE CREATED YOU KNOW A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CHANGE IN
A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE THE OPTIONS IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YOUR TIME IS UP. THANK YOU
MISS MEDINA MISS MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. TODAY WE HAVE
THE CHANCE TO LEARN FROM THE
MISTAKES OF OUR PAST THREE
SESSIONS. AS PRESIDENT REAGAN
ONCE AID MORE GOVERNMENT IS
THE PROBLEM NOT THE SOLUTION.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
SOMETHING GREAT BUT INSTEAD I
SEE WE ARE GOING DOWN THE SAME
ROADS WE HAVE IN THE PAST. HAVE
WE LEARNED NOTHING. FROM THE
200-082-0009 RECESSION.
COLLEAGUES YOU HAVE THE CHANCE
TO STAND UP AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT
AND ACTUALLY GET IT RIGHT THIS
TIME. WE'VE SEEN THE GOVERNOR
CHANGE OVER TWO HUNDRED PIECES
OF LEGISLATION WITH THE WEB OF
AND- LETTING CRIMINALS INTO OUR
STREETS WHILE RESTING BUSINESS
OWNERS. CLOSING PRISONS AND
FORCING PRESSURE ON TO OUR
COUNTIES WERE FACING BUDGET
CUTS AS WELL. OUR PRIORITIES
SHOULD BE INSURING FAMILIES THE
ABILITY TO WORK. TO SEND OUR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL HAVING SAFE
COMMUNITIES IN SECURING OUR
ECONOMY. GET IN OUR COUNTIES IN
SMALL BUSINESSES THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO OPEN. SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN SAFELY GET BACK TO
WORK. THE MORE PEOPLE WE HAVE
WORKING THE MORE REVENUE WE
BRING IT. THESE REVENUES ARE
NOT JUST. FUND PROGRAMS. BUT
THE FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR FUTURE. AT THE RATE WE'RE
GOING THERE WILL NOT BE ENOUGH
GOVERNMENT AID IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY TO MAKE US WHOLE AGAIN.
THIS GOVERNMENT HAS RAN OUT OF
OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY. LET'S
THINK ABOUT THIS A ONE TRILLION
DOLLAR BAILOUT ASK. YET WE ARE
FILED OVER SIXTY TWO LAWSUITS
AGAINST THE FENCE. TALK ABOUT
BITING THE HAND THAT FEEDS YOU.
LET'S NOT FORGET OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. CUTS TO OUR ELDERLY AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
CUTTING PREVENTIVE CARE WE KNOW
THIS ONLY CAUSES MORE. WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD A FIRST
CLASS MEDICAL WORKFORCE. NOT
JUST FOR URBAN AREAS BUT OUR
ROLE WANTS TO. WE NEED TO BRING
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. WHICH WE KNOW
IS ONE OF THE POOREST AREAS AND
OUR STATE THAT STILL HAS THIRD
WORLD CONDITIONS. I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THE INVESTMENT OF A
MEDICAL SCHOOL. AND THE SOUTH
VALLEY THERE. NOW THE GOVERNOR
IS TALKING ABOUT GOING AFTER
OUR PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDS IS
ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED BY MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS. MY DISTRICT.
WITH THESE CUTS. FACES UP 215%
MEDICAL CLOSURES. AS STATED
BEFORE NOT JUST MY HOSPITALS
THE HOSPITALS ACROSS THE STATE.
ARE FACING CLOSURE. AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT BETTER WAYS TO
HELP THEM. OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO HAVE OUR BACKS HAVE
THEIR BACKS BECAUSE THEIR BACKS
ARE AGAINST THE WALL THESE
BUDGET CUTS SCHOOL PHILIP
CIVILITY IS ALL OF THESE THINGS
WE NEED TO LISTEN. AND DO
WHAT'S RIGHT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
STATED OUR EDUCATION IS OUR
FUTURE. THIRTY SECONDS. YOU
KNOW MEMBERS THE CLOSE THIS
I'VE I'VE GOT MANY MANY MORE
OBVIOUSLY ISN'T ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS AN ENTIRE BUDGET BUT
THIS IDEA. OF ALL THIS COST
SHIFTING. IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE OUR STATE CANNOT BEG
BORROW AND STEAL FROM THE
FUTURE OF OUR CHILDREN IT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND WE ALL KNOW
BETTER. I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF YOU IN THE
MAJORITY TO PUT YOUR FOOT DOWN
TO THE GOVERNOR AND GET THIS
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
NOT SAYING THIS BOERNER HORVATH
SOME GOING TO GO TO MR LACKEY
IN THIS MYTH THE BILL. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND CHAIR. THE
INTELLECTUALLY DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED SYSTEM AS FOR THE BIG
DEVASTATED BY THIS PROPOSAL
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL UNLIKE
OTHER SAFETY NET ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS THE IDEAS NEVER BEEN
MADE WHOLE AFTER DECADES OF
CUTS. RECESSIONARY OF ERA
POLICIES AND FROZEN RATES FAR
FROM RECOGNIZING THIS THE MAY
REVISION EXACERBATES THE
PROBLEM WITH FURTHER CUTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES CONDUCTED THEIR OWN
RATE STUDY DETERMINED THAT
THERE WAS A ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION WITH A B. IN NEW
FUNDING THAT WAS REQUIRED TO
FUND THE CITED THE SYSTEM
APPROPRIATELY. THE BASE CUTS
THE TOTAL BASE CARDS AMOUNT TO
EIGHTY FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. AND IF WE CONSIDER THE
ADDITIONAL CUTS OF NO FEDERAL
MONIES RECEIVED. THERE'S A
TOTAL ADDITIONAL KIND OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE. RIGHT
THREE MILLION. COLLEGE WE HAVE
WHAT IS. CALLED THE LETTERMAN
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
WHICH WAS SUPPOSED TO GUARANTEE
THE RIGHT TO SERVICES TO THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED SO
THAT THEY CAN LIVE MORE
INDEPENDENT AND FULFILLING
LIVES. AFTER THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL MANY OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WERE DEEPLY
CONCERNED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LACK OF
APPARENT DIRECTION TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
STUDY THAT SHOWED THIS ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL. THE MAY REVISION
SHOW EVEN MORE FLAGRANT
DISREGARD FOR THE IMPORTANT
ROLES. THESE PROVIDERS PLATE
AND CARING FOR THAT POPULATION.
AND PROVIDING THEM THE KEY
SERVICES THEY OFFER. KNOWING
THAT THESE PROGRAMS HAVE HUGE
GAPS IS SORT FALLS LEFT FOR
DECADES OF UNMET NEEDS AND
UNRESOLVED HOLES LEFT IN THE- A
PREVIOUS RECESSION WHY TURN
AGAIN TO THIS POPULATION. FOR
BUDGET SOLUTIONS. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO MAKE A QUICK COMMENT
ABOUT TO DJJ THE CCPOA
UNDOUBTEDLY HAS THE BEST
TRAINED YOUTH CORRECTIONAL
STAFF. IN THE CDC OUR DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE WHICH IS
DJJ. THEY ALSO THE GREATEST
ACCESS TO RESOURCES FOR
PROGRAMMING AND TREATMENT AND
THIS IS JUST A RHETORICAL
QUESTION. HOW DISCLOSING THREE
DJJ FACILITIES ARE REALIGNING
WORDS TO OVERBURDEN COUNTIES
CONTRIBUTE TO A BETTERMENT OF
REHABILITATION. AND THE RUSH TO
CLOSE THESE FACILITIES THERE
ARE MANY COSTLY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS AS THE CHAIR OF SUB
FIGHT STATED. I NOW WOULD LIKE
TO CLUB THREE QUESTIONS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THERE ARE THERE YES NO. ANSWERS
FIRST OF ALL WITH THE STATE
CONSIDER EXTENDING THE
STATUTORY CARRY FORWARD PERIODS
BY THREE YEARS DUE TO THE FIVE
MILLION LIMITATION OPPOSED
YEARS TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR THE BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS IMPACTED. SECOND WITH
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR LIMIT
APPLY ON A SEPARATE COMPANY OR
COMBINED UNITARY GROUP BASIS
AND THIRDLY WITH THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR LIMóN APPLY TO
ALL BUSINESS CREDITS OR TO ONLY
CERTAIN BUSINESS CREDITS AL.
AND WITH THAT. THANK YOU MISS
PART OF AND I KNOW THAT IDEA IS
THAT FOR BOTH THE AND THE NET
OPERATING LOSSES AND THE TAX
CREDITS THE LIMITATION OF FIVE
MILLION IT WOULD ONLY BE FOR
THREE YEARS. AND THEN AFTER
THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO RESUME USING
THE CREDIT AND THE AND OUT AND
THE NET OPERATING LOSSES IN
TERMS OF YOUR VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS I'M GONNA HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT- BUT HI AND
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
ANOTHER THE NESTLE MON. AND
THEN MISS RUBIO AT THE MISTER
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ANDMEMBERS WELL I HAVE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH THIS
BUDGET I AM FOCUSING MY
COMMENTS TODAY ON A FEW POINTS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO MY
DISTRICT TO THE BANKING
COMMITTEE WHICH CHAIR AND AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S COPS. ONLY
SIX OF CALIFORNIA'S FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO CITIES
AND SIXTEEN OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVE RECEIVED A
PORTION OF THE FIFTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION ALLOCATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA TO CALIFORNIA. CARES
ACT. DISTRICT ON THE HAS NOT
RECEIVED FUNDING. I AM GLAD TO
SEE THAT THE MAY REVISED
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY. SKEWS ME.
ON HOW MUCH COUNTIES CAN EXPECT
TO RECEIVE. HIGHER IS THAT WE
EXPEDITE THE ALLOCATION OF
THESE FUNDS AND TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES. BECAUSE OF IN
NINETEEN CRISIS HAS PUSHED
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN CLINICS
TO THE BRINK OF CLOSURE. THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION REPORTED LAST WEEK
THAT ONE OUT OF THREE OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS ARE
WORRIED THEY MAY HAVE TO CLOSE
THE DOORS IN OUR STATE. ONE
CLINIC SANSOM IN MY DISTRICT
WHICH IS A SOURCE OF HEALTH
CARE IN THE REGION IT MAY BE
FORCED TO CLOSE ITS DOORS
UNLESS ASSISTANCE IS PROVIDED.
ADDITIONALLY WE MUST KEEP THOSE
IN MIND THAT HAVE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE FOR OUR STATE AND THE
CENTRAL WORKERS. INCLUDING
FARMWORKERS AND THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION. I
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS TO ENSURE I TEN
FILERS HAVE ACCESS TO THE EITC
PROGRAM. AS CHAIR OF THE
BANKING COMMITTEE I SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED ENHANCEMENT OF THE DVL
WE KNOW THAT THIS PANDEMIC IS
ONLY A HEALTH CRISIS BUT ALSO
IT'S AN ECONOMIC CRISIS IN
TIMES LIKE THESE FINANCIAL
PREDATORS AND FRAUDSTERS ARE
WORKING HARDER THAN EVER TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. I INTRODUCED A
BILL LAST YEAR WE HELD A
HEARING ON THIS VERY ISSUE
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE THAT ARE
EXISTING PIECEMEAL APPROACH TO
FINANCIAL REGULATION HAD LEFT
MANY GAPS THAT COULD BE
EXPLOITED BY BAD ACTORS. I AM
HAPPY TO SEE THAT HE D. V. O.
ENHANCE ME IN THE MAY REVISED
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
REQUIRES NO APPROPRIATION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS WE CARE ABOUT A FEMINIST
BUDGET THAT INCLUDES ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE. PAID FAMILY LEAVE
SUPPORT FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR
WOMEN. WE ARE REQUESTING THE
REJECTION OF THE 10% CUT TO THE
S. S. R. S. R. OR AN ARM OUR
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. AS WELL AS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW
SINGLE REGIONAL EYES RATE
STRUCTURE. DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. VAST CUTS WERE MADE
ACROSS DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. WELL THE
STATE RECOVERED CHILDCARE
FIELD DID NOT GROW AT THE SAME
RATE. APPROXIMATELY 70% OF
CHILD CARE CENTERS HAVE CLOSE
DURING THE SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDER. UNFORTUNATELY SOME WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO RE OPEN. THIS
WILL HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON WOMEN AND IT WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT WOMEN
OF COLOR. WE WANT TO PRESERVE
AS MANY CENTERS AS WE CAN. BUT
WE MUST ALSO LOOK TO EXPAND THE
AVAILABILITY OF ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT VOUCHERS THAT PROVIDE
THE MOST FLEXIBILITY. AS
FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO FIND CHILD
CARE TO RETURN TO WORK
INCLUDING THOSE THAT LIVE IN
RURAL AREAS IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
THE COMPLETE ABSENCE OF
CENTERS. MANY WILL RETURN TO
THEIR FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. IN CLOSING I BRING
UP AN ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED IN
BUDGETS UP TO. I AM CONCERNED
THAT THE FEDERAL CARE IS MANY
IS THE ONLY RELIEF FOR THE
FEDERAL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN PROVIDING SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. THESE
PROGRAMS WILL STRUGGLE TO
PROVIDE MEALS TO CHILDREN IN
THE SUMMER AND FALL I URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CD TO
IDENTIFY AND PLAN TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN HAVE AXES TO
MEALS AND FOOD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MISS
RUBIO. THAN MISTER GALLAGHER
THE MISTER MERCER CHEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY AS A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AS WELL AS- WOMEN'S
CAUCUS MEMBER AND A MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DELEGATION. TO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS OVER THE DEVASTATING
CUTS IN THE MAY REVISE.
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IS THE MOST NOBLE
AND MEANINGFUL IMPACT WE CAN
MAKE FOR OUR BUDGET I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF FOSTER YOUTH
CALIFORNIA SENIORS CHILD CARE
REIMBURSEMENTS AND D. H. U. S.
WAIVERS TO DISCUSS MY
OPPOSITION TO CUTS MADE.
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OUR MOST
MODERN BUT HE'S CALIFORNIA'S DO
YOU NEED TO NEED OUR HELP NOW
MORE THAN EVER. FAMILIES WHO
CARE FOR OUR STATE FOSTER YOUTH
ARE PCP DIRE SITUATION BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS INCREASING
TIME LINES FOR RESOURCE
FAMILIES APPROVAL LEAVING FOR
LEASE FOR ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH JOB LOSSES AND
OTHER IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
NINETEEN. WITH FEW RESOURCES TO
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN. A THE
STATE PLACE IN THEIR HOMES. TO
CUT THEM NOW AT A TIME WITH A
STARK AND EMPLOYMENT MAYBE A
SHORT SIGHTED DECISION THE COST
THE STATE'S MORE MONEY IN THE
END. FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES
TAKE CARE OF THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FOSTER KIDS DAILY WHICH IS ONE
THIRD OF ALL FOSTER KIDS AND
HOMES AND EVER FREE SOCIAL
WORKERS. SERVE TO SUPPORT A
100% OF ALL FOSTER YOUTH IN
INTENSIVE SERVICES. FOSTER CARE
WHICH INCLUDES SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING SITUATIONS. WITH
THE WORK FIRST THAT HAVE 90% OF
ITS MEMBERS IDENTIFY AS FEMALE
AND IS ALREADY FACING A FIFTY
NINE PERCENT. TURNOVER RATE DUE
TO LOW WAGES THE ASSEMBLY NEEDS
TO CONSIDER THE LONG TERM
RAMIFICATIONS OF THESE THESE
CUTS. STUDIES HAVE PROVEN THAT
WITH ONE SOCIAL WORKER THERE IS
A 75% PERMANENCY RATE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND THAT DOT DROPS
218% WHEN THERE ARE TWO OR MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS. NEXT MAY REVISE
DECISION TO ELIMINATE COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS C. D. A. S. AND MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICE PROGRAMS
OTHERWISE KNOWN IN AMERICA AS
M. S. S. P. MAY HAVE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS IN OUR
STATE. THE M. S. S. P. SERVICE
TWELVE THOUSAND POOR FRAIL
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR
FAMILY CARE GIVERS YEARLY.
HELPING KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
NURSING HOMES. THE MAJORITY OF
THE M. F. S. P. CLIENTS RESIDE
ALONG ALONE LIVE ON APPROXIMATE
ONE DOLLARS PER MONTH. WITHOUT
AN ASSIST P. SERVICES MANY
PEOPLE WILL BE FORCED TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES AND MOVE INTO
NURSING HOMES. RECENT ESTIMATES
HAVE SHOWN GREATER THAN ONE
THIRD OF US COVERT NINETEEN
DEATHS HAVE OCCURRED IN NURSING
HOMES A PROBLEM WE STILL HAVE
NOT GRASS. WITH EXPERTS
PREDICTING A LIKELY SECOND WAVE
THIS FALL WE MUST ASK OURSELVES
WHAT DIRECT IMPACT WILL THIS
DECISION HAVE ON OUR DEATH TOLL.
M. F. S. P. AND C. B. EIGHT F.
ARE CRUCIAL LONGSTANDING
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS THAT SHOULD
BE PRESERVED FOR OUR SENIOR
POPULATION. IN ADDITION TO
SENIOR PROGRAM FROM PROGRAM
SUPPORTING FOSTER YOUTH I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS OPPOSING THE
10% KIND TO CUT TO CHILD CARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. THE FOR
THOSE FAMILIES NEED US RIGHT
NOW SO THAT THEY CAN GET BACK
TO WORK. AND PROPER CHILD CARE
WILL ALLOW THEM TO DIESEL.
FINALLY AS A MEMBER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION WE
URGE THE D. H. S. D. H. C. S.
TO SUBMIT THE ONE ONE ONE FIVE
A WAIVER PROPOSED. TO THE
CENTER FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID AS MEDICAID SERVICES
WAIVER WILL PROVIDE A TEMPORARY
INCREASE IN THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR BOARDING CARE
RESIDENTS TO COVER COVERT
NINETEEN RELATED COSTS. LOS
ANGELES HAS BEEN A CLARK HAS
SEEN A CLOSER FORTY NINE ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES AND MANY
CLOSURES OF RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
BUT THEME THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER. THE DEVASTATING
PROPORTIONATE CUTS DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER THAN MISTER MERCER TO
THE MYSTICAL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY I THINK
UNDERSCORES WHY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA NEED THEIR
LEGISLATURE. NOW WE HAVE THE
POWER OF THE PURSE. WE HAVE THE
POWER OVER POLICY. WE HAVE THE
POWER OVER OVERSIGHT AND WE
NEED TO USE IT. THIS MAYREVISE
IS OFF BASE IT'S TOTALLY OFF
BASE AND IT NEEDS THE
LEGISLATURE. TO MAKE IT RIGHT.
NOW WE HAVE A TOUGH JOB IN
FRONT OF US WE'VE ALL EXPRESSED
THAT TODAY- DEVASTATING- LOSSES
TO OUR GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
WE HAVE TOUGH CHOICES TO MAKE
BUT WE WILL DO WELL. IF WE
STICK TO THIS THEME KEEP OUR
PROMISES. AND STICK WITH OUR
PRIORITIES. NOW THIS MAY REVISE
DOESN'T DO THAT. I KNOW THIS
LEGISLATURE ONE THING THAT WE
WILL NOT DO IS TURN OUR BACKS
ON WILD FIRE VICTIMS. THIS MAY
REVISE TAKE SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE TOWN OF
PARADISES WATER DISTRICT IS
STRUGGLING TO RECOVER IN THE
WAKE OF THE CAMPFIRE. THESE ARE
NOT UNSPENT PROGRAM FUNDS THIS
WAS A COMMITMENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR. AND FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE TO A TOWN THAT WAS
COMPLETELY WIPED OUT. BY THAT
FIRE. IT WAS A COMMITMENT OF
TWO YEARS OF REVENUE BACK FILL
TAX BACK FILL THAT WE'VE DONE
FOR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHO'VE BEEN RAVAGED BY
FIRE AND I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
OTHER COMMUNITY. THAT HAD ITS-
VITAL DOLLARS PULLED BACK. LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID
TO THE TOWN OF PARADISE. IN
THEIR WATER DISTRICT LAST WEEK.
WE NEED TO MAKE THIS RIGHT KEEP
YOUR COMMITMENTS ESPECIALLY TO
THESE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY WILDFIRES. AND
STICK WITH OUR PRIORITIES NOW
LET ME LET ME ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE OF FEDERAL FUNDS BECAUSE
NGUYEN ACTUAL WE INQUIRED ABOUT
PARADISE ONE OF THE ANSWERS WE
GOT BACK WAS WELL THIS IS WHY
WE NEED. THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
MOTOR THAT MESSAGE TO US THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS CONTINGENT THAT
THE STATE'S PROMISED THIS THE
PROBLEM THE STATE MADE WITH
STATE MONEY IS SOMEHOW
CONTINGENT. UPON FEDERAL
FUNDING MORE FOLKS IS ALREADY
BEEN TWO AND A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS OF FEDERAL AID THAT HAS
COME THROUGH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT HAVE COME TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THESE%
TRIGGER CUTS ARE COMPLETELY
BOGUS AND ANY TO BE CALLED OUT
FOR THAT. SAYING THAT EDUCATION
WILL HAVE TO TAKE THESE HUGE
CUTS. IS EDUCATION A PRIORITY
OR NOT. THIS LEGISLATURE'S
ALWAYS MADE IT A PRIORITY WE
WILL CONTINUE BUT LET'S TALK
ABOUT THAT EDUCATION BUDGET.
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
ARE BEING USED IN THIS MAY AND
THIS MAY REVISE FEDERAL FUNDS.
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
AND YET WE ARE CUTTING K.
THROUGH TWELVE GENERAL FUND
PROP NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION
MONEY BY 14% WHILE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS IN PROJECTIONS ARE ONLY
DOWN EIGHT PERCENT. WERE MAKE
AN EVEN BIGGER CUTS EDUCATION
WHEN THE FEDS OF STEPPED UP
THIS GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
STEPS BACK. WE TALK ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF COME IN. LET ME JUST
DETAIL IT FOR YOU THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
OR SO OR SORRY TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OF COME
IN TO HELP SUPPORT. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TO
SUPPORT THE UC SYSTEM. THREE
HUNDRED AND NINE. MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE COME IN TO SUPPORT
THE CSU SYSTEM. FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS OF FEDERAL FUNDS HAVE
COME IN TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BUT THEY GET A 10%
CUT. IN THIS GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CT PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE MADE A
PRIORITY GET A 50% CUT. IN THIS
MAY REVISED BUDGET. THAT'S NOT
A PRIORITY. THAT'S NOT MAKING
EDUCATION A PRIORITY THE FEDS
OF STEPPED UP THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET STEPS BACK. AND WE IN
THE LEGISLATURE NEED TO MAKE
THAT RIGHT. I HOPE I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU AS WE ALWAYS HAVE DONE.
USING OUR CONSTITUTIONALLY
GIVEN POWER TO MAKE THIS RIGHT
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THE FORMER SEARCHING. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AS A STATE
LEGISLATOR AND AS A PARENT OF A
FIFTH GRADER. NOTHING BREAKS MY
HEART MORE THAN CUTTING OUR
FUNDING FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION. I SUPPORT K. THROUGH
TWELVE FUNDING AS OUR STATE'S
HIGHEST BUDGET PRIORITY. IN
THIS TIME OF BUDGETARY CRISIS
WE MUST PRIORITIZE OUR CORE
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS. OUR CORD
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS INCLUDE
OUR SCHOOLS. AT A TIME WHEN OUR
SCHOOLS ARE FACING INCREASED
COSTS IN DEALING WITH THE CALL
OF IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE NEED
TO GIVE OUR SCHOOLS MORE NOT
LESS RESOURCES. WE CANNOT FULLY
RE OPEN OUR ECONOMY WITHOUT RE
OPENING OUR SCHOOLS. MANY
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT GET BACK TO
WORK WITHOUT OUR SCHOOLS RE
OPENING. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
CLEARLY UNDERSCORED HOW OUR
SCHOOLS AND NOT JUST PROVIDE
EDUCATION FOR OUR CHILDREN. BUT
ALSO CHILD CARE BEFORE SCHOOL
DURING SCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL FOR
WORKING FAMILIES. OUR SCHOOLS
PROVIDE MEALS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES STRUGGLING DURING THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS. OUR SCHOOLS
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER
VITAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR
CHILDREN DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS. OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE MUST
GIVE OUR SCHOOLS THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO RE OPEN IN THE
FALL. MOST FUNDING FOR OUR
SCHOOLS IS DISTRIBUTED THROUGH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. WE NEED TO FIND L. C.
F. F. AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. WE
MUST ALSO DISTRIBUTE FEDERAL
CARES ACT FUNDING IN A FAIR AND
ETHICAL ROLE WAY TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BECAUSE THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
OVERRIDING PURPOSE OF THE CARES
ACT FUNDING IS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC. THIS
FUNDING NEEDS TO BE DISTRIBUTED
TO HELP ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY SERVICES
AND EQUIPMENT FOR OUR CHILDREN
AND SCHOOL STAFF WHETHER FOR
NECESSARY PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES. OR TO MAKE DISTANCE
LEARNING WORK FOR ALL STUDENTS.
TO THIS END I ASK. THAT THE
FEDERAL CARES ACT DOLLARS BE
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BASED ON THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO
TO MR COOLEY- THAN MR KILEY IN
THE LOCAL DOCTOR MISS FOR ORDER.
HEALY IT'S A PLEASURE TO HAVE
YOU IN THIS HOUSE. I THINK WE
ARE. FORTUNATE TO HAVE YOU
THERE I KNOW YOU WERE CLOSE TO
CONVERSATIONS BACK IN THE LAST
BIG DOWNTURN- TWO THOUSAND
NINE. TEN ELEVEN. THAT THERE IS
ON MY MIND TODAY I THINK WE GET
A LOT OF REALIGNMENT BACK AT
THAT PERIOD A LOT OF CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES SOCIAL WELFARE
SERVICES GOT REALIGNED TO THE
COUNTIES. AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THE QUARANTINE THE SHELTER AT
HOME. DRAMATIC IMPACTS ON LOCAL.
BUSINESSES WHICH MEANS SALES
TAX SO WE HAVE SOME POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN ROLLED OUT%
THEY'RE GOING TO IMPACT LOCAL
REVENUES AND THE SERVICES FOR
KIDS IN THE VARIOUS COUNTIES. I
WANT TO SPEAK TO JUST THIS
PARTICULAR POPULATION OF FOSTER
CHILDREN I CHAIR THAT SELECT
COMMITTEE. YOU'RE A PARENT THE
GOVERNOR'S A PARENT. OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AND THEY'RE VERY
DEPENDENT NOW UPON THESE
PROGRAMS BEING ADMINISTERED BY
THE COUNTIES OF THIS ALIGNMENT
REALIGNMENT. I WE'VE ALREADY
HAD ALLUSION TO THE RESOURCE
FAMILY ALLOCATION THE PROCESS
TO GET RESOURCES IN FAMILIES
WITH FOSTER KIDS. THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION THEIR
NEEDS ARE EDUCATION FOOD
STABILITY. THERE ARE VERY
DEPENDENT POPULATION WITHIN ALL
THE IMPORTANT GROUPS WERE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. SO CLEARLY
I JUST WANT TO SAY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I PRAY THAT YOU WOULD
BE ATTENTIVE TO WHAT DSS HAS TO
SAY WHAT YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT
FOSTER KIDS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
VULNERABILITY THAT THEY HAD
BEFORE COLD IN HERE. IS MUCH
COMPOUNDED YOU KNOW FOSTER KIDS
THERE'S A FRAILTY TO THE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE OUT OF SCHOOL
THE OTHER CUSTOMARY
INTERACTIONS WITH PEOPLE
CUSTOMER SUPPORT NETWORK. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE CHAMPIONS THE
STATE A CALIFORNIA'S OUR
CHAMPION. SO WHY I LOOK TO YOU
AS SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN DOWN THIS TRAIL BEFORE AS
DISCONCERTING AS I KNOW THIS
YEAR'S. I ASK YOU TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THESE FOSTER. CARE
CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE CHAMPIONS I DON'T KNOW SIR
HAVE INSTITUTIONAL CHAMPIONS
THEY HAVE A MOM AND A DAD. SO
MOST AMERICANS WITH THE STATE
TO BE THEIR CHAMPION I KNOW IS
YOU SORT THESE TO DSS. AND YOUR
OWN INSTINCTS AS A MOM WILL BE
HELP. I COMMIT THEM TO YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO
MR KILEY THAN THIS
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU AS I
HAVE A FOUR MINUTES TO ADDRESS
OF TWO HUNDRED THREE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET I'M GONNA FOCUS
ON ONE LINE ITEM. AND THAT IS
TWENTY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOUR EDT THE I. R.
INDIO J. TO ENFORCE LAST YEAR'S
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE. LET'S BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS IS.
IT'S TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO TAKE AIM AT SMALL BUSINESSES.
TO AUDIT AND PROSECUTE THEM
DEFINE AND PENALIZE THEM TO
BOLDLY AND HARASS THEM WHEN
THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
LIKE NEVER BEFORE. IT'S TWENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO FINISH
THE JOB OF DECIMATING A
COMMUNITY OF INDEPENDENT
PROFESSIONALS AS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA ITSELF SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF PROFESSIONS MANY OF
THE MOST TALENTED PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE. AND MANY OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR STATE.
IT'S TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO SHUT DOWN GAINFUL WORK AND
DESTROYED LIVELIHOODS WHEN
THERE ARE MORE UNEMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS THEN HE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF HALF THE STATES.
IN THE COUNTRY. ONE SUCH
CALIFORNIAN IS A WOMAN NAMED
MONICA. I AM A SIXTY ONE YEAR
OLD CANCER SURVIVOR MONICA
WROTE. AB FIVE DESTROYED MY
LIFE TAKING MY OVER THE PHONE
INTERPRETER JOB. WHO WILL HIRE
A SIX SENIOR LIKE ME. I WAS
MAKING GOOD MONEY TAKING MY
BREAKS WHEN I FEEL LIKE IT.
DURING MY CHEMOTHERAPY THIS JOB
WAS MY SALVATION AGAINST
OPPRESSION IT MADE ME FEEL
USEFUL. HELPING PEOPLE IN
HOSPITALS PHARMACIES HOTELS
RENTAL COMPANIES IMMIGRATION
AGENCIES AND MUCH MORE. WHEN I
WAS INTERPRETING I DIDN'T EVEN
THINK ABOUT ANY BAD THINGS
HAPPENING IN MY LIFE. SINCE
JANUARY I LIVE WITH DEPRESSION.
SOME DAYS I DON'T HAVE STRENGTH
TO GET UP IN THE MORNING I JUST
CRAWL AND CRIED BECAUSE FOR
EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN WAKING UP
TO LOG IN AND START TO WORK.
SOMETIMES I WISH I COULD DIE MY
NAME IS MONICA AND THIS IS MY
AB FIVE STORY. GOVERNOR NEWSOME
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT MONICA
THAT'S CLEAR FROM THIS BUDGET.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS DENIED
THAT PEOPLE LIKE MONICA EVEN
EXIST. GOVERNOR NEW SOME IS ALL
TOO WILLING TO CREATE MANY MORE
MONICA AS AS A RICH REWARD FOR
THE SPECIAL INTERESTS WITH THE
MOST JEWS AT THIS CAPITAL. IT'S
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
OF LINE ITEM. ONE LINE ITEM IN
A SPRAWLING BUDGET YET THERE IS
SO MUCH DISHONOR PACKED INTO
THAT ONE LINE WE'LL MORE
TIGHTLY THAN A STRAND OF DNA.
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING ABOUT
WHAT'S BECOME OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. NO SERIOUS PERSON.
HONESTLY BELIEVES ON THE MERITS
IT WAS A GOOD IDEA TO PASS
EIGHTY FIVE MUCH LESS TO INVEST
IN ITS ENFORCEMENT WHEN WE HAVE
A RECORD ON EMPLOYMENT AND- A
RECORD DEFICIT. THE FOUNDER OF
THE LIBERAL DAILY KOS TO TAKE
ONE EXAMPLE. CALL AB FIVE
DISASTROUS AND ITS SUPPORTERS
SHAMEFUL. GAVIN NEWSOM'S OWN
FORMER DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF
YOU CHARLIE SAID IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY PHD
ECONOMISTS ROAD OPEN LETTER TO
THE GOVERNOR SAYING AB FIVE IS
DOING ITS SUBSTANTIAL AND
AVOIDABLE HARM THIRTY VERY
PEOPLE WHO NOW HAVE THE FEWEST
RESOURCES AND THE WORST
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THIS TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
DEFIES EXPERT OPINION COMMON
SENSE AND BASIC HUMAN DECENCY.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY. I ASK YOU TO
REMOVE THIS FUNDING AND REPEAL
THIS WALL. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO NEXT TO MISS
BOERNER HORVATH MISS GONZALEZ
AND THEN MR FLORA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK
YOU'VE DONE TO BRING US HERE
TODAY TO ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON
WHAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST. BOOK
BUT THAT. EVER WORKED ON. THE
ACTIONS WE TAKE IN THE COMING
WEEKS WILL DETERMINE THE PATH
OF ECONOMIC EVERY. FOR
CALIFORNIA THE MOST IMPORTANT.
HOW FAIR AND EQUITABLE THIS
RECOVERY WILL BE. ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I'D LIKE TO
ECHO THE SENTIMENT. OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT SUPPORT OF.
FEMINIST BUDGET FOR ME A MOTHER
A FEMINIST BUDGET MEANS THREE I
MERRY THINGS. WE SHOULD PROP
TIES FUNDING TO CHILDCARE K.
TWELVE EDUCATION. THESE CUTS.
THE CARD AND THE CURRENT BUDGET
MEAN THAT WOMEN WHO ARE BY AND
LARGE ARE THE PRIMARY
CARETAKERS OF OUR CHILDREN MEAN
WOMEN WILL WILL REMAIN OUT OF
THE WORKFORCE EVEN AS OUR
ECONOMY RE OPENS AND RECOVERS.
AS IT IS NOW WOMEN MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE CLAIMING UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. THIS IS THE TIME
WHICH CARE CENTERS AND SCHOOLS
NEED TO DO MORE NOT LESS TO
HELP OUR KIDS RETURN TO SCHOOL
FIVE DAYS A WEEK WITH
APPROPRIATE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
INCREASE SANITATION AND
INNOVATIVE CURRICULUM. THIS CAN
ONLY BE REPORTER TRIES FUNDING
TO SCHOOLS AS LONG AS KIDS ARE
NOT BACK IN SCHOOL OR IN
CHILDCARE FIVE DAYS A WEEK
WOMEN WILL REMAIN OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE FURTHER INCREASING.
WORKFORCE WHAT DO YOU PAY
INEQUITY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
ADVANCEMENT OF WOMEN THAT WE
HAVE FOUGHT SO HARD OVER THE
LAST DECADES. TO ACHIEVE. TO BE
HONEST I CAME TO SACRAMENTO TO
FIGHT FOR A BETTER WORLD. FOR
MY DAUGHTER. WHEN ALL THE
LITTLE GIRLS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEN WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY THAT I HAD GROWING
UP THE MANY OF THE WOMEN HERE
EXPERIENCED IN THEIR CHILDHOOD
AND ADULTHOOD AND CAREERS. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE GAMES
THAT WOMEN HAVE MADE IN THE
WORKPLACE ARE NOT SET BACK. A
DECADE OR MORE. BY THE BUDGET.
NOT APPROPRIATE PRIORITIZE K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION AND
CHILD CARE OUR GIRLS AND ALL
THE CHURCH CALIFORNIA DESERVE
BETTER. CERTAINLY THERE'S TO
BE. HOW TO DO THIS BY
PRIORITIZING FUNDING IS THE
FIRST STEP. SECOND WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN
RETRAINING AND WORK SHARE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WOMEN AND LOW
SKILL WORKERS ARE PROJECTED TO
BE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
IN THE MEN ALONG MID AND LONG
TERM IMPACTS OF COVE IN
NINETEEN RECESSION. WE DID THAT
NOW AN INNOVATIVE TRAINING ROOM
SOME WORK SURE PROGRAMS THEY
CAN BETTER HANDLE A PROJECTED
SECOND SEARCH OF THE
CORONAVIRUS. BY PRIOR TO ME
COLLEGE IN FUNDING NOW WE COULD
INCREASE OUR BE NUMBER OF IT
RETRAINING TO ADDRESS ALL THE-
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK WORK. THE
BETTER INVEST TAXPAYER MONEY
KEEPING PEOPLE EMPLOYED WHICH
WILL ACCELERATE RECOVERY IN THE
LONG TERM. THESE CHOICES ARE
CHOICES WE MADE TODAY THAT
AFFECT THE ABILITY TO SAFELY
AND SWIFTLY. AS POSSIBLE
RECOVER JOBS WHICH SHOULD BE A
TOP PRIORITY OF OUR BODY. AND
THIRD WE SHOULD MAINTAIN
INVESTMENTS IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM TO BE HONEST
AT SOMETHING VERY LONG PLANNED
TO SAY ABOUT THAT BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF ALL OF OUR TIME.
I'M JUST GOING SAY DITTO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SANTA
ROSA. HE NAILED IT. SO THESE MY
FRIENDS ARE THE PRIORITIES OF
WHAT I CONSIDER FROM BUDGET.
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. IF YOU
WERE GONNA GO TO MISS A
GONZALEZ. THE MISTER FLORA THE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ AND AGAIN JUST
REMIND PEOPLE. THAT WE DO HAVE
WITNESSES FEEL FREE TO ADDRESS
QUESTIONS TO THE WITNESSES.
IT'S GONZALEZ THANK YOU FIRST
AND FOREMOST- AS CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LATINO
CAUCUS IT WOULD BE REMISS TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE IS NOTHING
IN THIS BUDGET FOR ARE
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS. AND WHY
THIS IS SUCH A PROBLEM IS WE
KNOW THAT IN PARTICULAR I ITS
HAND I TEND FILERS THE BEANS
ARE ACTUALLY FILING. ON TAXES
THAT THEY'VE EARNED IN THIS
STATE. ARE THE ONLY GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO GET NOTHING BACK.
DESPITE PAYING MORE THAN THREE
BILLION DOLLARS STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. AND
IN MY COMMUNITY AND SO MANY
LIKE YOURS THAT HAVE A LOT OF
MAKE STATUS HOUSEHOLDS. A
DOUBLE CHECK PRETTY. IF THEY'RE
MARRIED TO SOMEBODY WHO'S EVEN
A U. S. CITIZEN THAT US CITIZEN
DIDN'T EVEN GET A STIMULUS
CHECK FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THEY CAN'T GET
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
THEIR U. S. BORN CHILDREN ARE
GETTING NOTHING AT ALL. IT IS
JUST INJUSTICE THAT THESE TAX
PAYERS CAN'T ACCESS THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. IT HAS BEEN
GOING ON TOO LONG AND WE'VE ALL
SEEN OUR COMMUNITIES WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF LEAVE THAT WERE
VERY GREAT. THIS ADMINISTRATION
CAME UP WITH. KIND OF PANIC
THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE COMMUNITIES
WHICH FOR THE LAST WEEK HAS
RESULTED IN EIGHT AM THROUGH
EIGHT PM PHONE CALLS TO
NONPROFITS TO GET FIVE DOLLAR
JUST ONE TIME. THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT HELLO CHECK
THE LIVES. OF OUR TAX PAYING.
SENSUAL WORK IN CALIFORNIA WHO
HAPPEN BE UNDOCUMENTED WE HOPE
THAT WE CONSIDER THIS BUDGET. I
ALSO RISE AS A SUPPORT OF A
FEMINIST BUDGET AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE PROMOTE FROM
ENCINITAS I HAVE TO SAY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN TALK
ABOUT RECOVERING IF WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
CHILD CARE FACILITY OPENING.
WHEN I FIRST RAN OFFICE I RAN
AS A WORKING SINGLE MOM- THERE
WEREN'T A LOT OF THOSE DURING
THOSE DAYS I KNOW WE HAVE A
COUPLE NOW I AM NO LONGER A
SINGLE MOM. THIS I FIRST TWO
ASIANS WERE HEARING FROM OUR
SCHOOLS TWICE A WEEK HALF DAYS.
THERE IS NO WAY FOR WOMEN TO
RETURN TO WORK. AND I KNOW IT
COULD BE MEN AS WELL. BUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN HAVE
PICKED UP THE SCROLL AT HOME.
AND ARE TAKING CARE. I KNOW
THAT SO MANY OF US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY ARE DOING DOUBLE DUTY OF
TRYING TO WORK FULL TIME. TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR CHILDREN AT
HOME AND BE A HOME SCHOOL
PARENT. ONLY SO MUCH THAT CAN
BE DONE AND I WORRY ABOUT ANY
ECONOMY COMING BACK. WHEN HALF
THE WORKFORCE CAN'T ACTUALLY
WORK BECAUSE THEY HAVE CHILDREN
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN AT HOME.
IT'S A PROBLEM. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST I DO WANT TO BRING UP
AND SHOW SUPPORT FOR THE VICE
CHAIRS POINT. ABOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IN THE
LOAN THAT WILL BECOME DO
PROBABLY IN TWO YEARS IF IT'S
NORMAL. TIME PERIOD. AND I'D
LIKE TO ASK THIS QUESTION WE
KNOW THAT A REPORT DONE BY UC
BERKELEY SHOWED US. THAT
COMPANY JUST. BENEATH COULD BE
MISSED. THEIR WORKERS OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS- OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND.
FIVE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS.
TO COME. WE KNOW THAT MONEY
GOING TO EDT TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH AB FIVE
INSURERS THE COMPANIES WHO HAVE
NOT PAID INTO OUR EMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND. AND NOW HAVE TO
BE FORCED TO BUY WHY DOES THAT
MATTER THAT MEANS THAT LAW
ABIDING COMPANIES THOSE
COMPANIES WHO BEEN PAIN IN OVER
THE LAST DECADE ARE NOT GONNA
BE FOOTING THE BILL FOR
COMPANIES THAT HAVE CHEATED OUR
PROGRAMS. I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT FEATURE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN WE HAVE RULES IN
CALIFORNIA WE REALIZE THAT IF
YOU DON'T ABIDE BY THE UP.
THANK YOU HURT THE LAW ABIDING
MISS IT WHO HAVE WHO AND WILL
IN THE FUTURE I WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
PLAN TO GO AFTER THOSE
COMPANIES THAT FOR YEARS. IT
ARE SURE FIND OUT. POSTED ALL.
HE'S STILL IN ME IN THE STATE
TO GO TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO ASK FOR A LOAN IT FOR LESS
MONEY AND FOR. IN THE US AND I
HOPE WE HAVE A TO GO THOSE
COMPANIES AS WELL TO HELP WITH
FUTURE BUDGET. REQUEST WITH
THAT A QUESTION DIRECTED TO
SOMEBODY TO MISS. WITH HIS
FATHER ON THE FRONT I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU A MINUTE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. YEAH I THINK
THAT I AM CLEARLY THAT THE MISS
CLASSIFICATION OF EMPLOYEES- IS
REALLY COMING INTO CLEAR FOCUS
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THAT THE
ONLY WAY THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN- I HAVE THAT ARE NOT
EMPLOYEES ARE GETTING
UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY PANDEMIC AND
EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IS A SPECIAL PERMIT IS NOT.
BASED PROGRAM I'M THESE ARE THE
KIND OF. THAT WE THE NET OF
EMPLOYMENT- A BASKET OF GOODS
THAT WE ALL PAY INTO AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY BEING CLEAR
WHY THEY ARE SO IMPORTANT- FOR
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES THE SO- IN
TERMS OF YOUR REQUEST ABOUT
GOING AFTER THOSE COMPANIES WE
DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL IN THE
BUDGET ON THAT. OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE PLAN CONTINUE. FOURTH MEANT.
PROGRAM THAT POSED IN JANUARY
THAT WAS A PRIORITY TO MAINTAIN
IN MAY- AND I'M HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU ABOUT YOUR SPECIFIC
REQUESTS. THANK YOU BURGER
MISTER FLORA THE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AND THEN MISTER
BERMAN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS IT'S- GOOD TO BE BACK
ON THE FLOOR WITH YOU TODAY I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS AND REALLY THIS TIME
OF THE DAY MOST OF MY COMMENTS
OF ALL OF IT BOB DYLAN MADE BUT
I LIKE ALSO DOCTOR WOULD HAVE
THE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY HEALTH-
ON THIS PROP FIFTY SIX- READ.
I'M DIRECTING A FINDS IT IS
FASCINATING TO ME COMING FROM A
CENTRAL VALLEY A LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITY- JUST LAST YEAR WE
FOUGHT VERY VERY HARD TO PUT IT
SERVICES COVERED BACK UP MEDI
CAL. AND NOW ON YOUR LATER IT'S
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK AND SO I
THINK FOR ME IN NOT
UNDERSTANDING THIS SIGNIFICANT
OF JUST THAT ONE ASPECT OF THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM IMPOSSIBLE
SYSTEM IN ITS ENTIRETY BUT I
SERVICE THIS I WANT IT IS
DIABETIC PATIENTS. THIS WOULD
BE. THE MOST. TO BE TO UP AND
GET OUT YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
IMPORTANT REGARDING TO LEGAL
WERE. SO HAVING THAT STRIPPED
OUT OF MEDI CAL- I THINK IS
DEVASTATING SIMPLY ONE YEAR
AFTER- IT WAS PUT IN AND IT WAS
STRIPPED OUT INTO THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT IN THE LAST
RECESSION AND WE JUST WERE ABLE
TO GET BACK IN LAST YEAR SO
THAT AS FAR AS- VERY VERY.
CLOSE EYE ON. IT IN THE SECOND
SITUATION I WANT TO JUST BRING
UP. IS THE CLOSURE OF THESE TO
PRISON FACILITIES. YOU KNOW I
GIVEN THE VOLATILITY. AND THE
SERIES NATURE OF THESE
OFFENDERS. A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
MY COMMUNITY. THAT TAKES A LOT
OF THESE FOLKS BACK IN. IT'S MY
COMMUNITY THAT THEY COME BACK
TO. AND MANY MANY TIMES EVEN
TODAY ON THE FLOOR WE TALK
ABOUT. THE RIGHTS OF THE PROOF.
THE PRESS SAFE. I'M ALL. I WHEN
THEY CARS TO. WE SHOULD HAVE.
THE BEST INCARCERATIONS SYSTEM
THAT WE AND- WE SHOULD PROTECT.
FOLKS WELL. NOT STATE. PAUL BUT-
WE'RE MISS. IS THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE TO BE SAFE
WELL. IN WE'RE VERY LONG TIME.
I'VE BEEN THIS BILL SINCE BEEN
ELECT. WE'VE DONE REALIGNMENT
WE'VE REDUCED OUR PRISON
POPULATION WE'VE PUT PEOPLE
BACK IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT MAY
OR MAY NOT BE. YOU KNOW ABLE TO
COPE WITH THAT SO I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS THE
CLOSURE OF THESE TWO PRESENTS
AND THEN SIMPLY WHAT TO PRISONS
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT WE HAVEN'T
EVEN IDENTIFY THOSE AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED TO KNOW WHAT
IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN. SO REALLY
THOSE ARE MY TWO CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THEY MISS RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS AS CHAIR
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS
THIS YEAR I KNOWN SPEAK FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE AND THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE OUR ENTIRE STATE RECOVERS
WITH EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ASSISTANCE WILL MAKE TAKE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES TO ENSURE WE ARE
SUPPORTING ARE VULNERABLE
REGIONS EVERYONE NEEDS GET
THEIR FAIR SHARE. BUDGET MUST
BE WITH EVERY UNIT IN MIND
WRITING A BUDGET IS A SERIOUS
CHALLENGE. BUT A SOUL IS
IMPORTANT THE IMPACT ON
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE IN LOW AND WORKING CLASS
NEIGHBORHOODS. ARSON SOCIAL
SAFETY NET MUST BE PROTECTED
AND PROGRAMS TO MOVE THE
ECONOMY MUST BE INCREASED. OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS HAS BEEN
MADE MORE CHALLENGING SOLUTIONS
LIKE EXPANDING THE TYPES OF
HOUSING CARES ACT FUNDING CAN
BE APPLIED TO WILL BE ESSENTIAL.
IN PARTICULAR I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERING THE CLOSURE OF TO
STATE PRISONS WHEN THIS YEAR.
I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR MEN THE STATE
PRISON IN CHINO. THIS FACILITY
HAS MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES
ALONG WITH THE HIGHEST
INFECTION RATES OF COVERT
NINETEEN IN THE STATE. THE
FACILITY IS A NIGHTMARE HOWEVER
TO CLOSE TO PRISONS MEANS
ADDING MORE INMATES TO CHINO
THIS IS DANGEROUS WITHOUT
NEEDED UPGRADES AND
IMPROVEMENTS. MISTER CHAIR MY
QUESTION IS TO THE PARMA
FINANCE. WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO
UPGRADE CURRENT FACILITIES SUCH
AS GINO TO COUNT FOR HIGHER
POPULATION. THANK YOU. I'M JUST
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS- THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY PROVISION DOES PRIORITIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY ABSOLUTELY- THAT
THE SAVINGS THAT I YOU KNOW
HAVING HAVING BEEN SOMEONE WHO
WORKED ON PUBLIC SAFETY
PROPOSALS MANY YEARS AGO DURING
THE LAST RECESSION WHAT USUALLY
WITH THE DYNAMICIS REALLY A
SPLASHING OF THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
THE OTHER YOU KNOW MAINTAIN THE
REST OF THE PERSON OPERATIONS
AND IN THIS CASE THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE PROPOSAL IS BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A REAL
RECOGNITION BY THIS BODY- AT AS
WELL AS THE AS THE GOVERNOR IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE AT. THE TIME
THAT WE DO HAVE INMATES IN OUR
PRESS IS THAT THEY ARE WORKING
TOWARDS REHABILITATION AND THEN
WILL BE RELEASED TO COMMUNITIES
AND THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
COMMUNITY SAFE WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY LEAVE HAVE LEADS US
PROGRAM. ONE PER. IN OUR IN OUR
BUDGET TO I. WERE COST IN THE
PER SYSTEM AND AT THAT I WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT WITH WAS ON THE
PAROLE TERMS THIS IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED- PROPOSAL- TO
LIMIT THE- CAP THE PAROLE TERMS
FOR A LOT OF INMATES AT. AT TWO
YEARS- AND THE IDEA THERE IS
THAT MOST INMATES AND WHAT MOST
OFFENDERS WHO. PRESIDENT BE AN
ISSUE TO USE ON THE VERY FIRST
FEW MONTHS AND THAT'S REALLY
BEEN BORNE OUT BY RESEARCH. AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY IN
THIS AREA. I'M IN TERMS OF OUR
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AND THIS
BODY- AS WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN
PRIORITIZING I'M ESPECIALLY
THE- FIXING OF ROOFS AND
PRESENT THE CELL AND PRISON
KITCHEN FACILITIES WHICH ARE
SOME OF THE MORE IT YOU KNOW
IMPORTANT TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. OF THE INMATES AND SO
THE STAFF- AND SAID THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE CONTINUING- ADD
AT THE ROUTE THE MULTI YEAR-
BUT NOT AT THE LEVELS THAT WE
HAD HOPED. TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS BUT THOSE THOSE
CONTINUE TO BE PRIORITY
EXPENDITURES THERE NECESSARY IN
TO MAKE. HELL IT'S SAFE. I'M
JUST ONE SALE LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT THE THIRD RIGHT NOW. AND
KEEP THOSE INSTITUTIONAL
POPULATIONS- THE SAFE AND SAID
THAT THERE BECAUSE ABSOLUTELY
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT CAN MOVE
VERY QUICKLY. THROUGH AN
INSTITUTION AND SO THAT AND IN
A IN A BEEN A HIGH PRIORITY-
INCLUDING STOPPING INTAKE- FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS NOW THAT'S
ACTUALLY SO. TO ROUTE. FROM THE
GYM OF BUT THAT ALSO COULD USE
TO BE SOMETHING THAT WERE
WATCHING CLOSELY. THANK YOU.
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO MISTER
BERMAN THAT WE HAVE MISSED
THREE OF US MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
AND MISS QUIRK SILVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M PROUD OF HOW
QUICKLY CALIFORNIA MOVED TO
RECOGNIZE THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE CORONA VIRUS AND TAKE
MEASURES TO LIMIT THE DAMAGE
THAT IS DONE. AS WE REALIZE THE
SERIOUSNESS AND LONG LASTING
NATURE OF THIS PANDEMIC I'M
ALSO PROUD OF A QUICKLY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPACT THIS WILL
HAVE ON OUR NOVEMBER ELECTIONS.
AND THE NEED TO UPDATE OUR
ELECTIONS PROCEDURES TO UPHOLD
THE FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLE THAT
NO CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE TO
RISK IN THEIR HEALTH AND
POSSIBLY THEIR LIFE. TO
EXERCISE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO VOTE. WE MUST AVOID
THE BOTTLE THAT WE SAW ON
WISCONSIN WHERE VOTERS WERE
DISENFRANCHISED WHEN THEY WERE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE
SAFETY OF THEIR HOMES. AND THE
UNKNOWN RISKS VOTING IN PERSON.
IN EARLY APRIL I'M AT AB EIGHT
SIXTY TO REQUIRE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA VOTER. RECEIVE A
BALLOT IN THE MAIL AND HAVE THE
OPTION TO VOTE FROM THE SAFETY
OF THEIR OWN HOME. IN EARLY MAY
THE GOVERNOR FOLLOWED THIS WITH
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO REQUIRE
THE SAME. BOTH MY BILL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN IN PERSON VOTING
OPTIONS FOR THOSE WHO NEED. FOR
MILLIONS OF VOTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THIS WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT TO THE WAY
THEY HAVE VOTED FOR THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE. IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE VOTER
CONFUSION. IF THIS CONFUSION
LEADS TO CALIFORNIANS NOT
VOTING OUT OF FRUSTRATION THEN
ALL WE'VE DONE IS
UNINTENTIONALLY DISENFRANCHISE
A DIFFERENT GROUP OF VOTERS.
THAT IS WHY A STATEWIDE VOTER
EDUCATION AND INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT EVERY VOTER IN
CALIFORNIA UNDERSTANDS THE
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN
PLACE. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION. THIS CAMPAIGN
MUST INCLUDE DIGITAL MEDIA
CAMPAIGN TV ADS DIRECT MAIL AND
RADIO AND STREAMING AUDIO AND
IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE CAMPAIGN
IS CONDUCTED WITH APPROPRIATE
LANGUAGE ACCESS. I KNOW THAT
THEIR ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE IN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR
GENERAL ELECTION. AND WHILE
THEY'RE HEALTHY DISAGREEMENTS
AS TO HOW MUCH THAT BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT SHOULD BE I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DIRECTOR BALLS ALERT.
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND RECOGNITION
THAT IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT NO CALIFORNIA GETS
DISAGREEMENT DISENFRANCHISE
THIS NOVEMBER EITHER DUE TO
FEAR OF IN PERSON VOTING OR DUE
TO CONFUSION ABOUT THE NEW
VOTING YEARS. THANKS. THANK YOU
MISTER RIVERS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT TO OUR COMMITTEE OF
THE WHOLE AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK MISTER SPEAKER AND ALL
OF THE STAFF THAT MADE THIS
HEARING POSSIBLE UNDER THESE
CHALLENGING CERTAIN STANCES ON
THERE JUST A FEW ITEMS THAT I
WON WOULD LIKE TO DRAW SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO AS WE WORK OVER
THE BUDGET IN THESE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS. FIRST CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO MORE THAN TWO MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
ALREADY DISCUSSED THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONTRIBUTING
MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
AND ECONOMY AND ARE ESTIMATED
TO PAY MORE THAN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES INCLUDING INCOME
TAXES AND PROPERTY TAXES. AS A
MEMBER OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATE
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE TAX FILERS OF THESE WE
ARE GENERATING REVENUE FROM
THIS COMMUNITY YEAH WE EXCLUDE
THEM FROM ALL THE PROGRAMS IN
THIS BUDGET AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK SHOULD
BE DOING THEY'RE NOT JUST OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS A LATINO CAUCUS
MEMBER BUT FOR MANY OF YOU IN
THE ROOM THESE ARE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO. BUT YOU SHOULD
BE FIGHTING FOR. NEXT I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO HOMELESSNESS
AS IT RELATES TO THE BUDGET.
EARLIER THIS YEAR OUR GOVERNOR
SPENT HIS WHOLE STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT-
AND IT'S AN A AND A CRISIS IN
OUR STATE- AND IT STILL IS. AND
MAYBE EVEN MORE NOW WITH THE
COVERT NINETEEN SITUATION. I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS I'VE MET
WITH DOZENS OF STAKEHOLDERS
STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES THAT
ALL UP ECHO THE SAME SENTIMENT.
WE MUST CREATE ONE CENTRALIZED
OFFICE AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
COORDINATE THE STATE'S RESPONSE
ON HOMELESSNESS WELL STATE
FUNDING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HOMELESSNESS. FUNDING ALONE
WILL SOLVE THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO OF DISCUSSING
THIS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND- AS WE SEEK TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL ISSUES ON
HOMELESSNESS. NEXT ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND AS A
WOMAN OF COLOR I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A BUDGET THAT REFLECTS
FEMINIST PRIORITIES INCLUDING
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE PROTECTING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR ALL
WOMEN. THESE ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES TO WOMEN
EVERYWHERE ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
LIVE IN LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS A
MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DELEGATION AT HOME TO
THIS THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN OUR STATE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED. I HOPE TO SEE
GREATER EQUITY IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS FOR
STUDENTS WITH MODERATE TO
SEVERE DISABILITIES. STUDENTS
WITH MODERATE TO SEVERE
DISABILITIES INCLUDE STUDENTS
WITH AUTISM- DEAF EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. OTHER
DISABILITIES THAT ONLY SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE MORE OF
THE STUDENTS AND AVE TO
EDUCATE THE STUDENTS AND WE
WANT TO EDUCATE BUT WE NEED
EQUITABLE FUNDING TO ASSURE
THAT THE STUDENTS ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND FUNDING SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS WHO ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES. AND POSE IN
THE MAY REVISION SEVERAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT SERVE ANY
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE AN EQUAL
SHARE AS THOSE WHO DO. FINALLY
TODAY I RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
TWENTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY SCHOOL MEALS AND AS
WE HAVE ALL SEEN MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE STEPPED UP AND
PROVIDED GRABBING GO MEALS TO
ALL CHILDREN IN THEIR AREA AND
MANY FAMILIES WITHOUT CHILDREN
I HAD INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT WAS
ATTEMPTING TO ENSURE THAT
SCHOOL LUNCHES WERE PROVIDED
FOR FREE FOR ALL LOW INCOME
CHILDREN WITHOUT ANY COPAY OR
THE TYPE OF CD. I ALSO HAD A
BILL THAT WAS TRYING TO MAKE
COULD IDENTIFY HOMELESS
CHILDREN WHO OFTEN GO HUNGRY
AND DEPEND ON SCHOOL MEALS AS
THEIR ONLY MEAL FOR THAT HEY.
WHAT WHAT MY BILLS WERE HELD
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THIS BUDGET
TO ENSURE THAT THE CHILDREN OF
OUR GREAT STATE DON'T GO
HUNGRY. ULTIMATELY WE WILL BE
JUDGED BY THE DECISIONS WE MAKE
IN THE WEEKS TO COME I HOPE
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT NO
CHILD SHOULD GO HUNGRY. OR
WITHOUT A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
THANK YOU THANK YOU REAGAN THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY THAN THIS. QUIRK
SILVA AND THEN MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TING IN
MEMBERS. WE ARE UNION PRESS
ATTEND THE TIME ALL OF US
PUTTING OUR JANUARY PLANS AND
ASPIRATIONS AWAY AND REFOCUSING
TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
OF OUR STATE AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS. UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
WILDFIRES IN OUR DISTRICTS YEAR
AFTER YEAR STATE EMERGENCIES
ARE BECOMING ENORMOUS. PLUS
EVEN UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
WHEN YOU REPRESENT SMALL TOWNS
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES YOU
REALIZE ACCESS IS EVERYTHING.
BECAUSE OF THIS MY PRIORITIES
OF THE LEGISLATOR HAVE BEEN THE
SAME IT WILL STAY THE SAME.
THEY ARE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN HEALTH CARE.
THE CIVIC PLEA TELEHEALTH. IT
IS FELT IT'S TAKEN A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC TO BRING THIS TO THE
pBY MY CONSTITUENTS AND NOW
YOURS CAN NO LONGER BE IGNORED
TECHNOLOGY IS THE ONLY WAY FOR
MANY PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE EDUCATION TRAINING
AG. POST PANDEMIC BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND MUCH MORE.
WITHOUT BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY
PEOPLE IN SMALL TOWNS AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE
AMONGST THE POOREST AND SICKEST
CALIFORNIANS WILL FALL FURTHER
AND FURTHER BEHIND URBAN AND
SUBURBAN PEERS. LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH TODAY HAS MADE SURE
THE TELEHEALTH SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE IN REIMBURSED DURING
AN EMERGENCY. I AUTHORED AB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR THREE CARTEL
HEALTH PAYMENT PARITY WHICH HAS
BECOME A LIFELINE TO OUR
STATE'S PHYSICIANS PRACTICES.
THESE TELEHEALTH LAWS CRITICAL
TO MY CONSTITUENTS AXES HAVE
GIVEN ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
ACCESS TO CARE AND CONTINUITY
OF CARE DURING THE CALL BUT
NINETEEN CRISIS. THIS BUDGET
MUST PROTECT THAT ACCESS TO
CARE FOR ALL COMMUNITIES URBAN
AND RURAL BUT LACK ACCESS. TELL
HEALTH REIMBURSEMENT IN MEDI
CAL SHOULD NOT BE CONTINGENT ON
A STATE WIDE DISASTER THE
TELEHEALTH PARITY MUST BE
REALIZED. FURTHER I STAND AGAIN
FLUSHING PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. THIS WOULD UNDERCUT
THE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT
WE HAVE MADE TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO CARE IN THE MID A SAFETY NET
PROGRAM FOR SO MANY PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE. THIS IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT TODAY IT WILL BE
ESSENTIAL POST CLOVER. ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMAN'S CAUCUS WE
CARE ABOUT A FEMINIST BUDGET
THAT INCLUDES ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE PROTECTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY FOR WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
AS YOU KNOW ARE UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
AT EVERY ESSENTIAL FUNCTION
DURING THIS CRISIS. THEY HAVE
BEEN HIT HARD BY COBIT BOTH
FINANCIALLY. AND WITH REGARDS
TO THE HEALTH. WE CANNOT LEAVE
THEM OUT OF A OUT OF OUR
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
INCLUDING THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT WHICH WILL NOT
COMPENSATE THEM FOR BEING
EXPOSED AND DURING SHELTER
ORDERS BUT AT LEAST AT LEAST
WILL NOT COMPLETELY ABANDON
THEM WHEN THEY NEED. OUR HELP
THE MOST. WE KNOW THAT THERE
MUST BE SIGNIFICANT CUTS
DEFERRALS OF OUR DREAMS WHICH
IT SEEMS SO ATTAINABLE FOUR
MONTHS AGO. HOWEVER WE MUST
PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS THAT WE
LITERALLY CANNOT LIVE WITHOUT.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS OUR STATES PEOPLE AND
ECONOMY. THE AXIS OF OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES RELY
ON AND THE PHYSICAL MENTAL AND
ECONOMIC HEALTH OF OUR PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCHES FROM THE BRINK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WERE GOING TO
GO IN THIS QUIRK SILVA. THANK
YOU- MS SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN A HISTORIC
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE. THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US AS
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS TO
LISTEN AND TO HEAR OTHERS
PRIORITIES TO HEAR FROM OUR
EXPERTS AND TO LEARN. I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
OUR SENIORS. OUR DISABLED
COMMUNITIES. OUR FOSTER YOUTH
AND WE NEED TO FULLY INVEST IN
EDUCATION. WE NEED TO MAKE
THOSE IMPORTANT PRIORITIES AS
WE KNOW THOSE ARE CALIFORNIA
VALUES. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
KEEP OUR PROMISE WE NEED TO
KEEP OUR PROMISE TO NOT SUPPORT
A BUDGET THAT RATES ARE GAS
TAX. WE MADE THAT PROMISE TO
OUR CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND I
WILL NOT SUPPORT A BUDGET THAT
DOES THAT. HOWEVER I WILL
SUPPORT A BUDGET THE GETS
CALIFORNIANS WORKING. I WANT TO
FOCUS MY BUDGET PROP PRIORITIES
ON. ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING. ADDRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND INVESTING IN
CHILD CARE. WHEN WE LOOK AT
HOMELESSNESS IN HOUSING THOSE
TWO ISSUES GO TOGETHER WE MUST
BUILD AND WE MUST BUILD QUICKLY
AS WE KNOW THAT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS MANY ARE HOMELESS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT IF WE DO RETURN
TO SOME TYPE OF NORMALCY ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION IS GOING TO
HAVE INCREASED WE KNOW THAT
RIGHT NOW MANY ARE ON THE VERGE
OF EVICTIONS SO WE MUST WE MUST
LOOK AT. DOING WHAT THE
GOVERNOR SAID IN JANUARY WHICH
IS USING OUR STATE LANDS. TO
HOUSE PEOPLE AND WE NEED TO YOU
HOUSE PEOPLE AND ECONOMIC WAY
THAT STREAMLINES HOUSING AND
BUILDING. MENTAL HEALTH WE KNOW
THAT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE
NOT BEEN ADDRESSED THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN A PRIORITY AND YET THE
COST OUR STATE IN OUR COUNTIES
IN OUR CITIES ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY WHEN PEOPLE NOW ARE
SUFFERING FROM SOME TYPE OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE THEY ARE
TYPICALLY. GO TO EMERGENCY
ROOMS OR ARE RESTED AND I IN
OUR IN OUR COUNTY JAILS THIS IS
A HUGE COST TO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE NEED TO MAKE MENTAL
HEALTH JUST THE SAME PRIORITY
AS HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH GO TOGETHER. THIRD I
WANT TO FOCUS ON CHILD CARE AS
THE MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WE KNOW THAT WE
CANNOT RETURN TO WORK AND A
VIBRANT ECONOMY WITH OUT. SAFE
CHILD CARE AND WITH OUT FULLY
FUNDED OUR CHILD CARE. WE NEED
TO OBJECT TO A 10% CUT. IF
CHILD CARE WORKERS CAN NOT
COUNT ON INCOME THAT COMES IN
AND IS STEADFAST WAY THEY WERE
CLOSE AND OUR FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY MOTHERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO GET BACK TO WORK WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO WORK
IT IS ESSENTIAL. TO GETTING
CALIFORNIA MOVING AAIN TO
INVEST IN CHILD CARE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU I'M GONNA GO
TO. THIS POWER CARE BECAUSE
SHE'S GOING TO SWITCH WITH MR
MULLIN. AND THEN- MISTER GIBSON
THEN- DOCTOR JEWELRY AND THEN
MISS MR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO GIVE
VOICE TO THE VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. WHO NEED VOICE
TODAY TO ENSURE THAT OUR BUDGET
PRIORITIZE THEM AS IT SHOULD.
IT IS OFTEN SAID AND IT'S BEEN
SAID HERE TODAY THAT OUR BUDGET
SHOULD BE A STATEMENT OF OUR
VALUES. AND IT SHOULD AND NOT
IS WHAT I ASKED TODAY AND THIS
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE AND THIS
BODY THAT WE HOLD TRUE TO OUR
VALUES AND FUND THE PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE THAT NEED US MOST SO
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S WOMEN. AND
CHILDREN. I AM SOBRE ABOUT THE
FISCAL REALITIES WE FACE.
UNDERSTANDING WE MUST MAKE HARD
DECISIONS TO BALANCE THIS
BUDGET. WE MUST DO SO ONE NOT
MAKING THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS PAY THE MAJORITY
OF THAT PRICE. CUTS TO OUR
SENIORS OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
WOMEN ARE DEVASTATING IN THE
PROPOSED MAY REVIVE. IS NOT WHO
WE ARE AS A STATE. FIRST FOR
THE WOMEN OF CALIFORNIA. AS
CHAIRPERSON OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH WE HAVE
SPENT THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
EXAMINING THE ISSUES AROUND
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
CALIFORNIA IS GRAPPLING WITH
EPIDEMIC LEVELS OF STI. IN
EXPERTS EXPECT THE RECENT THOSE
RATE OF THOSE FDIC INCREASE. AS
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
ITS AFTERMATH CONTINUE. PLAN
HEARD HEALTH CENTERS ARE SEEING
AN INCREASE IN POSITIVE
PREGNANCY TEST IN SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS ARE RACING FOR AN
INCREASE IN UNINSURED PATIENTS.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO CUT
FUNDING FOR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. IN THE MIDDLE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX IS THE
BACKBONE OF MANY REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS LIKE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHO'VE
ALREADY BEEN FACED WITH A RASH
OF ATTACKS FROM ANTI ABORTION
LAWMAKERS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE MUST BE
A PRIORITY IN THIS BUDGET. AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
HEALTH CARE. THE LIVES AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS ARE ON
THE LINE. AND LET ME BE CLEAR A
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CUT
TO FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES. IS
A ONE BILLION DOLLAR LOSS IN
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA.
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
CURRENTLY RECEIVING ENHANCED
FEDERAL MATCHING OF NINE TO ONE
TO ENCOURAGE ACCESS TO THOSE
SERVICES THIS IS THE HIGHEST
FEDERAL MATCHING. RATE OF ANY
TYPE OF SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA
IF THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
MAY REVISED IS ADOPTED PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WOULD LOSE THOSE
FEDERAL FUNDS. WHICH HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED THROUGH
THE END OF DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS MEANS ALL THE
WE MAY SAVE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BY CUTTING THE
SERVICES. WE LOSE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE CARE FOR FAMILY
PACKED AND MEDI CAL PATIENTS.
THAT IS NOT SMART FISCAL
DECISION MAKING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES WILL BE
FORCED TO LAY OFF STAFF
PATIENTS WILL SEE INCREASED
WAIT TIMES SERVICES AND FUNDING
FOR ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS WILL BE
CUT INCLUDING SEX EDUCATION
CLINIC ESCORTS IN HEALTH
CENTERS WILL CLOSE.WITH OUR TO
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS LOSE
ACCESS TO CARE LIFESAVING
SERVICES LIKE CANCER SCREENINGS
AND WELLNESS VISITS WILL KNOW
LEARN LONGER BE ACCESSIBLE IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THAT
NEED IT MOST. A CALIFORNIA
REACHES HISTORIC LEVELS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT IT IS ANTICIPATED
THE TWO POINT SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIA WORKERS INDEPENDENCE
ARE AT RISK OF LOSING EMPLOYER
BASED HEALTH CARE. THOSE
PATIENTS WILL LIKELY TURN TO
THE SAFETY NET PROVIDERS.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDS ARE
THE BACKBONE OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD TO KEEP DOORS OPEN
AND PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE
SO I WANNA KNOW HAVE THESE
FEDERAL DOLLARS DIDN'T COUNTED
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE CUTS WERE
MAKING ARE WE MAKING THE RIGHT
DECISIONS. I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK
FOR THE CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE MOTHER OF THREE SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN IN ONE OF THE
LOWEST FUNDED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THIS STATE THERE IS NOTHING
LEFT TO CUT EXCEPT THE QUALITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION. THE 10% ACROSS THE
BOARD CUTS TO SCHOOLS IS THE
LARGEST CUT WITH KIND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET IT'S
MORE THAN 25% OF THE CUTS WE
ARE MAKING. WHAT DOES THIS SAY
ABOUT OUR VALUES OUR CHILDREN
ARE OUR FUTURE AND THEY DESERVE
OUR INVESTMENT NOT OUR
LEFTOVERS. MY DISTRICT HAS CUT
EVERYTHING THERE IS TO CAST AND
IT WILL BE STUDENT SERVICES THE
TAKE THIS HEAD. PLEASE MEMBERS.
LET US NOT MAKE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN PAY THE PRICE. BUT
YOU'RE GONNA GO MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WANTED
DID- WHAT A LOT OF HER THUS FAR.
WANT TO BRING UP THREE VERY
IMPORTANT POINTS ONLY THREE.
ONE MAR THE KING COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL. I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULTIES IN ADDRESSING THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS BUT I
RISE TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS
UNFORTUNATELY THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVIVED A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ELIMINATE.
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING I SAID
ELIMINATE SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
TOMORROW THE KING COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL MURDER THE KING
HOSPITAL OFFERS A HIGH QUALITY
CARE TO ONE OF THE MOST.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA SOUTH LOS ANGELES
SAVINGS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY REPRESENTS SEVENTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
ITS GENERAL FUND. LOSING AN
UPWARDS OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR WITH
SIMILAR LOSSES EACH YEAR. LONG
TERM ABSENCE OF THIS FUNDING
THE HOSPITAL'S FINANCIAL
STRUCTURE WAS ORIGINALLY
PLANNED WITH THREATEN THE VERY
VOLATILITY OF THIS HOSPITAL. IT
WILL REQUIRE CUTS THAT WAS
SEVERELY REDUCE THE SCOPE OF
CARE PARTICULARLY IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM DEPARTMENT MOST
CERTAINLY LEADS TO PREVENTABLE
LOSS OF LIFE. IN MY DISTRICT.
THIS IS THE WORST POSSIBLE TIME
TO REDUCE BURNS FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITIES WHO MORTALITY RATE
FOR COVERT NINETEEN IS
PREDICTED TO BE FOUR TIMES THE
FOUR TIMES THAT OF OTHER
COMMUNITIES. MY SECOND POINT
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT MY
DISTRICT IS COMPRISED OF SOME
OF THE POOREST COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
STAND HERE TODAY TO FIGHT ON
THE BARE ON THEIR BEHALF
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT IS
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS.
WERE CUT BY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE MAY REVISE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUDGET. THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE INCOME SUPPORT TO
PEOPLE WHO COULD NOT FIND JOBS
IN THE REGULAR LABOR MARKET
PARTICULARLY DOING APPEARED OF
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT LIKE NOW
WE'VE ALREADY INDICATED FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW ON.
WE SHOULD LOOK FOR WAYS TO
STRENGTHEN OUR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT NOT TO CHIP AWAY AT
IT. WHY ARE WE MAKING CUTS TO
RESOURCES THAT PREPARE THE
CRITICAL WORK FORCE BECAUSE WE
ARE ALL. WE ALL KNOW ALL TOO
WELL THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
WILL BE HURT THOSE ARE OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND IT
WILL RESULT IN HOMELESSNESS IN
THIS STATE IT IS OUR SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THEIR
NEEDS. I WILL KEEP ON FIGHTING
TO MAKE SURE THE JOB IS IN THE
FOREFRONT AND SO HE PEOPLE CAN
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE IS IN OUR
CHILDREN'S BACKS AND A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD MY THIRD. CALL
THE CLUBS NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE GIMLI
CONTROL FUNDS MONIES THAT CARD
ROOMS WERE OVER CHARGED WITH
ALLOCATED SOMEWHERE ELSE TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC. FASTER BUT THIS
WERE HAVE THIS INTO THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EMPLOYING
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS IT WAS THIRTY
SECONDS. IT WAS THE SPECIAL
BOND THAT OF THE CAR ROOM CLUBS
HAVE CREATED AND THEY PAY INTO
IT WOULD NOT HAVE IMPACTED THE
CALIFORNIA. ECONOMY OR THE
GENERAL FUND THESE CAR RULES
ALLOW THE CONTINUES PAYMENTS OF
EMPLOYEES CRITICAL FUNDS TO
THOSE EMPLOYEES. MORE OVER
FURTHERMORE SKEWS ME I WANT TO
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
GRAY AND OTHERS WHO HAVE SEIZE
THE MOMENT OF DIFFICULTIES TO
CREATE A SOLUTION TO CREATE
REVENUE FOR OUR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE ALL HAVE THE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICT WHO
ARE THE WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
ECONOMIC DISASTER THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THESE SOLUTIONS MY
CITY OF THE CITY OF COMPTON.
WILL BE THE FIRST ONE TO WRAP
UP PLEASE MAKE YES WILL BE THE
FIRST OF ALL THAT LIST I
SUPPORT- VOTERS HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON SPORTS
WAIT WHAT. PORTS WEIGHTS OF
BETTING HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BRING NEW REVENUE
MEMBERS THIS. BUDGET IS
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT WE MUST DO
OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE IT DOES
NOT HURT THE MOST VULNERABLE
MOTHERS THANK. THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO GO. UP TO CHOI MISTER
STONE MISS SMITH AND THEN THIS
TO HOLD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TEN
AND- THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
SO- ARE. EMBRACING THE
DIFFICULT A PANDEMIC TIME.
MEMBERS IT IS SO OVERWHELMING
AND AT THE SAME TIME TROUBLING.
OUT TO HEAR THE PROPOSED A
BUDGET UP BY I WILL GOVERNOR.
AS OUR LA- AND THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE UP GOING OUT. THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF OUR AREAS SO OF
COURSE THE BUDGET. THAT THE
REYES US YOUR YES OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE ROLE IN
FUTURE FINANCIAL. POSITIONS
THERE IS A UNIQUE TO AND THE
SENSITIVE TIME WHERE ARE WE-
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY- WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. FOR WHAT THE
STATE DOES WHAT DOES NOT DO IN
DISPENSING OF THE OP BUDGET AND
THE STATE'S SO RESOLUTIONS WHAT
DOES STATE SO RESOURCES SO. IN
THAT TIME IN OUR UNIQUE-
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A ANSWER FOR HOW
WE ADDRESS TO THIS A HISTORIC
BUDGET THE CHALLENGES. I URGE
ALL COLLEAGUES TO WORK OF
VIGOROUSLY VIGOROUSLY TO ENSURE
A TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE WORK IN
THE BI PARTISAN EFFORT TO MEET
THESE CHALLENGES. YOUR THANK
YOU WILL GO TO MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS KEEP YOUR SPEECHES WARM
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
WHEN WE ACTUALLY VOTE ON THIS
THING. THIS IS A DIFFICULT
BUDGET AND DIFFICULT TIMES AND
ACTUALLY WHAT BETTER TIME THAN
A CRISIS LIKE THIS THAN TO HAVE
A FEMINIST BUDGET. BUDGET
FOCUSED ON FAMILIES AND OUR
MOST VULNERABLE THAT. THAT'S
GREAT SO TO THE SUB FIVE CHAIR
IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
REALIGNING DEPARTMENT JUVENILE
JUSTICE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THANK YOU THAT IS A GOOD
PROPOSAL THE DEVIL WILL BE IN
THE DETAILS AND HOW IT'S
IMPLEMENTED CLOSING PRESENCE
AGAIN SO FIVE IS BEEN ASKING
ABOUT FOR AWHILE SO APPRECIATE
SEEING THAT LET'S LET'S WORK
TOGETHER ON THAT AS WELL. TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE SUB
ONE CHAIR. COUNTIES RIGHT NOW
OR IN THE MIDDLE OF
IMPLEMENTING THE CONTINUING
CARE REFORM. AND THERE ARE
VULNERABLE TIME. BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT JUST REALLY RAMPING
UP INVESTMENTS IN THE RESOURCE
FAMILY NETWORKS THE FOSTER
FAMILY RESOURCE FAMILY
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT. AND
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT ANECDOTALLY
SEEMS TO BE HAPPENING THERE IS
A LIKELIHOOD THAT THAT SYSTEM
WE'LL SEE MORE INPUT BECAUSE OF
THE STRESS IS BEING PUT ON
FAMILIES NOW. SO I AM HOPING
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN THAT SYSTEM GOD
FORBID WE NEED IT BUT WE
PROBABLY WILL NEED IT AND IF
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. KEEPING KIDS AT
HOME OR GIVING THEM SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED PRECLUDES. YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AND IF WE CAN
ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WE
PRECLUDE INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF ADULT HOMELESS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. SO THESE ARE HONESTLY
INVESTMENTS WE CAN AD SHOULD
BE MAKING NOW. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
SHORT CHANGING THOSE EFFORTS IN
THIS BROADER SENSE OVER THIS
BROADER NEED OF MANAGING THE
BUDGET WHICH IS HAS BEEN A
DIFFICULT TASK AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION.
TAKING THAT DEEP DIVE BUT WE
ALSO TALK ABOUT IT WE BEMOAN.
THE CUTS. AND WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT THE EXPENSE SIDE BUT
AS ANY. ORGANIZATIONS GOING TO
DO WHEN YOU CAN'T LOOK AT THE
EXPENSE SIE WITHOUT ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT THE REVENUE SIDE. AS
WELL AND I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN
FIND AND WORK TOGETHER TO FIND.
BETTER SOURCES OF REVENUE WE
HAVE TO REACH THANK THE
REVENUES IN THE TAXATION SYSTEM
MULTIMILLION CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
WE ARE VULNERABLE TO THESE KIND
OF CHANGE AS- THESE UPS AND
DOWNS DONE A GOOD. SALTING THEM
AWAY. BUT WE'RE GONNA BURN
THROUGH THAT VERY QUICKLY WE
HAVE STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS THAT
ARE NOT JUST EXPENSE PROBLEMS
BUT THERE REVENUE PROBLEMS AND
I THINK WE HAVE TO ADMIT TO.
MAY THAT IT BETTER WILL. WE'RE
GONNA MISS MRS A BY PASS IN HER
TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MR
HOLDEN. FOR C. WORKING HIS WAY
BACK AN THEN MISTER NAZARIAN
IN THE MIDST BURKE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MR VICE CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS AS A MEMBER OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION I
RISE TO SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF
EDUCATION. PART OF THIS
RECESSION CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
WERE ALREADY UNDER FUNDED. AND
IN MY DISTRICT SCHOOLS WERE
ALREADY CLOSING TO SAVE MONEY.
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
PROPOSES A 10% CUT AND LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. THIS
WOULD BE DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND TEACHERS.
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE WORKING TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS HAS
PUSHED FOR REFORM TO THE LCL F.
THAT EXPANDS FUNDING FOR MORE
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY THE
LOWEST PERFORMING SUBGROUP. WE
BELIEVE THIS WOULD FUND THE
LITERAL GAP IN L. CFL AND GO A
LONG WAY IN ADDRESSING
DISPARITIES IN EDUCATION FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. BUT
INSTEAD OF MOVING FORWARD WE'RE
NOW STEPPING BACKWARDS. WITH
BIG CUTS. A 10% CUT TO L. CFF
EQUATES TO THE FRONT FOLLOWING
CUTS. THIS WOULD LOOK LIKE A
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
DOLLAR DECREASED PER STUDENT
SPENDING. EIGHT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN DOLLAR FUNDING CUT.
PASSWORD IN A NINETEEN POINT 1%
INCREASE IN CLASS SIZE. I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS MUST BE MADE WITH
THESE PROPOSED CUTS WOULD STRIP
DISTRICTS OF THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO RE OPEN SAFELY. WHICH
IS CRITICAL THE RECOVERY OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY. HOWEVER I
BELIEVE AN INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS
WHICH IS WHY I WROTE AND
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THE COLLEGE
AND CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS
PROGRAM. IT GIVES SCHOOLS THE
ABILITY TO CREATE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. BUT SCHOOLS NEED THE
FUNDS TO BE CREATIVE AND PUSH
PROGRAMS FOR. WHICH IS WHY THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES.
AND THE GOVERNOR TO ALSO BE
INNOVATIVE INSURE OUR STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS ARE PRIORITIZE
DURING THE TOUGH BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH BY THE BACK TO MR
MULLIN FOR A QUICK SECOND
THOUGH I HAVE- NAZARIAN BURKE
RAMOS AND DAVID CHIU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THE QUESTION
IS FOR MR PROTECT. THEIR BEEN
SOME DISCUSSIONS AROUND-
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. ROACHES
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE DEALING WITH
BUDGETS AND IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS WERE TO
MAKE BUT IN TERMS OF
RECOVERING. FROM WHAT THE
ECONOMY. IS CONFRONTING RIGHT
NOW WE TALK ABOUT SOME BONDS A
JOBS BOND CLIMATE RESILIENCY
BOND WHICH COULD HAVE SOME JOB
CREATING A FAX THERE'S ALSO A
DISCUSSION AROUND. A SECURE
TIES SAYING. A SPECIAL FUNDS
FOR EXAMPLE TO- ESSENTIALLY GET
MONEY OUT ON THE STREET AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO HAVE
SOME STIMULATIVE A FAX- JUST
GIVEN WHERE WE ARE WITH
INTEREST RATES AND SO FORTH ARE
THERE PREFERRED APPROACH IS ON
FROM THE ALLEY- STANDPOINT ON
HOW WE MIGHT GO ABOUT THIS OR
IT WILL BE. TENSION WE
SOMETHING UP A MIX UP TALK
ABOUT A- IN THE THIS OF THE
SAME KIND OF A CONVERT. I'M A
CO. I THINK IS WILLING TO PUT
MISTER MALONE I CAN OFFER A
COUPLE OF INITIAL THOUGHTS AND
PERHAPS MY COLLEAGUES BACK IN
THE OFFICE COULD WEIGH IN AS
WELL- IN GENERAL INTEREST RATES
ARE LOW YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS THAT
IS A GOOD TIME TO BORROW FOR
PROJECTS THE ONE THING WE WOULD
JUST MENTIONED I BELIEVE IS
THAT. LOT OF TIMES THERE'S A
SUBSTANTIAL LEAD TIME FROM THE
POINT WHEN YOU DECIDE YOU WOULD
WANT TO GO DOWN THAT PATH TO
GETTING THE VOTER APPROVAL
NECESSARY TO GET TO RANGING THE
FINANCING IDENTIFYING PROJECT
BY THE TIME YOU GET THE MONEY
OUT YEAH HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE
STARTING A ECONOMIC EVERY TAP
SO. THE CHALLENGE AT THE TIME I
MEAN IF IT. IT SO I DON'T KNOW
IF MY ARE AVAIL IN THE U. I.
YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE AVAILABLE I
THINK THEY COME ON THE SCREEN
WHEN THEY START TALKING. SO
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TOLD. CAN YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES SOME FOR
CAROLINE GO AHEAD CHARACTER
HOWEVER. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I JUST A FEW POINTS
WHICH ACTUALLY OCCURRED ADD TO
WHAT MISTER PECK SAID AS YOU
KNOW WITH THE STATE ALSO FACES
A CHALLENGE IN THE FACT THAT IT
CAN'T IT CAN'T DEFICIT SPEND.
THERE ARE SOME AREAS WHERE THE
STATE- CAN SERVE INDIRECTLY DO
THIS THAT WE THAT WE RAISE OF
AN OFFICE INCLUDING- EXTENDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ARE THINKING ABOUT OPTIONS
RELATED TO THE- IT DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM BUT WE ARE
CONSTRAINED- PARTICULARLY IN
TERMS OF HOW QUICKLY WE COULD
GET THE MONEY OUT WHERE WE GO
DOWN THE BOND FINANCING. AS IT
RELATES OF APPROVAL- BUT WE
CERTAINLY CAN HELP ARE YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT MAKES OF
SOLUTIONS YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO
AND IF THEY'RE PARTICULARLY-
ITEMS THAT YOU- AS A BODY
DECIDE TO PURSUE WE CERTAINLY
CAN HELP YOU ARE. ON THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I'M
WORKING THROUGH THE TRIP. UP
FOR THOSE ITEMS. DOES THAT
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. BURKE WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
MISSION IS VERY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FIRST OF ALL OF FOR
ALL THE WONDERFUL POINTS THAT
WERE MADE AND GIVING VOICE TO
ALL THE VOICELESS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHETHER
IT'S- OUR YOUTH AND FOSTER CARE
OR- OUR NEIGHBORS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED- NEIGHBORS I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO MISS
PARKER FOR BEING HERE WITH US I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BEING
FIRST STEP AND- SERIES OF THE
LOGS AND CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING. IN ORDER
TO GET TO A THE OF THAT UNDER
THE WORST CIRCUMSTANCES CAN CAN
HAVE SOME- PRESERVES BENEFITS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
DECADE. THE LOS ANGELES
DELEGATION. WHICH ALSO THE-
SUFFERS FROM THE IMPACTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN. AS WELL AS THE
OTHER EPIDEMIC THAT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH UP UNTIL COVERT
NINETEEN STRUCK OUR
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE. THAT HAS
ALSO BEEN DISPROPORTIONATE AND
LOS ANGELES. I WANTED TO FOCUS
AS CHAIR OF AGING COMMITTEE ON-
ON THE IMPACTS OF- WHAT IT WHAT
THIS BUDGET IS DOING TO OUR
SENIORS AND ARE FRAIL. TING
COMMUNITY. UP FIRST POINT AT
WHEN WE ALL SHARE CONCERNS FOR
SENIORS BECAUSE OF CORBETT AND
CAN RATES. AND THAT'S ARE WE
CONSIDERING. PROGRAM THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOR SENIORS WERE
CERTIFIED ELIGIBLE FOR SKILLED
NURSING. BUT LOOK AT HOME. THIS
PROGRAMS THE CIVIC. PROGRAMS
THAT SEND THE CENTER BASED
ADULTS OR PREFER A BILL TO THE
USER AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
MORE COST EFFECTIVE ELIMINATING
THESE PROGRAMS SIMPLY MEANS
TRANSFERRING THE POPULATION TO
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
THERE WILL NOT ONLY BE GREATER
UNCERTAINTY FOR PATIENTS BUT
INCREASED MORBIDITY. ESTACION
PUT OUT A STATEMENT. THAT A
PROGRAM CALLED SKILLED NURSING
AT HOME WILL BE IN PLACE
SOMETIME IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS IS THIS WAS AS OF- FOUR
O'CLOCK FOUR PM LAST FRIDAY.
THIS WAS A STATEMENT WITH NO
DETAILS AND COMMITTEE DATE
DON'T MISS THE ELIMINATION OF
THE STAFFS AND ASSIST. PLEASE
IT HOW THE- OVERALL BUT THIS IS
AN OVERALL BUDGET SAVINGS AND
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'M JUST
GOING TO GO THROUGH MY POINTS.
AND SO FAR THERE'S BEEN TWO
QUESTIONS- NEXT IS A SENIOR
NEXT AREA IS THE SENIOR
NUTRITION WHAT WE COMMONLY KNOW
AS MEALS ON WHEELS AND OTHER
CONGREGATE NUTRITION PROGRAMS
ARE BEING CUT BY NEARLY HALF.
THERE HAS BEEN AN INCREASE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOUR SEATER
MEET DELIVERY AND THE AREA IN
SEASON AGING HAVE MET THE
INCREASEDNEED. HOW ARE WE
CONSIDER HEADING BASS LINE
THING TO A PROGRAM THAT HAS HAD
AN OVERWHELMING INCREASED BY
HALF. AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE
INCREASING FUNDING TO OTHER
NUTRITION PROGRAMS LIKE FOOD
BANKS THAT MOST SENIORS IN MILK
YOU CAN ACCESS. THE KOBE
GUIDELINES HAVE THEM SHELTERING
WELL BEYOND OTHERS. FOOD IS ONE
OF THE MOST BASIC AS WE HAVE
HOW CAN WE EXPECT OUR AGENCY
I'M SORRY BUT CUT THIS
MAGNITUDE AND STILL NEED THE
BASE NEEDS US HERE'S- WHAT NOT
LEAST. SERVICE CENTER. PROVIDES
IS AT REST PAGE FOR THE- THIS
REMOVES KERN AND BUDGET. AND
TAKES THEM TO LINE THEY SEEN
THE RECESSION DURING THIS
DURING FROM SINCE THE LAST
GREATRECESSION DURING THIS
PANDEMIC FAMILY CARE GIVERS ARE
ALREADY SEEN LIMITED SERVICES
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND ARE
HAVING TO FILL NEEDS THAT MANY
RELY ON THE TRAINING THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER PROVIDE
AGAIN THEY PROVIDE SERVICES
TRAININGS AND RESPITE TO UNPAID
FAMILY CARE GIVERS CUTTING
FUNDING WILL LIKELY CAUSE AN
INCREASE OF SENIORS GOING INTO
SKILLED NURSING OR LEAVING THEM
IN UNSAFE SITUATIONS.
COLLEAGUES LET'S NOT FORGET%
THESE CUTS ARE BEING PROPOSED
AT A TIME WHEN WE NO OUR AGING
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA WILL
BE INCREASING FROM WHAT IT
CURRENTLY 12% IS THE RELATION
TO TWENTY FIVE OF THE STATE'S
POP. WITH THE NEXT FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA NAGA MISS BURKE THING WE
HAVE RAMOS DAVID CHIU. AND MR
DAILY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS A FAMILY THAT WAS
STRUCK WITH COVERT NINETEEN WE
KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE FEAR AND
UNCERTAINTY THIS VIRUS CAN
BRING. WE STRUGGLE TO FIND
TASKS AND I HAD TO TELL MY
DAUGHTER THAT THE VIRUS THAT
ENDED HER SCHOOL YEAR. THAT WAS
KEEPING US HOME. THAT STOP THE
WORLD IN ITS TRACKS WAS NOW
PART OF OUR LIVES. THE HARDEST
PART OF THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS.
WAS THAT I COULDN'T PROMISE MY
DAUGHTER BETTER DAD WOULD BE
OKAY. BUT I CAN'T PROMISE WAS
THAT NO MATTER WHAT. I WOULD
LOVE HER I WOULD TAKE CARE OF
HER TO THE BACK OF MY
EXPERIENCE KNOWLEDGE AND
ABILITY. IT'S ALSO A PROMISE
THAT I NEED TO EVERY CALIFORNIA
CHILD THE DAD WAS SWORN IN. IT
IS BECAUSE OF THAT PROMISE I
RIE TO SPEAK TODAY. OUR STATE
HOME RESTRICTIONS HAVE
NECESSARILY BUT ARTIFICIALLY
CONSTRAINED OUR SUPPLY DEMAND
IS STILL THERE. THOSE WHO CAN
STILL ONE OF BY YOU CAN SEE IN
IN THE LINES AT THE GROCERY
STORES AND THE THOUSANDS OF
DELIVERY TRUCKS RUNNING AROUND
OUR CITIES. PEOPLE WANT TO BUY
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
BUSINESSES CAN RESPOND TO THAT
DEMAND BY BEING ABLE TO AMONG
OTHER THINGS FIND TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED. EMPLOYEES VERY AND
ROBIN ON. THIS RECESSION HAS
FALLEN HARDEST ON THOSE WHO CAN
LEAST AFFORD IT. THESE WORKERS
ARE RELYING ON A SOCIAL SAFETY
NET IN ORDER TO WEATHER THIS
STORM. OUR SISTER DIRECTED TO
SEE CASES INCREASED TO SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ABOUT A 100% INCREASE.
75% OF WHICH RECIPIENTS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THESE NUMBERS
DEEPLY DOES THIS FOR THE NEED
TO CREATE OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA DEPENDS AS WE
NAVIGATE UNCHARTERED WATERS. I
AM HOWEVER ENCOURAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S DECISION TO CONTINUE
FLEXIBLE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND CAL WORK TO
CHANGE THAT I PROPOSED TO MAKE
PERMANENT AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN. HOWEVER I AM
DISHEARTENED BY THE NEARLY A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CUT TO EXPANDED
SUBSIDIZE EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS
WITHIN CAO WORKS. WE MADE
SIMILAR CUTS IN OUR LAST
RECESSION A GREATLY
DETERIORATED THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THOSE PROGRAMS. IN MY
DISTRICT THE SOUTH BAY WITH
NOTES THAT THIS WILL RESULT IN
AN IMMEDIATE INTEREST DRASTIC
REDUCTION IN PARTICIPATION IN
THEIR PROGRAMS FROM TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES TWO FIVE
HUNDRED. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
ABLE TO TEACH THE SKILLS
NECESSARY TO STRENGTHEN OUR
CENTRAL WORKFORCE THEY SHOULD
BE COUPLED WITH POLICE TO
TRANSITION FROM HIGH THE
PHYSICAL EXPOSURE JOBS TO WORK
AT HOME. URGE THE GOVERNOR TO
RETAIN. THE PLASTIC TO WORK FOR
TO PROGRAMS THAT CAN BOLSTER
OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IF WE
CANNOT PROMISE OUR CONSTITUENTS
A JOB RIGHT NOW THE VERY LEAST
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO TRAINING. SO THAT
WHEN THE TIME COMES A LIVING
WAGE IT'S NO LONGER A DREAM.
BUT A REALITY. AS CHAIR REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE I'M
FULLY AWARE OF THE FISCAL
CHALLENGES WE FACE OUR GENERAL
FUND. REVENUES RELIES HEAVILY
ON PERSONAL INCOME TAX. WITHOUT
SAFEGUARDING INSISTING JOBS AND
CREATING MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WORKERS TO EARN A LIVING WAGE
WE MAKE THE CHOICE TO LIMóN
OUR ECONOMIC POTENTIAL. I AM
RECOVERY. ONE THING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT CALLED
FOR AN INCREASE IN TAX RATE WE
ARE STILL BEING ASKED TO LIMIT
TO THE DEGREE. COMPANIES CAN
USE PREVIOUSLY ON TAX CREDIT.
THESE ARE COMPANIES ENGAGING IN
SOCIAL WEEK USEFUL BEHAVIOR.
LIKE UNION WORK ON
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS BUILDING
HOMES FOR THE POOR AND
RESEARCHING NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
IF WE ARE NOT IN A POSITION TO
HONOR THOSE INVESTMENTS IN THE
SHORT TERM. WE SHOULD AT THE
VERY LEAST BE THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN LIFT OTHER BURDENS
ON THE VERY BUSINESSES WE WILL
NEED. TO CARRY OUT INTO A MORE
HOPEFUL FUTURE. ADDITIONALLY WE
CANNOT TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT INCLUDING
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
STUDENTS IN MY DISTRICT LACK
THE DEVICES AND CONNECTIVE ITTY
TO ENGAGE A REMOTE LEARNING
SEVERELY JEOPARDIZING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. AND
HIGHLIGHTING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
THAT EXISTS IN LOW INCOME URBAN
AREAS. I WOULD BE REMISS ALSO
IF I DIDN'T INCLUDE THE GREAT
OBSTACLES FACING THE CHILDREN
OF CALIFORNIA. HOUSING IN
SECURITY. WE CANNOT FULLY
RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC
PHYSICALLY OR ECONOMICALLY INTO
EVERY FAMILY AND CHILD HAS
THIRTY SECONDS. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE ARE AWARE OF HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES ARE
ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM BEING
HOMELESS. WORKING TOWARDS A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
INCLUDING PREVENTION EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND PERMIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS IMPERATIVE. I WANT
TO CLOSE BY SAYING THANK YOU TO
THE SPEAKER FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TODAY. I LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES BELIEVE WILL BEING
ELECTED TO OFFICE IS A GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY. I VALUE THE
WORKING INSIDE OF THE LA IN
THEIR CORRECT. THE LEGISLATURE
MUST GUARD ITS AUTHORITY. I
BELIEVE IN THIS BODY. THE VERY
PEOPLE LIKE TO IT. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT FAITH BASED PLACE
THEIR FAITH IN US AND I BELIEVE
OUR BUDGET AND IT'S PROCESS
SHOULD. PROTECT THOSE VALUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
ROSS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- MISTER SPEAKER FOR
HOLDING THIS- HISTORIC EVENT
HERE TODAY AND ALLOWING US TO
SPEAK ON ISSUES ARE IMPORTANT
TO US CERTAINLY MENTAL ILLNESS
IS AN AREA THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT WHEN WE START TO TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMY MOVING
FORWARD MENTAL HEALTH HAS TO BE
PART OF THAT EQUATION TO MOVE
FORWARD A VIBRANT AND HEALTHY
ECONOMY AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
THAT WERE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
ARE HOMELESS OUTH THAT ARE OUT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL AS SUICIDE SUICIDE IN OUR
YOUTH POPULATION CONTINUES TO
RISE IN BECOMES COULD BECOME
THAT EPIDEMIC THAT WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT SO FUNDING STREAMS
SHOULD BE INTACT FOR THOSE
AREAS MOVING FORWARD WE ALSO
KNOW THAT OUR SENIOR POPULATION
WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC BUT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE START TO LOOK
AT THE CUTS ARE SENIORS ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE LOOKING AT SOME
OF THE MOST SEVERE CUTS WITHIN
THIS BUDGET. WE START TO LOOK
AT THOSE AREAS AND MAKE SURE
THEY WERE ADVOCATING ON BEHALF
OF ALL THAT ARE OUT THERE AS
WELL AS OUR VETERANS WE TO
CELEBRATE MEMORIAL DAY AND JUST
CHAIR AND TO TALK ABOUT THE
VETERANS HOME IN BARSTOW
TALKING ABOUT CLOSING THE
VETERANS HOME IN BARSTOW IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T
TOLERATE DECEMBER DINO COUNTY
WE NEED TO SPEAK UP FOR OUR
VETERANS ESPECIALLY ONE OF THE
FEW STATE VETERAN HOMES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT FIRES OR SOMETHING
THAT WE FACE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE GOING TO BE
COMING. THEY'RE GONNA BE
CUMMINGS FIRE SEASON AROUND THE
CORNER. AND WE START TO TALK
ABOUT A 10% CUT. LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING ON
THE BACK OF PUBLIC SAFETY OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF FIREFIGHTERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE. THAT DURING
THOSE TIMES OF CRISIS WE CALL
UPON. THIS MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PART OF THE- DISCUSSION
MOVING FORWARD.AND I ALSO URGE
THIS BODY. ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE BODIES. IN OUR NATION.
THEN WE MAKE PROMISES
ESPECIALLY TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. ON TRIBAL
DIVERSION PROGRAMS ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE INDIAN
HERITAGE CENTER. THAT CURRENTLY
SITS ON CENTER FOR PROPERTY. A
DIS UP DISPLAYS TO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE BY PUTTING A
CENTER. IN A SUTTER FOR. WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
FUNDING PRIOR FINDING. AN AREA.
FOR INDIAN HERITAGE CENTER TO
MOVE FORWARD AND TO SEE THAT AS
SOMETHING THAT'S GONNA BE CUT
IN THE BUDGET. IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN'T TOLERATE. LET'S
MAKE SURE. THAT WHEN FUNDING
PROMISES ARE MADE THAT WE KEEP
THOSE PROMISES THAT ARE THERE.
WE ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
HAVE MET WITH THE GOVERNOR. OF
WITH THE LATINO CAUCUS THERE WE
TALK ABOUT THE FARMWORKERS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE OUT THERE
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR
US. THAT WE MAKE SURE WE HONOR
THEM WITH THEIR I. TEN AREAS
THAT ARE THERE SO THEY COULD
ACTUALLY COME THROUGH AND BE
ABLE TO FILE FOR THOSE THINGS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE SSUES
THAT MAKES OUR ECONOMY MOVE
FORWARD. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THEN WE SEEN IN THE
PRESENTATIONS AND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THERE I'M BUDGET
SOLUTIONS IS SUPPORTING JOB
CREATION. THAT WE START TO LOOK
AT BUSINESSES SO WE DRIVING IN
THAT REVENUE INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS
THAT MIGHT BE. TALKED ABOUT
LATER IN THE FUTURE BUT IF WE
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THOSE SOLUTIONS ON THE REVENUE
STREAMS THAT ARE COMING IN
ESPECIALLY TO SMALL BUSINESS. I
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE IT.
ALL BUSINESSES SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE DEDICATING TO. AND
THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE HERE AT
THE STATE- BUT ALSO IN THE
LOCAL. AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AB I'VE I'VE-
FOUNDATIONS AS WELL- AND SO
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO FILL
IN THE GAPS WHERE THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM- DID LEFT A
LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES OUT
ESPECIALLY IN ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED. COMMUNITIES I'M SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS
THE OTHER THING IS THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX- THAT IS THE
FIRST THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAXES EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX. SOMETHING
THAT THIS BODY HAS BEEN LOOKING
OUT FOR SEVERAL YEARS- WE
PROPOSE THE TO MAINTAIN THAT
PROPOSAL FROM JANUARY WHICH IS
TO WAIVE. THAT TAX IN THE FIRST
YEAR BUSINESS SO FOR A NEW
START BUSINESSES THEY WOULD
HAVE. LESS OF A BARRIER I'M TO
CROSS IN IN CREATING THEIR
BUSINESS SO THOSE ARE TWO
IMPORTANT THINGS BUT I DO WANT
TO LEAVE- THIS BODY WITH THE
AND THAT THAT IS NOT ENOUGH
THERE'S MORE THAT WE NEED TO
DO. TO CREATE JOBS I THINK I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THE TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT WE NEED TO SUBSIDIZE
EMPLOYMENT THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS. THAT CAN BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK IN A SPECIALLY
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR SKILLS
ARE MATCHED UP. WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT- THAT WE HAVE HERE
IN THE STATE AND IN THE FUTURE-
SO THOSE ARE THINGS WE WANT TO
KEEP WORKING WITH YOU ALL. ON
I'M OVER THE COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU THERE ANY OTHER-SOLUTION I KNOW THERE WAS
ANOTHER IF YOU IF YOU COULD
JUST. MAKE ONE MOST OF THEM ARE
GOING TO GET NEXT HI THIS FROM.
THANK YOU. AND I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THE HAPPINESS-
STAND HERE SPEAK ESPECIALLY ON
THE FUNDING THAT WAS PROMISED.
TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. LET'S
MAKE SURE WE HOLD THOSE
PROMISES TRUE BECAUSE THERE'S
NEVER BEEN. ANOTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN- TOLD ONE
THING AND TAKING THINGS AWAY
FROM THEM. RIGHT THANK YOU CAN
I THINK I JUST WANT TO SPEAK ON
THAT ONE HE'S BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THAT WAS
GENERAL FUND AND THAT. THAT'S
NOW BEEN SHIFTED TO LEASE
REVENUE BONDS- SO THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A CUT IT'S JUST A
DIFFERENT FINANCING. OF THE OF
THE FACILITY SO ONCE THERE'S A
PROJECT AT THAT WE- CAN PUT
TOGETHER THEN THERE WOULD BE
BONDS ISSUED TO PAY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE WILL WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO GET THE RIGHT MESSAGE
OUT FOR THE RIGHT PEOPLE. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER DAVID CHIU-
THEN MR DAILY IF YOU STILL HERE
IF NOT THE MR GABRIEL. AND THEN
MR BONTA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LET ME FIRST START BY- BY
THANKING THE GOVERNOR AND
ADMINISTRATION- WITH REGARD TO
THIS BUDGET- WE ALL KNOW HOW
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING THIS IS
AS THE CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE MY COMMENTS WILL BE
MOSTLY FOCUSED ON HOUSING.
DURING OUR STATE'S HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THE WORDS
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY AND THAT
WAS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
WAS ABLE TO AVOID MAJOR CUTS IN
THIS AREA- FROM HIS ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED BUDGET. BUT ON HOUSE
CALIFORNIANS NEED MORE
RESOURCES. CORONAVIRUS ON TOP
OF THESE CRISES IS GASOLINE ON
FIRE BECAUSE HOUSING AS HEALTH
CARE AND THE LACK OF HOUSING
WILL INCREASE COVER NINETEEN
SPREAD. WE NEED MORE FUNDING TO
PERSONALLY HOUSE CALIFORNIANS
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS TO
STABILIZE RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS. WHO ARE A WRENCH OR
A MORTGAGE CHECK AWAY FROM
ADDICTIONS OR FORECLOSURES. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SUGGEST I HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER ONGOING
REVENUE MEASURES TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. IN BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR I ASKED A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND
SOME SPECIFICALLY PROPOSED
POLICIES AND WOULD STILL
APPRECIATE ANSWERS TO THEM.
FIRST PROJECT ROOM KEY TO
PURCHASE HOTELS AND MOTELS FOR
HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS IS A GOOD
CONCEPT. BUT THERE ARE MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
IT WILL BE EFFECTIVE. BOTH
BECAUSE IT'S SO EXPENSIVE PER
UNIT AND ALSO BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T FUND THE SERVICES
NEEDED FOR EFFECTIVE PERMITS
SUPPORT OF HOUSING. MY QUESTION
IS WHETHER WE CAN MAKE THE
PROGRAM MORE FLEXIBLE TO ALSO
CONSIDER RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
MASTER LEASES FROM PRIVATE
LANDLORDS. PAYING FOR RENT AS A
LUMP SUM BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR WITH OPERATING ASSISTANCE
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING. COULD
BE CONSIDER SPENDING ON REAL
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH WOULD BE A TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT PER
UNIT VERSES THE ESTIMATED TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR COST.
TO PURCHASE AND REHAB A HOTEL
OR MOTEL UNIT. SECOND I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FROM AND
MAINTAINING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TAX CREDIT LIKE TECH. A
MUCH NEEDED TO OUR CHAMPION FOR
YEARS. THAT BEING SAID THE
PROPOSED CAP ON INVESTORS USING
TAX CREDITS WOULD UNDERMINE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INVESTMENTS.
THE PROPOSAL ITSELF IS ALREADY
DECREASING INVESTOR INTEREST IN
THESE CREDITS PUTTING PROJECT
FINANCING IN JEOPARDY. I'D LIKE
TO ASK FOR CONSIDERATION OF
CHANGING THAT CAP OR EXEMPTING
LIE TECH. BE ON HOUSING I WANT
TO JOIN OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES IN PUSHING FOR WHAT
WE NEED TO DO. AND HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION CHILD CARE FAMILY
LEAVE AND SOCIAL SERVICES TO
STABILIZE OUR SAFETY NET. I
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION OF THE PROPOSAL
EMANATION OF ADULT DAY HEALTH
CENTERS. AND MULTI PURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICE PROGRAMS. TO NOT
UNDERMINE PAST DECISIONS ON
PROP FIFTY SIX FOR A HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CENTERS. TO STABILIZE
THE PLIGHT OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND WORKERS WHO
BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS CAN'T
ACCESS FEDERAL SUPPORT OR MUCH
SUPPORT AT ALL. TO ASSIST SMALL
BUSINESSES THE REFLECT THE
ECONOMIC VITALITY AND DIVERSITY
OF OUR STATE. AND ALSO TO
ADDRESS THE RISE IN HATE
INCIDENTS AGAINST ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AND OTHERS- HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET SOME ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS- NOT NECESSARILY
TODAY I WOULD IMAGINE BUT- IN
THE NEAR FUTURE WITH THAT TO
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH EVERYONE.
TO WHAT MOVING FORWARD THESE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. I'M IN A
DRESS A COUPLE OF THEM ONE OF
THEM THAT HAVE BEEN- AFTER A
COUPLE TIMES AND THAT'S ABOUT
THE MSF P. PROGRAM. AND THE SEA
BASS PROGRAM- BOTH PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ARE VERY GOOD PROGRAMS
THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY-
IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE STATE
EVENLY. AND WE ARE LOOKING
BECAUSE OF HOW VULNERABLE AND
FREE OF THIS POPULATION IS AND
HOW- IMPACTED BY THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THEY ARE. AND
WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS NEW
BENEFIT THAT WOULD BE A PART OF
THE MAIN MEDI CAL PROGRAM SO
WOULD BE STATEWIDE IN WOULD BE
CONSISTENT STATEWIDE- THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDE. THE NURSING
NURSING HOME AT AND NURSING
CERTAIN NURSING HOME SERVICES
AT HOME. AND THE IDEA WOULD BE
TO WRAP AROUND THESE FRAIL
SENIORS WITH THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT-
AT HOME- TO BE HONEST LIKE THE
COVERT BAND HAMMOCK HAS REALLY
IMPACTED SIGNIFICANTLY THE
OPERATION OF MANY OF THESE
CENTERS BECAUSE- SENIORS CAN'T
SAFELY CONGREGATE- IN. AND
COMMON SPACES SO THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK I'M AT
DAY IN AND DAY NIGHT TO GET
THOSE- WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO
THOSE SENIORS- ADDITIONAL MEALS
TO THE SENIORS. AND THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ARE COMING IN JULY ONE- I
BELIEVE THAT THE SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM- IT THAT'S
BEEN REFERENCED A FEW TIMES WAS
A ONE TIME REQUESTED THAT FROM
LAST YEAR THAT HADN'T GONE OUT
YET AND I THINK THAT'S- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- KEEPS BEING
RIGHT UP IT'S NOT A BASE CUTS
YOU SEEN YOUR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THAT. ABSOLUTELY WOULD
NOT BE IN LINE WITH WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IN THIS BUDGET.
AND THERE IS ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FINES THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
GOING ON IN THE COPA NINETEEN
RESPONSE TO GET ADDITIONAL
MEALS TO SENIORS. AND ALSO HELP
TO SUPPORT THAT THE RICH THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY THAT'S BEEN
VERY- HARD HIT BY THE PANDEMIC.
I'M SO SENIORS ARE A HIGH
PRIORITY- I DEFINITELY
RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THOSE TWO OPTIONAL
BENEFITS. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE CHOICES THERE ARE REALLY
HARD CHOICES WHEN YOU LOOK AT
REDUCING THE GENERAL FUND AT
THE LEVEL. THAT WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET ABSENCE
BETTER ABSENT FEDERAL FUNDS-
THERE ARE REALLY JUST THREE
SCHOOLS IN THE HEALTHCARE AREA
THERE'S ELIGIBILITY THEIR
OPTIONAL BENEFITS AND THEIR
RATES. AND THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX ARE SUPPLEMENTAL
RATES THAT WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING
JUST FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. PRIOR AT TO ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO THOSE THOSE MONIES
WERE BEING FUND FOR FINDING CAL
BASED. AND THEN WE WERE ABLE TO
THROUGH THE BETTER ECONOMIC
TIMES. TO SWITCH THOSE MONEY
INTO SUPPLEMENTAL RAY. AND I'M
NOT TO SIT HERE AND- THAT THE
CARE AND THREE AND A BE FINE
THROUGH THIS THERE IS ALL. OF
AND- I THE ENTIRE CARE AND THE
IMPACTS THAT THE KOBE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD ON IT AND MAY CONTINUE
TO HAVE ON IT. IN TERMS OF THE
A SURGE AND NEEDING TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL HOSPITAL BEDS
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ENERGY-
BUILDING UP ADDITIONAL SURGE
CAPACITY SO THAT WE COULD AVOID
SOME OF THE AWFUL THINGS THAT
WE'VE SEEN AROUND THE WORLD-
WITH PAY. PATIENTS NOT HAVING
ADEQUATE SPACES. IN IN
HOSPITALS AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WATCH WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS WE DON'T HAVE ALL AND A
FULL GRASP OF ALL THE IMPACTS
YET. BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT-
AS WE WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HEALTHCARE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS. IT'S A SHARED
FUNDING PART PARTNERSHIP ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A HUGE
PART OF FUNDING OU HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY. AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
ON HOW TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND FUNDING OUR
OUR- OUR SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT I YOU KNOW I
JUST WANTED TO SAY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I
THINK EVERYONE RECOGNIZED. THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF. CONCERN AND
IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO BE THIS
YEAR BUT THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS ESPECIALLY HOW THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PANDEMIC
ARE GOING TO BE- WRAPPED INTO
MANAGED CARE RATES. THERE ISN'T
ANY MINUTE THINGS WE DON'T KNOW
AS WE SIT HERE TODAY- AND I
WILL BE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS FOR MANY YEARS. APPRECIATE
THAT I. MICHAEL TURNS WERE
HOUSING SO. I'D OF IF I COULD
GET SO ADDRESSES ARE A I YEAH
YOUR HOUSE QUESTIONS AS WELL
YEAH SO. CAN USED TO BE A VERY
HIGH PRICE. OF THE GOVERNOR AND
FOR. WE HAD TO PULL BACK ON
SOME OF THE- FUN. IT WAS RIPPED.
ORDINARY OUR- GENERAL FUND.
SCENE AND THAT WE'RE IN THE
LAST. BUDGET BUT WE DIDN'T WANT
TO MAINTAIN THE ALREADY FOR
THAT I'M TO THE- CREDIT BROWN
THERE REALLY. PIECING TOGETHER.
AT HOUSING ACROSS STATE THERE
BARTON THAN EVER AND THE HOW
ACTION IT USED I ARE TO BE A TO
BE A PRICE FOR THE GOVERNOR WE
WILL FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS BY AND THIS TO MEET I'M
REFORMS BUT FORWARD I HAVE TO
DO IN TERMS OF HOME. I THINK
THE IDEA OF A THE HOME PROPOSAL
AND SWITCH WITH REALLY TO USE
THESE ONE BETTER UNDS TO TRY
AND SOME OUT THAT CAN
SUSTAINING A COULD HOLD
COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE I'M
HAVE MORE THIS FOR I OF IT AB
GOING FOR AND SO THE THAT WAS
REALLY THE IDEA OF ON YOU THESE
WERE TIME FOR FUN TO TRYING
MAKE THAT CONTINUE HAPPENED I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS
CONTINUES TO BE MORE NEED FOR
THOSE WRAPAROUND IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES. IT'S JUST GIVEN THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE FISCAL
SITUATION IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
THE STATE TO COMMIT TO
ADDITIONAL BE ON THE CORE
PROGRAMS THAT THAT WE ALREADY
FIND WHICH IS MEDI CAL CAL
WORKS AS A SCIENTIST P. I HSS
THOSE PROGRAMS REALLY NEEDED TO
NEED TO BE MAINTAINED AS THE AS
THE FOUNDATION OF SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED. THANK YOU. THE MR
GABRIEL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
KEEPING US ALONG WITH OUR
SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOR YOUR HELPFUL- AND
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND ALSO TO
THE MINISTRATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THINK THIS HEARING TODAY'S
GIVE US SOME INSIGHT INTO THE
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO A CHOICES AND
DILEMMAS THAT YOU'RE FACING AND-
YOUR THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE TO A
LOT OF THIS- A LOT OF WHAT I
WANTED TO SAY THIRTY BEEN
SHARED BY MY COLLEAGUES I JUST
WANNA. ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THAT. COMMENTS THAT HAVE MADE
ABOUT FUNDING FOR A- FOR
EDUCATION PARTICULARLY HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD FOR AN S. S. P. FOR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY- ALSO
WANTED TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE PARTICULARLY THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS OF OUR FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA ROSA WHO I
THINK REALLY. HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
RESPECTS- WHAT I DID WANT TO DO
IS JUST BRIEFLY SHARE TWO
CONCERNS- BUT I THINK HAVING
BEEN SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSED
TODAY ONE. ONE ONE LARGER AND
ONE ONE OF THE BIT MORE MODEST.
AT THE FIRST ONE IS AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING WHICH
IS A TOP PARTY FOR THE LA
COUNTY DELEGATION SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND ON BEHALF
OF THE DELEGATION AS WELL. I'M
JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT
THEIR NIGHT MIGHT NOT BE-
SUFFICIENT EMPHASIS AROUND THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED IN OUR
COUNTY IS THAT. AS MUCH WORK AS
WE'VE DONE IN IN THE- LAST YEAR
WE PUT TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO HOUSING YET
HOMELESSNESS STILL ONE UP. 12%
IN THE COUNTY. A DIFFERENT WAY
TO THINK ABOUT THAT IS THAT-
EVERY DAY ON AVERAGE FOR
PUTTING A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
PEOPLE INTO. HOUSING AND
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE ARE
SLIPPING INTO. CYNICISM BUT
THAT RATE WERE JUST DOING OUR
CELL INTO A- DEEPER AND- INTO.
HOLE OUT WE- KNOW. IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WERE. TO LOOK. AT
CLOSE TO THIRTY FIVE. THOUSAND
OF SUB. AFFORD HOUSING IS.
SUBSIDIES IN THE RESTRICTIONS
EXPIRE NOT AS- WHAT HAPPENED
ACTUALLY CALLOUSED.
CONSEQUENCES FOR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS SO. VERY INTERESTED TO
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MENTION SOME OF THIS IN THE MAY
REVISED BY. REALLY OFFICE.
AROUND HELLO IT'S HOUSE KEY.
THEM IN THEIR HOMES. IT'S A
IT'S A REALLYPRUDENT
INVESTMENT FOR TWENTY THOUSAND.
YOU CAN PRISON. OF THE HOUSE.
PLUS MORE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND- THE UNIT IN IN PARTS OF
AUSTIN. I'M ALSO ALL OF THE
VûI. COST THE GOAL. WITH THIS
ONCE PEOPLE FALLING
HOMELESSNESS THE- HEALTH CARE
NOW. HEALTH AND- JUSTICE. THAT
IS. TO PAY PEOPLE OUT
HOMELESSNESS. IS EXTRAORDINARY
VERY IN. TO HEAR. FROM THE
MISTER. ABOUT THE- ABOUT THE
PRESS. AND EVER ARE AND
PREVENTION OF HOME. IN THIS.
THERE THE OTHER IS A IS A MORE
MODERN CONCERNED ONE THAT I IS
ISRAEL. POOR TOOL OF PHONEBOOK.
THAT ARE RISK OF HATE MOTIVATE
VIOLENCE. LAST YEAR THE VILLAGE
CREATED THE CAL. NONPROFITS
GRANT PROGRAM FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED TO.
ASSIST NON PROFITS AT RISK OF
HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE. ON THE
PROGRAM IS DRAMATICALLY OVER
SUBSCRIBE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FROM
AROUND THE STATE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHICH DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY FUNDING- HISTORY
UNFORTUNATELY TEACHES US THAT
IN MOMENTS OF. SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY HATE TENDS
TO RISE AND- AND- VIOLENCE
TENDS TO INCREASE HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE AND SO- YOU
KNOW THIS FUNDING THAT GOES TO
MOSQUE. AND SYNAGOGUES AND
CHURCHES IN LGBT COMMUNITY
CENTERS- IT'S REALLY BUDGET
DUST- IN THE PHYSICAL SENSE BUT
IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
TO. TO THOSE COMMUNITIES IN
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND SO. I
THINK IT'S A REALLY POWERFUL
MESSAGE WHEN WE- CREATED THE
PROGRAM ALLOCATED THAT FUNDING
AND I WOULD HATE TO SEND THE
OPPOSITE MESSAGE AT AT AT. A
MOMENT APPAREL IT WOULD BE.
VERY INTERESTED WITH WITH THE
LEAD TIME TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE
ON THOSE ISSUES. YES IN TERMS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR I'D-
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION I THINK
THAT THAT'S REALLY AT THE ROOT
OF THE ORGANIZING PRINCIPLES
THAT THIS NAY REVISION WAS
BUILT. AND PROTECTING THOSE CAL
WORKS GRANTS PROTECTING US
ASIDE AT THIS P. GRANTS. YOU
KNOW BASED. INCOME THAT'S
PROVIDED TO FAMILIES THAT ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE SO THAT
THEY CAN PAY. FOR RENT AND
FOOD- AND THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED- SO THOSE THAT. THAT'S ONE
ASPECT AND WE ARE SEEING A LOT
OF. FEDERAL MONEY COMING INTO
THE STATE MUCH OF IT IS NOT
COMING TO THE STATE BUT GOING
DIRECTLY TO LOCAL- GOVERNMENTS
IN THE FORM OF THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT LOCK GRANT. I WE
WANT TO WORK WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MAXIMIZE THAT
MONEY THE SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
CORONAVIRUS REALLY FUN THAT.
THE STATE IS PROPOSING TO
ALLOCATE- TOWARDS THE PURCHASE.
OF A LOW INCOME UNITS. I MEAN I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW HOW WE-
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS. A LOT OF
OTHER STRATEGIES THAT WE WANT
TO WORK WITH YOU ALL ON
INCLUDING. I'M DIFFERENT BILLS-
TO ADD REALLY LEVERAGE THOSE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND EXISTING
STATE PROGRAMS- TO REALLY
CREATE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO NOT LOSE GROUND
ESPECIALLY BUT ALSO THEY
CONTINUE TO BUILD- ADDITIONAL.
CAPACITY WE DEFINITELY NOTHING
HAS CHANGED ON THE HOUSING
CRISIS- WITH THE COBRA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I'M IN SOME CASES
IT'S PROBABLY INTENSIFIED-
BECAUSE OF THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT OF THIS CRISIS ON ON LOW
WAGE WORKERS. I AM AND WHO WHO
TEND BE THE MORE HOUSE AND
SECURE WORKERS. I CONTINUES TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT- AND- WE'LL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MORE ON THAT IF I MAY
MISTER JUST WANT TO ECHO MIGHT
MY COMMENT. THE COMMENTS MY
CARD FOR SINCE IT'S GONNA THANK
YOU FOR. THE EMILY LOCUM HOUSE
TAX CUT SIX SIX THE TAX CREDITS
MIGHT BE A REALLY IF. WAY TELL
PRESERVE SOME OF THAT. HOUSING
STOCK AS YOU KNOW HAVE THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS AT RISK OF
DISAPPEAR. THERE'S A WAY THAT
WE CAN HAVE MISSION DRIVEN
NONPROFITS ACQUIRE ALL OF THAT.
A TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR UNITS
TO KEEP. YOU KNOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSE OR
JUST. HUMBLY OFFER THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE ON THE
ISSUES. THE MEXICAN ECONOMIST
BONTA. CUNNINGHAM IN THIS KALRA
AND THE MISS COME. THANK
COLLEAGUES AND MISTER CHAIR I
IN YOUR CAN INSTEAD AS A AS
MISTER TECH AND THAT LEóN YOUR
AND MISS FOSTER IN THE FROM TO
FINANCE YOUR C. BRING ALL
TOGETHER IN THE SYSTEM UP TO.
OF THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION A
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE AN
OBVIOUS WERE ON. IN ON PRESS.
TIMES IN A PANDEMIC. ECONOMIC
RECESSION FACING A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT
AND- RIGHT NOW. THAT REALLY
CREATES THE PROSPECT OF
HEARTBREAKING. AND GUT
WRENCHING CUTS AND SO I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE TWO THEMES
NOT SPECIFICS THE THEY CAN BE
APPLIED TO A NUMBER SPECIFICS
BUT TWO THEMES ONE THAT WE- DO
A LOT OF US. HAVE ALREADY ASKED
THAT WE DO WHICH IS KEEP OUR
MOST VULNERABLE IN MIND. AND
TOP OF MIND AS WE MAKE OUR
DECISIONS AND TO. THAT WE
PRIORITIZE. REVENUE OPTIONS
MORE THAN WE HAVE SO FAR IN
THIS DISCUSSION WE KNOW RIGHT
NOW. THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
BARELY HANGING ON OTHERS. CAN
NO LONGER HANG ON WE KNOW. THAT
FOLKS ARE TEETERING ON THE EDGE
AND SOME HAVE FALLEN OVER THE
EDGE ALREADY WE KNOW THAT AN
ECONOMIC. RECESSION HURTS FIRST
AND HURTS WORSE THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE. IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO FOLKS NEED US TO HELP THEM
MORE NOT LESS. THEY NEED TO
INVEST I'M NOT. THAT FROM THEM
SO I REALLY ASK THAT WE CAN ARM
VULNERABLE TALK SOME. ABOUT
HERO. ARE ARE FOR. ASCENSION
WORKERS. ARE SUPPLY CHAIN
WORKERS FIRST WITH. ARE ARE
HEALTH CARE. ARE TEACHERS IN
CLASS OF WORKER. THEIR LITTER.
FEEDING TEACHING MARK. KEY US
SAFE KEEPING US HEALTHY. IN
MANY CASES KEEPING US. MANY OF
THEM. STAND TO LOSE SO MUCH
FROM THE CUTS IN PROPOSED CUTS
IN THIS BUDGET AND I KNOW THOSE
CUTS. AREN'T DESIRED WE TAKE NO
PLEASURE IN THEM- THERE ON.
CONSEQUENCES BUT I REALLY ASKED
THAT WE KEEP THAT EQUITY LANDS.
AS WE VIEW OUR BUDGET AND MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT- WHO GOING TO
BENEFIT IN GOING TO GET HURT
BECAUSE THAT THOSE THE THAT.
HURT MOST THE AT LEAST PREPARED
TO BEAR THAT BURDEN. SO LET'S
KEEP THAT IN IN MIND I KNOW SO
MANY OF YOUR AND APPRECIATE
THAT CONCEPT IN THAT IDEA AND
THAT VALUE BEING UP LIFTED. SO
MANY TIMES AND THEN I WANNA
JUST APPRECIATE A LOT OF THE
THINKING THAT'S GONE AND FROM.
BOTH HOUSES FROM THE PARTNER
FINANCE ELLIE- FROM THAT FROM
THE GOVERNOR. I AND HOW TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET SOME OF THEM
I THINK. ARE ARE INCREDIBLY
THOUGHTFUL BUT THEY ALSO HAVE-
THE ALSO CREATE ANXIETY AND
WORRY FOR ME. FOR EXAMPLE THAT
FEDERAL. STIMULUS PROPOSAL I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE HEROES
ACT IN A WAY I KNOW SO MANY OF
US DO IF THAT MONEY CAME INTO
BE HUGE FOR US. BUT IT MAY OR
MAY NOT. AND IF IT DOESN'T
WE'RE GONNA FACE. IT TRIGGERS
CUTS THAT ARE JUST INCREDIBLY
PAINFUL AND DAMAGING AND
HURTFUL TO SO MANY PEOPLE. THAT
WE CARE ABOUT THE BARN
PROPOSALS THAT WE'VE HEARD.
ABOUT I DEFINITELY CAN HELP US
NOW. BUT THEY NEED TO BE PAID
BACK LATER AND- AT THE
POTENTIAL COST IN PAIN AND
HARM. TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES LATER
CUTS NOW FOR SURE. HURT THOSE
WHO ARE LEAST ABLE TO BEAR THAT
BURDEN- SO I DO WANT TO ASK US
TO. MAKE MORE CENTRAL AND AS A
HIGHER PRIORITY MORE PROMINENT
ARE DISCUSSED POSSIBILITY A
REVENUE OPTIONS. I'M MISTER HEY.
PROPOSED ONE EARLIER TODAY IT'S
WORTH YOUR CONSIDERATION. THE
KIND OF THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
RIGHT NOW. A TWO MINUTE THE
CUTS IN THE IN THE PEOPLE THAT
WE OUGHT ABOUT. SO EL I WANT TO
END WITH A. WHICH IS WE ARE TO
HAVE. FOR RESPONSIBLE AND TO
HAVE GOSH IT ABOUT AVENUE OP.
WHY AND MISS BY MISTER TECH YOU
SUGGEST BE THE PER THAT GUIDE
THAT DISCUSS WHICH YOU BE THINK
ABOUT ROOM EVERYDAY TAX BREAKS
YOU WE WOULD TARGETING CERTAIN
TAX. OR OR REVENUE. HOW DO YOU
ARE THE LEAD. THINK ABOUT WHAT
I THINK WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
WHICH IS INCREASING REVENUES TO
HELP BALLOT A BUDGET IN A VERY
TO I CAN SO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I THINK. THERE
COULD BE A COUPLE OF IDEAS OUT
THERE AS FAR AS TAKING ANOTHER
LOOK AT SOME OF THE STATE'S TAX
EXPENDITURES. AND IN SOME CASES
WE THINK THAT SOME OF THE TAX
EXPENDITURES THAT EXIST- HAVE A
QUESTIONABLE POLICY
JUSTIFICATION. ARE THAT YOU
COULD CONSIDER- THIS STEP UP
BASIS ON INHERITED ASSETS
WHERE- PERSON INHERITS AN ASSET
IN IT'S NOT- RE PRICES TO
MARKET VALUE- YOU COULD
CONSIDER- MOVING THE- STATE'S
TAX CODE MORE. IN LINE. WITH
WHAT THEY CALL- CONFORMITY TO
THE FEDERAL TAX CODE. AND PUT A
LIMIT ON THE PROPERTY TAX
DEDUCTIONS THAT- PEOPLE BENEFIT
FROM CURRENTLY WITH THEIR LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX PAYMENTS. SO THERE
ARE PROBABLY A RANGE OF OPTIONS
AND I THINK OUR OFFICEWOULD BE
HELD HAPPY TO. ASSIST WITH
PROVIDING SOME OF THAT ANALYSIS
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE A POST ON
OUR WEBSITE THAT TALKS THROUGH
SOME OF THESE IDEAS SO. THERE
ARE SOME IDEAS OUT THERE. THANK
YOU MISTER BETTER. THANK THANK
YOU OKAY AS THE VILLAINESS
CUNNINGHAM AND THEN- MISTER
KALRA MISS COM LAW ORDER IN
MYSTERY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF TWO
GROUPS OF PEOPLE THAT OFTEN DO
NOT HAVE A VOICE IN OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT. THOSE PEOPLE ARE
THE VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THEY ARE KIDS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. WELL THE
SHELTER HOME ORDER WAS
NECESSARY FOR A TIME. IT AT
SERIOUS AND DIRECT CONSEQUENCES
WITH RESPECT TO AN INCREASE IN
CALLS FOR SERVICE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THAT'S WHY ON APRIL
FOURTEENTH A COALITION OF
LEGISLATORS TEN OF US ONE EIGHT
THAT THIS BODY. SAID THE
GOVERNOR REQUEST THAT HE USED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
SB EIGHTY NINE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FUND 1% OF THAT FUN.
TO AUGMENT THE CAPACITY AT OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS. WE
NEVER GOT A RESPONSE THAT
REQUEST FROM THE GOVERNOR. NOT
EVEN A RESPONSE. AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR I CAN TELL YOU FIRST
HAND I'VE SEEN THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT MESSICK VIOLENCE HAS ON
VICTIMS AND THEIR CHILDREN. THE
IMPACT IS GENERATIONAL IT DOES
GENERATIONAL DAMAGE TO FAMILIES
AND TWO KIDS. AND SHELTER HOME
MEANT FOR SOME PEOPLE BEING
SHELTERED OR TRAPPED IN A
DANGEROUS SITUATION AND THE
ONLY PLACE THEY CAN GO IS OUR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS IN
MY HOME COUNTY CALL IS
INCREASING THE FIRST FOUR WEEKS
OF QUARANTINE. CALLS INCREASED
OVER A 100% DOUBLE. THOSE
SHELTERS ARE A LIFELINE FOR
THOSE PEOPLE AND THEIR CHILDREN
THEY'RE A LIFELINE WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
THAT INCLUDES THE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THEY HAVE
BEEN PUT IN DANGER IN A DIRECT
AND FORESEEABLE FASHION BY
GOVERNMENT STAY HOME ORDERS.
THAT IS AN EMERGENCY COBIT
SITUATION AND WE DIDN'T ANSWER
FROM OUR GOVERNOR ABOUT THAT.
NEXT WITH REGARD EDUCATION.
ACCORDING TO THE NAY REVISED
FIGURES PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES ARE
BEING SLASHED BY FOURTEEN POINT
THREE PERCENT. NON EDUCATION
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES ARE
ONLY BEING CUT BY FIVE PORT
FIVE POINT FOUR PERCENT. THE LA
PREPARED THIS CHART. HOW THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES SOLVING A
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET PROBLEM THE BIGGEST CUT
IS TO QUE THROUGH FOURTEEN
EDUCATION BIGGEST PARTS 28% OF
THE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS. THAT'S
WRONG EDUCATION IS A CORE STATE
GOVERNMENT FUNCTION IT'S THE
TOP PRIORITY OF OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT. THE TOP PRIORITY
THE VOTERS AGREE THAT'S WHY THE
PRATT PASSED PROP NINETY EIGHT
AND GUARANTEED A FLOOR FOR K.
TWELVE EDUCATIONS BUT SPENDING.
A FOR BUT IS NOW BECOME THE
CEILING BECAUSE THIS BUDGET. IF
EDUCATION IS TRULY OUR TOP
PRIORITY IT SHOULD BE THE FIRST
THING WE FIND AND THE LAST
THING WE CUT. PERIOD WE'VE SEEN
LEARNING LOSS FROM REMOTE
LEARNING ALREADY. WE ASKED OUR
TEACHERS ARE EDUCATORS ARE
ADMINISTRATORS TO DO DIFFICULT
AND CREATIVE AN UNPRECEDENTED
THINGS AND THEY RESPOND. TO
KEEP SOME SEMBLANCE OF
EDUCATION GOING DURING
WARRANTY. NOW WE'RE GONNA ASK
THEM TO DO EVEN MORE AS WE
START SCHOOL NEXT YEAR AND
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO WITH
MUCH MUCH LESS. AND THAT'S
WRONG. EDUCATION IS THE LADDER
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR MILLIONS.
EDUCATION IS THE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE TO A SKILLED TRADE. TO
PUBLIC SERVICE TO THE MILITARY
TO FUTURE CAREERS I'VE SEEN
THIS IS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
I'VE SEEN IT MY OWN PERSONAL
FAMILY HISTORY. CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WE FOUGHT
AS A BODY FOR FOUR YEARS TO GET
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PRIORITIZE AND FUNDED IN THIS
BODY AND THIS BUDGET SLASHES IT
IN HALF AND THAT'S WRONG. THAT
IS THE LIFELINE FOR PEOPLE THAT
IS THEIR PATHWAY TO A SKILLED
PROFESSION WHERE THEY CAN MAKE
A GREAT LIVING AND PROVIDE FOR
THIRTY SECONDS. OUR KIDS
DESERVE BETTER THAN A 14% CUT
IN EDUCATION I KNOW TIMES ARE
BAD BUT THEY DESERVE BETTER
THAN A FOURTEEN PERCENT CUT
BIGGER THAN ANYTHING ELSE. THEY
DESERVE BETTER THAN A RETREAT
FROM OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THEY DESERVE BETTER THAN THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU SURE TING
UNDER THE SPEAKER'S WELL DELEO
AND GOVERNMENT MINISTRY
GOVERNOR'S STAFF HERE. I WANT
TO START WITH THOSE WITH A LOT
BEHIND THE FEDERAL I WANTED
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS WORK
ON A- THE IMMIGRANT IS RELIEF
ASSISTANCE. I MORE NEEDS TO
DONE. I'D ON DOCTOR WORKER MAKE
UP ONE AND TEN WORKER ARE
DIVERSE STATE. ARE THE BACK ON
OF OUR SURE. IS ON TOP MOST
IMPORTANT IN JUST. I AM WITH A
OTHER CALLING PROPOSED. OF A
TEMPER PARTIAL INCOME UP
APPROACH FIRST THE WORKERS.
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO FOR THE
STATE OR FEDERAL BENEFITS A
MISTER BY YOU DO YOU WHO ARE
UNDER. ON AS A DIRECT RESULT
THE KOBE NINE. BANDANNA THIS AN
EXTRA REPEAL BIGGEST IMPORTANCE
OF AND WE WORKERS. CALIFORNIA
MUST AND THAT WE THESE WORKERS
AND- FOR THEIR FAMILIES DOING
QUITE WILL BE. DEPEND ON EACH
OTHER. I JOIN THE CONCERN WITH
UP OKAY THE MOTOR PURPOSE IN
SERVICE PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY.
ADULTS PROGRAM LIVING US
BINDING. WILL FORCE MORE A IN
AND HOME ARE HOMELESS. IN THE
OKAY BUT NINE THIS IS THE WORST.
TO FOR. IS WHAT THE PERCENT OF
CARBON I DOES HELP. WE'RE NORTH
HOME RESIDENTS. AND ASSIST BE
ACOSTA HALF THE COST. TO THE
STATE. OF NURSING FACILITIES. I
ALSO JOIN COLLEAGUES IN A TO
CUTS OF THIRTY MY DOLLARS THE
CAL NOW TO GET A PROGRAM
NAVIGATOR. IS A- IN THE STATE
COUNTIES YOU BASED. SUPPORT
ATTENTION IN YOU LOSE A SPORTS
MAY CAL CAL. ALL THE MILLION
COMPOSE CUTS OF NOT PROGRAM.
WAS A SICK MILLION DOLLAR. IN
SERVICES. CAN HELP PART AND
HEALTHIER TO KEPT ON ASIAN ON
THE PRO IN SAN HER ACCOUNT.
PROFITED GREATLY DURING THIS
POINT PANDEMIC. I SURE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF MORE THAN FORTY
PROGRESSIVE AND ANTI POVERTY
GROUPS WHO SENT A LETTER
CALLING OUT CALLING OUT THE OLD
CUTS BUDGET THE WRONG DIRECTION
FOR THE STATE. THIS IS THE SAME
PLAYBOOK THE STATE USE DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION AND
RESULTANT DECADES OF DIFFICULT
RECOVERY. THE ONLY FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE GREATEST INCOME
INEQUALITY THAT HAS EVER BEEN
MEASURED AND THAT WAS BEFORE-THE CRISIS OUR ECONOMY WAS
BOOMING FOR THE FEW. ALL
CREATING COST LIVING TRAUMA FOR
THE MANY. I DO HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS RICHARD CUTS ANY. THE
INCREASES THAT CAN VOTER FOR
THE PART. WE TASK PROTECT. YOU
MUST ENSURE REYES EQUITY
INCLUSION AND OLD GREATER
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT MEANS ALLOCATE
TARGETED RESOURCES TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR NOW
AND THROUGHOUT THE RECOVERY
PROCESS XCELERATED PROTECTION.
HELP ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
DEMOCRATIC PARTICIPATION.
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE INVESTMENTS
AND HEALTH CARE AND ECONOMIC
SAFETY NET FOR ALL. REGARDLESS
OF STATUS PROTECT TENANT
PROTECTION AS HOMEOWNERS A
SMALL. LOSING THEIR HOMES
INVEST IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ALL WORKING CALIFORNIANS
EMPOWER AND PROTECT ALL WORKERS
INCLUDING THROUGH MECHANISMS
THAT INCLUDE WORKERS IN SETTING
AND FORCE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
HEALTH. AND ECONOMIC STANDARDS.
WE MUST BEGIN TO REBALANCE THE
ECONOMY A COMBINATION NEW
CORPORATE WINDFALL. AND YES
WELL TO WAS STEPPED UP CONTRA
FROM THE WHO HAVE BEEN. THE
MOST FROM CAL ECONOMY. WE CAN
PUSH OUT REVENUE DISCUSSIONS
ASSEMBLY LINE THAT OUR PEOPLE
NEED US NOW. WITHOUT ONGOING
SOLUTIONS TRIGGER CUTS WHENEVER
TURN INTO DUSTING WOULD. IN A
SERVICES. THREATENING THE VERY
SAME ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE AIM
TO PROTECT. WE CANNOT SIMPLY
BORROW. FOR OUR WAY OF THIS. I
WITH COLLEAGUES OF BUDGET IS. A
MORAL DOCUMENT THIS IS NOT FOR
US TO BE ABOUT IT ARE THROUGH
THE LENS OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
FOR THOSE MOST CONCERNED THAT
OKAY COUNT ON ROAD THAT'S A
COMMON TO REFER. BUT CHOICE ARE
MADE BETWEEN POLITICAL IDEOLOGY.
OVER PROTECTING THE PEOPLE WE
ARE CAN. TO SERVE PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS WE MUST PRESERVE
AND HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE HOUSING IS
HEALTHCARE PREVENT HUNGER
BECAUSE ECONOMIC JUSTICE. LET
US ALSO HAVE OF A ONCE BEFORE
ABOUT. THE BY. OF A- BASED
HEALTH. IT'S A NOTE THAT ALL.
HELPS TO LIVE OF THOSE PROFIT
OF IT THANK HAVE A REAL DEBATE
ON THAT FOR A- AND SING A PAYER
HEALTH FINAL. WE DO NOT
DIFFICULT TO MAKE LET US MAKE
THE MORAL. TO ERR ON THE OF CAL
FOR. TO CHOOSE A PATH TO GO
TOGETHER. RATHER THAN MAKE
CHOICES THAT DEAN SO SAID
PROCESS. ON WHERE THE OF THE
CAL DREAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS KAMLAGER THEN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE REYES AND KOREA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR CONVENING THIS
COMMITTEE OF WHOLE I THINK THIS
IS A HISTORIC I WANT TO START
BY SAYING YOU DON'T YOU FORTY
HAVE A FAMOUS CALL CHOICE. AND
ONE OF THE LEADER IS THAT
EVERYBODY HAS CHOICES AND I
HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT THE
CHOICES THAT ARE IN THIS BUDGET
ARE NOT ARE ONLY ONE. I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT THE CUTS
TO PROP FIFTY SIX- STRIP
FUNDING FROM REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS LIKE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD MAKING US
EQUALLY GUILTY OF BLOCKING
ACCESS TO CRITICAL AND TIME
SENSITIVE CARE THE TOTAL CUTS
AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE WOULD
BE ONE BILLION DOLLARS. BECAUSE
OF A NINE TO ONE FEDERAL MATCH.
THESE CHOICES DON'T WORK FOR
WOMEN LOW INCOME ETHNIC WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THIS PANDEMIC. AND ALSO WHO ARE
THE PATIENTS OF SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WHO WILL BE CRIPPLED
BY THE DEVASTATING CUTS TO
MEDICARE ALL. AND FAMILY PACKED.
THESE CHOICES ALSO DON'T WORK
FOR CARE GIVERS AGAIN MOSTLY
WOMEN WHO'VE TAKEN CARE OF
SPOUSES AND CHILDREN WHO HAVE
DIED OR HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED
IN THE LONG TERM CARE WHO ARE
STILL IN ELIGIBLE. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
AND THIS NEEDS TO BE FIXED. AS
A MEMBER OF THE LOS THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
JUST HAVE TO SAY NO CUTS TO
CHILD CARE PROTECTIVE. FULL
STOP. AS A MEMBER OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DELEGATION I'M
HERE TO SAY THAT TRIGGER CUTS
TO THE M. OKAY HOSPITAL WILL BE
A DEATH TRIGGER. TO THE SOUTH
LA INTO THE ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES WHAT THAT HOSPITAL
SERVICE THAT IS A NO WIN
PROPOSITION AT ALL COSTS. THE
SPECIAL ED PROPOSAL IS NOT
EQUITABLE FOR THOSE DISTRICT
LIKE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT EDUCATE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH MODERATE TO
SEVERE DISABILITIES. FAIR SHARE
IS IMPORTANT. ESPECIALLY FOR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE THAT BIG YOU
DO THAT. YOU WOULD HAVE PULLED
THE RUG UNDER. UP FOR UNDER A
YOU KNOW. I THINK IT'S SHORT
SIGHTED THAT TO OUT THE
PROPOSED. FOR PROBATE REFORM WE
THIS IS THE WHEN CAN RE I'M-
THE SIX. FOR WHAT PRO LOOKS
LIKE WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WE NEED
TO USE THIS OPPORTUNITY
ESPECIALLY SEEING THAT SO MANY
OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS AND
BEGINNING TO STREAMLINE AND
LOOK AT HOW TO BE CREATIVE AS A
RESULT OF COVERT. TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW I BELIEVE THAT
IT CAN BE DONE. AND LASTLY WITH
REGARD TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS THE GOVERNOR DID I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS RIGHT
BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE VALLEY
THE GOVERNOR STARTED THIS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS LET'S NOT STOP
THE TRAIN BECAUSE OF KOBE. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAX CUTS. I'M SORRY TO TAX
CREDITS. AND THROUGH FUNDING
AND TO LEVERAGING PRIVATE
CAPITAL. TO BE INNOVATIVE AND
HOW WE DO RIGHT BY THOSE WHO
ARE ON HOUSEOR WHO ARE LIVING
ON THE MARGINS WE CAN LOOK AT
PHONES I GUARANTEE RENT FOR
QUALIFY PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND WE CAN
LOOK AT HOW TO FUND THE
PURCHASE OF THOSE. MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE CONNECTING ONCE
AGAIN TO MISSION DRIVEN
NONPROFIT. WE CAN CUT OUR WAY
OUT OF THIS BUT THAT WILL NOT
GIVE US WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY SAYING
PEOPLE WOULD RATHER FAIL ON
CONVENTIONALLY NO PEOPLE WOULD
RATHER FAIL CONVENTIONALLY THAN
SIX FEET ON CONVENTIONALLY. AND
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED IN VERY UNCONVENTIONAL
WAYS BY THINKING- ABOUT HOW TO
LOOK AT THIS BUDGET INCISIVE
LEISTER. LEVERAGING DOLLARS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND PASSING A BUDGET THAT
IS DIGNIFIED SO I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A TON OF NEW WANTS
QUESTIONS AND WHAT I SAID BUT I
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE TIME THAT WE HAVE NOW
TO REALLY BEGIN TO LOOK AT BOTH
RVENUES AND ALSO OPPORTUNITIES
TO FIND THINGS IN A WAY THAT
WILL BE EFFICIENT AND
STREAMLINED AND WILL BE
DIGNIFIED FOR THE CONSTITUENTS
OF THE STATE. THANK YOU. MISS
ROSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AS WE LEARN TO LEGISLATE DURING
THESE UNPREDICTABLE AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT WE NOT FORGET WHAT
IS IT THAT LED US TO BECOME
LEGISLATORS FOR ME LIKE FOR
MANY OF YOU IT WAS IN NEED OF
MY COMMUNITY TO HAVE A VOICE.
AS THIS PANDEMIC ERUPTED IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
COPE WITH NINETEEN. QUOTE IF
YOU LIVE IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY THE AIR YOU BREATHE
MIGHT PUT YOUR YOUR HEALTH AT
RISK. THIS IS FROM THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION SATED BEER
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
WE AL KNOW THAT STUDIES ARE
BEGINNING TO SHOW THAT AIR
POLLUTION EXACERBATES
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS FURTHER
LEADING TO INCREASED DEATHS
LINKED TO COPE WITH NINETEEN.
GIVEN THE TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES
THAT AIR QUALITY HAVE ALREADY
HAD ON THE HEALTH OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. AND THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN POOR AIR
QUALITY AND AN INCREASE IN COPD
NINETEEN DEATHS IT IS
ESPECIALLY CLEAR THE FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION AND
PROGRAMS AIMED AT REDUCING
EMISSIONS AT THE SOURCE OR MORE
VITAL THAN EVER. THE DEATHS ARE
NOT HAPPENING EQUALLY AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
LATINOS MAKE UP A 53% OF ALL
POSITIVE CASES IN CALIFORNIA
AND ARE DYING
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE
COMPARED TO OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS.
IN THESE DIRE TIMES WE NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES. ALL OF
OUR FAMILIES INCLUDING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION.
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
CONTINUING TO RECEIVE VERY
LITTLE ASSISTANCE DURING THIS
PERIOD OF NEED COMPARED TO
THEIR DOCUMENT APPEARS DESPITE
MANY OF THEM MAKING UP OUR
CENTRAL WORKERS. CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENTLY HOME TO MORE THAN TWO
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
AS WAS NOTED EARLIER WHO
CONTRIBUTE WHAT IS ESTIMATED TO
BE OVER THREE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO NORTH
HOLLYWOOD WHO AND OTHERS. WE
NEED TO EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT KELLY
I TO YOU SEE TO SERVE ALL
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS AS THE
KELLY YEAH I TO SEE HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO BE A FUNDAMENTAL
INVESTMENT IN THE ECONOMY. OF
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES. BY
EXTENDING THE KELLY I TO SEE T
ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE TAX FILERS
WE CAN TAKE SERIOUS AND JUST
STEPS TO REDUCE THE CURRENT AND
EXPECTED EFFECTS OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. FOR OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
MANY WHO COME FROM MIX STATUS
HOUSEHOLDS WERE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE FAMILY FILE WITH THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. THERE'S
NO REASON THESE TAXPAYERS WHO
HAVE INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. MANY OF WILL
MAKE UP OUR CENTRAL WORKFORCE
SHOULD NOT BE RECEIVING THEIR
EARNED TAX CREDIT AS CRUCIAL
MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
FINALLY AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE I ASKED THE
CALIFORNIA SAFETY NOT BE
PROVIDED FOR PROTECTION OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SO THEY DON'T FALL
TO ROCK BOTTOM. CALIFORNIA'S
ROAD TO RECOVERY SHOULD NOT BE
PAID WITH CUTS TO THE VITAL
SERVICES FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND THE DIRE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
MOVING COMMAS AND DECIMALS.
BUDGET COLUMN TO ANOTHER. THESE
ADJUSTMENTS AUGMENTATIONS IN
BUDGET SPEAK ARE NOT SIMPLY
BUDGET ACCOUNTING FORMULAS BUT
WILL IMPACT REAL PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WILL
ALREADY FACE THE BRUNT OF COOL
WOULD NINETEEN AND WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO RECOVER FROM THE
ECONOMIC SETBACKS OF THE GREAT
RECESSION. WE MUST NOT BALANCE
THE BUDGET ON THE BACKS OF
THOSE THAT HAVE ALREADY
SUFFERED. I WANT TO ALSO LEARN
MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SANTA ROSA AND
MY NEIGHBOR AND SAMBAR TO DO
YOU KNOW. WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES OUR
STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS OUR
SENIORS ARE FOSTER YOUTH OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE VICTIMS
ARE TEACHERS. THE AGENT IN THE
POOR AND THE DISABLED SHOULD
NOT BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED. AS WE BALANCE THE
BUDGET. WILL WE REMEMBER. THAT
WE BECAME LEGISLATORS TO GIVE A
VOICE TO OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
THAT THE VOICE OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ARE JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THE VOICE OF THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN PROTECTED AND
HAVE NOT PERSONALLY SUFFERED.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
STATED EARLIER. WE SHOULD
REMAIN A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO AND THE NEXT WE HAVE
MISTER ROBERT RIVAS MISTER
JONES SAWYER AND THEN MISS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY AS A MEMBER OF THE LA
COUNTY DELEGATION TO SPEAK OF
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF
EDUCATION. I'M ALSO GOING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS LONG TERM CARE
HOMELESSNESS AND LASTLY THE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE CALIFORNIA I
CAN TAX PAYER CONTINUED TO MARK
TO BE MARGINALIZED. THROUGHOUT
THE COVE IN NINETEEN CRISIS THE
LA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
THE LARGEST IN THE STATE
SERVING APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS 73% OF WHOM
ARE LATINO. 92% OF WHICH ARE
ENGLISH LEARNERS MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE SPANISH SPEAKERS
FOLLOWED BY STUDENTS TO SPEAK
ARMENIAN KOREAN TOOK ALL-
CANTONESE IN VIETNAMESE. TO
NAME A FEW. RENTS ARE
FRUSTRATED TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
DISTANCE LEARNING. TEACHERS ARE
TRYING TO NAVIGATE NEW
PLATFORMS. AND MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WHO ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. LIKE INTERNET AND
LAPTOPS FOR THEIR CHILDREN. THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS REAL. AND THE
CHIEF MAY GAP IS ONLY GROWING
LARGER. AS WE KNOW EQUAL IT'S
NOT THE SAME AS EQUITABLE. AND
WE CANNOT IN GOOD CONSCIENCE.
AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE. TO PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES WILL NOT PROVIDING
THE FUNDING NECESSARY. WHEN IT
COMES TO SPECIAL EDUCATION I
REPRESENT THE MOST STUDENTS
WITH MODERATE TO SEVERE
DISABILITIES. IN ALL OF ALLEY
WAS THE- THE MAY REVISE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
EQUALIZATION PROPOSAL USES A
FORMULA. THAT DOESN'T SUPPORT
EQUITY. SINCE IT FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THE AMOUNT OF SERVICE
TO STUDENTS WITH MODERATE TO
SEVERE DISAILITIES NEED. THE
STATE WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR A
COVERT NINETEEN GENERATION OF
STUDENTS WHO WILL. NOT LEARN TO
READ BY THIRD GRADE READING
LEVELS THERE BY ONLY INCREASING
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON TO PRISON
PIPELINE WHICH IS VERY REAL.
MEMBERS OF THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. OUR
STUDENTS DESERVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO LEARN TO READ. AND
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
THIS IS WHY LA UNIFIED LABOR
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS I JOIN
BY CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SAN DIEGO LONG BEACH
SAN FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND. TO
REJECT THIS PROPOSAL AND HAVE
SUBMITTED LETTERS WITH
ALTERNATIVE. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISED AFTER SCHOOL
FUNDING WAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
SLASH WITH AN OVERALL FUNDING
REDUCTION OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR STATEWIDE A 15%
CUT COMPARED TO AN EIGHT POINT
6% CUT TO THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUND. FOR LA'S BEST THIS WILL
RESULT IN A DEFICIT OF OVER
FIVE MILLION IN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. AS THE LARGEST AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE
IMPACT OF THESE CUTS WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURT WORKING
FAMILIES AND HINDER THE
REGION'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THE
CURRENT CRISIS IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WITH TEN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS 84% OF
CHILDREN ARE ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED NINE AND TEN OR
CHILDREN OF COLOR ONE IN THREE
OR ENGLISH LEARNERS. 25% ARE
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND THE
IMPACT WILL BE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND JOBS. WHEN IT COMES TO
LONG TERM CARE OLDER ADULTS 65%
AND OVER. COUNT I'M SORRY 65%
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER ACCOUNT
476% OF DEATHS RELATED TO COAL
BUT YET AT THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSES SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX MILLION TO CUTS TO SENIORS.
INCLUDING 7% CUT TO AYE HSS
ELIMINATING THE COMMUNITY BASED
AT ALL SERVICE PROGRAM
ELIMINATING THE ELIMINATION OF
THE MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM IT TAKES AWAY
VITAL BUT MEDI CAL BENEFITS
SUCH AS EYE GLASSES HEARING
AIDS DENTAL SERVICES. PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND MANY MORE AT A TIME
IN WHICH WE ARE TRYING TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF NURSING
HOMES AND ASSISTED LIVING WE
SHOULD BE WE SHOULD NOT BE
CUTTING SERVICES THAT WILL KEEP
PEOPLE SAFELY AT HOME. AND OUT
OF HOSPITALS. WHEN IT COMES
THIRTY. MINUTES THE CITY OF LA
IS REELING WITH CONTINUED
INCREASES TO WORK ON HOUSE
POPULATION. THIS IS WHY ALSO
SUPPORT. HELPING LEAD THE
EFFORT OF TWO BILLION AND
ONGOING AND I'M GOING FUNDING
LASTLY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO THE
SENTIMENTS ECHOED BEFORE THERE
ARE ONE POINT TWO MILLION I TO
TAXPAYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TROOPS THREE POINT
TWO BILLION. IN STATE TAXES IT
IS WRONG. THE DEMOCRATIC
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE THAT TAXES
AWAY FROM INDIVIDUALS AND TURN
AROUND AND SAY YOU ARE NOT
WORTHY OF ANY HELP. THIS IS WHY
I SUPPORT THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR AYE TEN TAXPAYERS.
MEMBERS THE STATE IS FACING 25%
UNEMPLOYMENT. NOTHING WE HAVE
EXPRESSED TODAY MAKES ANY
DIFFERENCE IS WHAT THE END OF
THE DAY WE LACK A STRONG
FOUNDATION IN EDUCATION THAT
INSURERS. ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. WE
MUST ACT WITH COURAGE AND MEET
WITH THE MORE COMPASS THAT
SERVES. FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
THE CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHATEVER MISTER
ROBERTS. ALL THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
TING VICE CHAIR OBERNOLTE AND
COLLEAGUES. NEARLY TEN YEARS
AGO I BEGAN MY SERVICE- AS A
MEMBER OF THE SEVEN OH COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. I HAD TO
DEAL WITH AT THAT TIME THE
LINGERING ECONOMIC INSTABILITY
THAT WAS BROUGHT ON BY THE
GREAT RECESSION. UNEMPLOYMENT
ARE COUNTY WAS AT NEARLY TWENTY
PERCENT. A RECORD NUMBER OF
LOCAL BUSINESSES HAD SHUT DOWN.
AND HOUSING CONSTRUCTION WHICH
ARE COUNTY SO- THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEEDED HAD PRETTY
MUCH COME TO A HALT. EVERYONE
WAS AFFECTED TEN YEARS AGO. BUT
WHAT BECAME CLEAR TO ME WITH
THAT THE MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WERE
HURTING THE MOST. THESE WERE
THE PEOPLE WONDERING WHETHER
NEXT PAYCHECKS WOULD COME FROM.
HOW THEY PAY THE RENT OR
MORTGAGE THE NEXT MONTH. HOW
THEY'D BE THEIR KIDS HOW THEY
KEEP THEM SAFE. AND TO RESPOND
TO THAT ECONOMIC CRISIS TO HELP
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE WE CAME
TOGETHER AS A COUNTY. WE FORGE
NEW PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
LOCAL AND REGIONAL-
MUNICIPALITIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. WE WORK WITH OUR
SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS. WE ARE
FIREFIGHTERS WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. WITH OUR POLICE
AND SHERIFF'S OFFICERS WHAT ARE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. WE FORGE
PARTNERSHIPS IN ORDER TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET. TO SAVE FOR
THE FUTURE AND TO ENSURE TO
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC SERVICES FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE WERE
PROTECTED. IT WASN'T EASY BUT
WE DEALT WITH THE CHALLENGES TO
GATHER. IN OUR COUNTY WAS
STRONGER IN THE END. NOW OUR
STATE FINDS ITSELF ONCE AGAIN
IN A MOMENT OF ECONOMIC CRISIS
NONE OF US HERE. KNOW WHAT THE
FUTURE HOLDS. BUT I BELIEVE
THAT THROUGH THIS CRISIS IT IS
AN OPPORTUNITY. IF WE ACT
WISELY IN THIS MOMENT IF WE
COME TOGETHER WE CAN BUILD A
STRONGER STATE WE CAN BUILD A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA. OUR
RESPONSE AS A STATE MUST BE
ROBUST AND SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
THE ENTIRE WORLD. FOR THE MORE
I WOULD ASK ALL OF YOU HERE. MY
COLLEAGUES IN THOSE LISTENING
TO OUR DISCUSSION PLEASE NOT TO
FORGET ABOUT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE STATE. MANY
OF YOU KNOW MY STORY I WAS
RAISED BY A SINGLE PARENT MY
MOTHER BY MY GRANDPARENTS THEY
WERE IMMIGRANTS IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS. AND IN THIS CRISIS
THE CENTRAL WORKERS. WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO FORGET ABOUT OUR HARD
WORKING FARMWORKERS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO HAVE CONTINUE TO
FEED OUR COUNTRY THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. WHETHER THEY ARE
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED.
THEY HAVE WORKED TO PUT FOOD ON
OUR TABLE. ON AND ON THE TABLES
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS HERE
IN THIS COUNTRY. WE OWE IT TO
THEM TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. A DECENT
HOME FOR THEIR FAMILY. ANY
NUTRITIOUS FOOD TO EAT AND IN
THIS PANDEMIC IT IS THE
REMINDED US I KNOW IS REMINDED
ME OF A FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH A
TRUTH. THAT AT THIS. THAT THAT
AS A STATE AS A AS A COUNTRY WE
OFTEN OVERLOOK AS A SIDE. AT
THAT AT A RISK TO SOME OF US IS
A RISK TO ALL OF US. WE ARE
ONLY AS HEALTHY AS ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. THIRTY SECOND AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO FIND THE BEST
PATH FORWARD TO PROTECT OUR
GREAT STATE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
GOODNESS FRIEDMAN SHE SEEMS
READY THEY WILL GO OF MISTER
JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU A THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO
FIRST THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOME
SPEAKER RENDON AND CARE TING
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT REALLY A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT AREAS- ALL DEALING
WITH THIS BUDGET AND HOW IT
IMPACTS RECOVERY OUR ABILITY TO
REBUILD IS A STATE AND
RESILIENCY WHICH I THINK SHOULD
OR OUR MANTRA. AFTER ANY KIND
OF DISASTER. YOU KNOW WE TALKED
FOR A LONG TIME. ON THIS FLOOR
IN THIS BODY. ABOUT HOW. SO
MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ONLY A COUPLE OF
PAYCHECKS AWAY FROM FINANCIAL
RUIN AND WE'VE NOW SEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE HAVE AN ENTIRE
STATE. THAT LOSES ITS PAYCHECK
FOR A COUPLE OF WEEKS AND I
THINK THAT THAT SHOULD SHOW US
THAT OUR ECONOMY IS NOT NEARLY
AS RESILIENT. AS WE MAY HAVE
THOUGHT WE'VE HAD FOR A LONG
TIME AND ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WORKED EXTREMELY WELL
FOR A VERY FEW AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
AND WE TALK ABOUT REBUILDING
AND RECOVERY I HOPE THAT A
RECOVERY IS NOT AS WITH AN EYE
TOWARDS GETTING BACK WHERE WE
BECAUSE IT DOES HOW TO SOLVE
THOSE ISSUES THAT LED TO SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS BEING. JUST A
COUPLE OF PAYCHECKS AWAY FROM
LOSING THE ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS. NOW COLBERT NINETEEN IS
HIDDEN CERTAIN POPULATIONS MORE
THAN OTHERS. IT'S NO SURPRISE
TO A LOT OF US THAT IT'S HIT.
ARE SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
BLACK IN OUR BROWN COMMUNITIES
MORE THAN IT'S HEARD A LOT OF
OTHER COMMUNITIES. THERE'S A
LOT OF REASONS TO GO INTO THAT
I DON'T THINK IT'S GENETICS. I
THINK IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
SYSTEMIC IN LONG TERMS UNDER
INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE
POPULATIONS. AND THE RESULTS
THAT THAT'S HAD OF BEEN REALLY-
TRAUMATIC AND WE'VE GOT A FIX
THAT AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
BUDGET DOESN'T DO MORE HARM. TO
THOSE VERY COMMUNITIES THAT
MEANS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT OUR
INVESTMENTS. IN CHILD CARE. IN
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND ARE HEALTH
FACILITIES. IN OUR ELDERLY WHO
ARE FRAIL AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED IN OUR FOSTER
YOUTH WHO WERE SO
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
HOMELESSNESS. AND BY LATER ON
A- GOING INTO PRISONS. IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS THAT IN LOS
ANGELES ALREADY WORK REALLY THE
SAME OF THE STATE AND IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE. THIS IS
GOING TO MAKE THAT
EXPONENTIALLY WORSE. CERTAINLY
IN EDUCATION WHICH SHOULD BE
THE PRIDE OF OUR STATE. ON THE
OTHER THING I WANT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT BEFORE I GET TO
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES. IS REALLY.
RESILIENCY AT MAKING SURE THAT
WHAT WE INVEST THAT WE DON'T.
PULL INVESTMENTS FROM SOME THAT
THEY MIGHT HELP BALANCE BUDGET.
BUT THE ON THE ROAD ACOSTA EXT.
MORE BECAUSE THEY WERE PROGRAMS
THAT KEPT US SAFE. SAFE THAT
EITHER KEPT US PHYSICALLY SAFE
BECAUSE OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
OR KEPT OUR COMMUNITY SAFE BY
INVESTING IN THOSE SOCIAL
PROGRAMS. AND LATER- OF FUTURE
GENERATIONS EVEN MAYBE JUST
FIVE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD WE'RE
GOING TO COST US MUCH MUCH
MORE. IN NOT JUST IN OUR BUDGET
IN FINANCIAL TERMS. BUT IN OUR
IN HUMAN CALL AUSTIN REAL HE
COST WEAPONS ABOUT A- OF THE-
FIRST AS I MAY. HOUSE AND HOME.
NOW IT'S S. THAT SHORTAGE A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN AND CAL
DEPRESSES THE GDP. JUST ACROSS
THE TAKE EL MATCH AREA BY MORE
THAN TWO PECENT. THIS
TRANSLATES INTO EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN LOST OUTPUT. JUST
FOR THE LOS ANGELES REGION AND
ALMOST DOUBLE THAT AMOUNT FOR
ALL OF LA COUNTY. I URGE YOU TO
SWITCH OUT TO SPECIFY THAT THE
TAX CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE
WARDS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PREVENTION TAX CREDITS. THIS
ALLOWANCE CAN PRESERVE THE
AFFORDABILITY OF ROUGHLY TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOMES AND MOBILE HOMES SPACES.
NOW FOSTER YOUTH. ALREADY IN
SUCH A PRECARIOUS POSITION IN
OUR STATE. I'M WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATIONS
CUTS TO VITAL PROGRAMS TAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET WE RISK.
IRREPARABLE HARM THOUGHT THAT
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE DO YOU
PROPOSE ELIMINATE THE HOUSING
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM WHICH WILL A
JUST. IMPACT ON FOSTER USE. AND
I JUST WANTED TO IS ALSO SAY
AND I WANTED TO SPEND MORE TIME
ON THIS SO IF YOU'LL JUST GIVE
ME A COUPLE OF SECONDS. AS
CHAIR OF NATURAL. RESOURCES
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE ROLE
BACK OF KEY PROGRAM SERVICE
AND- FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM CRISIS WHEN
IT COMES TO WILD FIRE. I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS AT HOW
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES AT HIGH POPULATION
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE VERY HIGH
RISK. OF WILDFIRE BUT BECAUSE
WE HAVE CHAPARRAL AND NOT HIGH
VALUE FOREST'S. LOS ANGELES
ONLY RECEIVES A OF SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE FUNDS FOR THE
KINDS OF REMEDIATION AND
MITIGATION. THAT COULD REALLY
REDUCE RISK ALL ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE INVEST IN
ECOLOGICAL HABITATS-
RESTORATION AND PROGRAMS THAT
WE KNOW. THAT TIME WILL SAVE US
IN TERMS OF HUMAN LIVES AND
ALSO IN FINANCIAL COST. THANK
YOU- AT MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU. GOING TO
GO TO A JONES SAWYER THAN WE
HAVE. MISS REPEAT. AND THEN
MISTER GRAYSON AND THEN MISS
POLLY. THAT YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND IN. AND CHAIRMAN KING AND
CHAIR OVER I ALSO WANT TO THANK
GOD NEW SO FOR HIS COULD
WORKING YOU RELEASED FOR TO
THIS. IS BIASED A FUND FOR AND
UNDOCUMENTED. HOWEVER LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS DROP
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING IN MY
DISTRICT WERE ALREADY
VULNERABLE TO HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC DISPARITIES BEFORE
KOBE NINETY AND WILL FACE MORE
HARDSHIPS AS RECOVER FROM THIS
CRISIS THAT IS WHY I ASKED THE
GOVERNOR NOT ONLY FOR FUNDING
FOR UNDOCUMENTED BUT ALSO
ASKING FOR A TASK FORCE TO LOOK
AT COVERT NINETEEN AND
ESPECIALLY WHY AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINOS SUFFER
MORE SO NOT ONLY ECONOMICALLY.
BUT THE NUMBER OF DEATHS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED AS A MEMBER OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DELEGATION OUR PRIORITIES ARE
HEALTH EDUCATION HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS THEY WERE BOTH MY
DISTRICTS PRIORITIES AND ALSO
WITH THE DELEGATIONS PRIORITIES
EVEN BEFORE PROVIDE NINETEEN
AND HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC. I HOWEVER BY. BY
THIS DISEASE AND IF. IT'S
BECOME MORE CRUCIAL AS A RESULT
OF JAPAN DAMAGE. IT IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
SOMETHING NOW. AND THAT IS WHY
I'M GOING TO PROPOSE A SOUTH
LOS ANGELES ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PLAN. KIND OF STIMULUS PACKAGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT SOUTH LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS ONE OF THE
POOREST DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS A VERY VERY EASY WAY A
VERY LARGE CRACK THAT IS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THIS PANDEMIC.
WELL I WOULD BE PROPOSING IS
HEALTH CARE FUNDING FOR CLINICS
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES WE DON'T
HAVE HOSPITALS WE HAVE LIKE
NINETY NINE POINT 99% OF THE
HEALTH CARE IS PROVIDED BY
CLINICS SO WE SHOULD RETURN ONE
POINT TWO BILLION IMPROPER.
FIFTY SIX FUNDS INCREASE
STIMULUS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS UNDER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WOULD DOUBLE THE FIVE
HUNDRED ALREADY RELEASE. UNTO
PROHIBITION ON CAL E. I. T. C.
FOUR E. I. T. N. OUR FLIGHT OF
FILERS SIXTY FIVE MILLION TO
SUPPORT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BANKS TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY BRIDGE FOR LOANS TO
SMALL BUSINESSES IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES RIGHT
NOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
NOT GIVE TO IMMIGRANTS FOR
FUNDING IN MY DISTRICT FOR
EXAMPLE THIS SMALL BUSINESSES
THERE ARE MOSTLY. FROM
IMMIGRANT POPULATION THE
LARGEST SINGLE PROVIDER YES IS
UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUT THAT PALES IN COMPARISON
THE AMOUNT OF BUSINESS IN ABOUT
IT PEOPLE THAT THE EMPLOYEE.
NEXT LAUSD. I HAVE THE MOST LA
YOU SCHOOLS. ENDED AND THE-
MOST CHARTER SCHOOL. IN THE
DISH. I'M ASKING TO REJECT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION EQUALIZATION
FORMULA- SCHOOL FUNDING HAVE
INCLUDE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION FUNDING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED
BEFORE. WE HAVE TO START
CREATING JOBS THAT ARE
SUSTAINABLE AND LONG LASTING IN
A- CAREER ORIENTED. AND THEN
FINALLY. LOOKING AT NEW
RESEARCH NEW SOURCES OF INCOME
COMING INTO TO THE CAPITAL I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT TAXES. I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT PUTTING A
BURDEN ON ONE PERSON I'M TALK
ABOUT LOOKING INTO THIRTY SO
WHAT WE CAN DO NOW LIKE AMNESTY
FOR FINES AND FEES THAT IN THE
COURT SYSTEM THEY HAVE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
FINES AND FEES IF WE JUST HAD
AN AMNESTY PROGRAM WHERE WE CAN
GET A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS%
BACK. THAT WOULD BE GREAT DRAW
DOWN ON A MAXIMUM FEDERAL FUNDS
FEMA. I USED TO BE IMMERSED
PARENTS COORDINATOR DEAR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE CAN
GET BACK FROM FEMA AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY JUST
FILLING OUT AN APPLICATION.
FEMA HAS MONEY FOR DISASTERS
LIKE THIS THAT WE CAN GET
REIMBURSED IN THE BILLIONS AND
WE'RE NOT ACTIVATING THAT AS
MUCH AS WE CAN AND FINALLY
WORKING WITH THE PART PART TO
NOT ONLY MINIMIZED CUTS BUT
HAVE IMPORTANT WITH THIS SO IF
THEY DO FINE A WAY THEY CAN BE
CAN. COME UP WITH REVENUE
WITHOUT INCREASING FEES AND
FINES IN TEXAS. WE SHOULD NOT
BE PENALIZED BY CUTTING THE
BUDGET SHOULD INCENTIVIZE THEM
MAKE SURE TO BUDGET STAY THE
SAME IT MAY BE GIVEN 10% OF
WHAT THEY FINE. OTHERWISE IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE FOR THEM
TO DO IT BECAUSE OF THE
PRACTICES IS ONCE THEY RAISE
MONEY OR LOWER THEIR THEIR
THEIR ABILITY TO DO THINGS WE
CUT THEM DOWN EVEN MORE SO IN
THE BUDGET AND SO WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE REVENUE ENHANCEMENTS.
THAT DO NOT AFFECT THE GENERAL
FUND AND DO NOT AFFECT THE WAY
WE TAX THE- THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO. MISS BETWEEN THE-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I SHARE THE CONCERN
THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE EXPRESSED
TODAY THAT HAD THE CUTS AS A
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE
WOULD HIT THE CALIFORNIANS WHO
CAN LEAST AFFORD IT. IF I GOT
HURT BREAKING HEARTBREAKING
CUTS TO CHILD CARE EDUCATION TO
HEALTH CARE TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE TO OUR SENIORS I
THINK FOR ME AS- AS A MOTHER
AND AS A MEMBER OF THIS BODY
THAT CUTS THAT I FIND MOST
HEARTBREAKING. THIS THE FACT
THAT THIS BUDGET FAILS
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS AND WE TALK
ABOUT DEVASTATING CUTS TO
EDUCATION IT'S NOT JUST A LINE
ITEM IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA KIDS IN IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE. OB SO. COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU DIRECTOR AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH US TODAY SO FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. BEFORE WE
CONTEMPLATE ANY OF THESE TRULY
DEVASTATING CUTS. IN BEFORE WE
ASK CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS TO
OPEN THEIR WALLET EVER WIDER I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE REALLY
HONEST WITH OURSELVES AND
REALLY SCRUTINIZE. OUR SPENDING
AND ENSURE THAT WE ARE SPENDING
CALIFORNIA'S TAX DOLLARS
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY SO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MERCED
MENTIONED. I'M THAT OVER THE
COURSE I THINK IT'S THE PAST
TEN YEARS WE'VE SEEN A 70%
GROWTH IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES AND NON EDUCATION
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES. AT
THE SAME TIME THAT OUR
POPULATION HAS GROWN BY TEN
PERCENT. WITH HELP ME WRAP MY
MIND AROUND THAT BECAUSE THAT
TO ME SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A TON
OF OPPORTUNITY THERE- AND THEN
QUESTION TO YOU YOU DIDN'T
INCLUDE ONE SIDE THAT TALKS
ABOUT. OPPORTUNITIES TO ENHANCE
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY SAID
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M WOULD
LOVE TO AGAIN JUST UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ABOUT
WHAT THAT ACTUALLY MEANS HOW
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GET FOR
THAT. AS WELL AS A WHAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES WERE EXPLORED
EVALUATED AND- ANGELES HONEST
AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW ARE WE
GOING TO CONFRONT. AS WE SAID
IN A PRESS BASIS. AT ME IN FREE
FALL. THANK YOU I'M INTO OF AS
THAT THE GROWTH OF THE NON
EIGHT XP THE BIG COME. OF THE
NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF THE- I'M
OUR UPS HEALTH IN HUMANS.
HIGHER AND THE CORRECTIONAL
BUDGET- THOSE ARE THE MAIN
COMPONENTS- THERE'S ALSO DEBT
SERVICE- THERE ARE PENSION
COSTS AS WELL THAT ARE SPREAD
AMONG THE GENERAL FUND AND
SPECIAL FUNDS AND THEN THERE
ARE SOME GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES AND IN BOTH
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY MAINLY
PARKS AND FISH AND WILDLIFE
WHICH WERE WIDE THOSE TWO
DEPARTMENTS IN THAT ENTIRE.
TIRE AGENCY WERE- THERE ARE
SOME SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
THE BUDGET AND AT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO PROPOSED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE A PROFICIENT
WILDLIFE AND THOSE THOSE ARE
REALLY THERE'S A LOT OF. A LOT
OF WHAT'S IN THOSE RESOURCES
AGENCY ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY ARE BOTH OF FUNDED WITH
SPECIAL FUNDS THE SAME WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AS WELL. SO A FEW OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS AND WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED THE OPTIONAL
EXPANSION- TO MEDI CAL WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT I'M COVERING
ALL. AS A LOW INCOME I
CALIFORNIANS- AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PARTICIPATES AT AND
SIGNIFICANTLY AND FUNDING THAT.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN A TO MAKES
INVESTMENTS IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND THAT HAVE
BEEN VERY VERY IMPORTANT. ADD
TO THAT SPENDING ACCESS TO A
SPECIAL ADDRESSING ISSUES OF
EQUITY. SO THERE'S A FEW OF THE
THINGS ACT ON TERMS DEBTS. WE
FAX TO. OVER THE AT IN TERMS OF
OUR RATIO WHICH IS GOOD WE'VE
BEEN PAYING DOWN DEBT AND WE
PAID OFF ECONOMIC RECOVERY
BONDS THAT WERE FOUND- IT TO
REST. REALLY BEFORE THE GREAT
RECESSION WITH WINDOWS WERE
ISSUED- SO THAT'S- WHAT ONE
GOOD A GOOD NEWS- THERE'S BEEN
OTHER AUGMENTATIONS- ALONG THE
WAY A LOT OF IT IS RESTORING
SERVICES- THAT WERE LOST DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION THAT. THE
MAJORITY OF- WHAT WHAT HAPPENED
IN TERMS OF- PROVIDER RATES AND
OTHER OPTIONAL BENEFITS AND
DENTAL UNFORTUNATELY WHAT
FORTUNATELY WAS WAS JUST
RESTORED AND THAT THIS MAY
REVISION DOES. NOT PROPOSED
ELIMINATE THE ENTIRE
RESTORATION OF DENTAL- JUSTIN
JUST THE PARTIAL- BECAUSE OF
THAT IT WILL YOU KNOW WHAT
ABSENT FEDERAL FUNDS BUT INTER
OF- OVERALL GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCIES I'LL GO BACK TO
THAT ON THE GO. IS TO REALLY
LOOK AT EVERY DEPARTMENT ACROSS
THE STATE GOVERNMENT NOT JUST
GENERAL FUND DEPARTMENTS BUT
ALSO SPECIAL FUND DEPARTMENTS.
AND LOOK FOR APPROXIMATELY 5%
REDUCTION IN THIS IS STATE
OPERATIONS THE BULK OF THE
MONEY THAT GOES THROUGH THE
STATE'S BUDGET GOES TO FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE- SO STATE
OPERATIONS IS REALLY THE STATE
STATE EMPLOYEES. AND THE
OPERATION OF GOVERNMENT AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND SO OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS- WILL BE LOOKING
AT. IT EFFICIENCIES THAT WE CAN
MAKE- WHETHER THAT BE REDUCE
SEEN OFFICE SPACE ESPECIALLY IN
LEASE SPACE WE HAVE A LOT OF
REAL ESTATE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M CAN WE DO MORE- TO
CAPITALIZE ON ALL OF THE
TELEWORK THAT'S HAPPENING AND
FIND WAYS TO REDUCE OUR FOOT
PRINTS ARE REAL ESTATE FOOT
PRINT- AND SAVE MONEY THERE-
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS TO
PUT MORE- SERVICES ONLINE TO
AND- TO INCREASE- CONVENIENCE
FOR THE PUBLIC. I'M DURING THIS
PANDEMIC A DMB WAS ABLE TO PUT
97% OF THEIR TRANSACTIONS
ONLINE I'M ESPECIALLY WITH THE
ADVENT OF THE VIRTUAL OFFICE
VISIT- THAT REALLY I THINK CAN
IMPROVE THE CONVENIENCE FOR THE
PUBLIC. BUT ALSO CAN SAVE-
MONEY OVER TIME THESE THINGS
ARE NOT EASY THEY WILL TAKE
SOME TIME TO IMPLEMENT SOME.
WHY SHOULD. THAT'S TECHNIQUE HE
I THAT CAN MODERNIZE OUR
CURRENT BUT IT'S- ARE. OP
AGENCY IS GOING TO BE LEADING.
I AB STTE WHY WE'RE- OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE COPAYS ADD IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE TRIP BY. THEY PASSED A-
WE'VE ALSO MADE THESE. WHICH IS
TO ALLOW. ALL AND THAT'S
TRAVEL- AND REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF PURCHASES REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF NEW VEHICLES THAT ARE
PURCHASED. I'M REALLY TRYING
TO- ADD MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THE PEOPLE'S MONEY IS BEING
SPENT WISELY- AND- TOWARDS- YOU
KNOW THE EFFECTIVE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT THAT DEPARTMENTS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SO. AN AD
THAT'S GOING TO BE- SOMETHING
THAT'S ON GOING- OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS- TO REACHED THAT-
THAT GOAL. THANK YOU WERE GOING
TO GO TO MR GRAYSON MISSED ALI.
MR GLORIA AND THEN MISTER
SANTIAGO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANT TO GIVE MUCH
THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP MISTER SPEAKER
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY. I LIKE MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN IN
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION WITH
CONSTITUENTS AND LOCAL LEADERS
AND MY DISTRICT. AND IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING BUT THE SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN HAVE HAD CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE VERY HARD. AND FOR
MANY PEOPLE DURING THIS TIME
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY SO
ANXIOUS- INTEREST SPIRITS ARE
UP AND AS WE RAPIDLY APPROACHED
CRAFTING A BALANCED BUDGET. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT UST A FEW
AREAS OF CONCERN NOT ONLY FOR
MYSELF BUT FOR MY DISTRICT AS
WELL. ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
AROUND THE WORLD NEWS REPORTS
ARE MOUNTING HOT OF HIGHER
RATES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
STAY HOME ORDERS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
NUMEROUS ARTICLES HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED AN ALARMING DROP IN
CHILD ABUSE AND THE REASON WHY
THIS IS ALARMING IS BECAUSE
PEOPLE LIKE TEACHERS WHO OFTEN
MAKE THESE REPORTS HAVE NOT
SEEN THEIR STUDENTS IN MONTHS.
THERE'S BEEN A DISTURBING
INCREASE IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MURDER SUICIDES THIS SHOULD
CONCERN ALL OF US FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSPECTIVE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFECT. ANY CALLOW. WE
ARE TWENTY FOUR JUSTICE CENTERS
THE PROVIDES THE SERVICES TO
VICTIMS INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE.
PLASTIC BRACKETS ACTUAL SOUL
JOE ABUSE ELDER ABUSE AND HUMAN.
SO AS WE ARE LOOK FOR A- TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE KEPT HEALTHY AND SAFE
DURING THESE TIMES WE SHOULD
CONSIDER FUNDING THE EXISTING
CENTERS LIKE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS AND OUR NEXT THAT ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES PROVIDING IS
WHY. BEING SERVICES. STATEWIDE
ORDER TO CHILDREN. CHILD CARE
SO AND FAMILY CARE HOMES CAN TO
REMAIN. AS A SENSE BUSINESS. AS
CALIPH URGING THE CENTRE TO RE
OPEN DURING THE- NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THIS ALSO MUST PER
CLICK. FOR OF FAMILY CARE HOMES.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE FOR. AND
CREATE TO OUR- FOR ENSURING
EQUAL. TO THE EAST OF TO CHILD
CARE FINDING AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY CHILDCARE IS A MAJOR
CHALLENGE FOR MANY FAMILIES AND
ACCESS DIFFERS BASED ON
GEOGRAPHY RACE. ETHNICITY AND
INCOME THERE ARE MANY SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF ACCESS
THAT THE STATE CAN CONSIDER
BOTH WITHIN THE BUDGET. AND
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE ACTION. THE
PANDEMIC INDUCED RESET A
RECESSION COMBINED WITH
MANDATORY SOCIAL DISTANCING
STRINGENT SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND
ANTICIPATED REDUCTIONS AND
CAPACITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DELIVER SERVICES TO THE
HOUSING INDUSTRY. WILL
DRASTICALLY IMPACT ALL SEGMENTS
OF A COMPLEX ECOSYSTEM THAT
DELIVERS THE ESSENTIAL HOUSING
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO COMBAT THE
HOUSING CRISIS. WELL PROJECT
ROOM KEY WAS A FIRST STEP TO
ENSURING HOMELESS IN OUR STATE-
THE HAVE SAFE HOUSING
CONDITIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC
IT WAS ONLY JUST A FIRST STEP.
AND WE MUST CONSIDER LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS FOR HOUSING THE
HOMELESS WITH. AND INCLUDING
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA'S FACING A HELPING
CRISIS AND A HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THAT HAVE ONLY BEEN MADE
WORSE BY THE BY OVER NINETY. US
HAVE BEEN ALL THE- OF THIS. AND
IT'S BEEN HIT HARD THEY WILL
NEED TO PRESERVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION PUBLIC HEALTH. MAKES
THE JOB. FOR A- THE CITY OF.
MIGHT HAVE TO CUT THE POLICE.
BY APPROX SEVEN PER WE NEED TO
DEDICATE FUNDING FOR OUR
LOCALITIES WHO ARE ALREADY
GRAPPLING WITH BUDGET DEFICITS
SO THEY DO NOT WORK ON THESE
CRITICAL. NEED POSITIONS AND
SPEEDY BROKE. JUST A OF MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AS THE AS MEASURE FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS INC. NOT ALL
LOSE WILL BE FOUND IN BUDGET
THERE MUST BE LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THAT WORKS IN TANDEM
WITH THE BUDGET TO PROVIDE
RESULTS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES SO
THEY CAN SAFELY RE OPEN AND
STAY AFLOAT. AND TO MAINTAIN
OUR POSITION A VIBRANT JOB
CREATION AND ALLOWING FOR
BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE MEMBERS.
WE NEED RESULTS SO THAT PEOPLE%
ARE NOT LIMITED TO FIGHTING FOR
SURVIVAL BUT ARE ABLE TO
PROSPER AND LIVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
GO TO MISS DOLLARS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND ELLIE- STAFF ECHO
MANY OF THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES PARTICULARLY
REGARDING THE EDUCATION CUTS
EDUCATION SHOULD BE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY THIS IS A FAILURE AND
PRIOR TRACING THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS SCHOOLS AND PARENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
STRUGGLING. FOR BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT COULD BE RE PURPOSED
TO MEET THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
OUR SCHOOLS TO KEEP THEM
AFLOAT. SECONDLY AS OUR STATE
INTEREST FIRE SEASON THE MAY
REVISE FAILED TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE SUPPORT TO ONE OF OUR
MOST IMPORTANT BASE CAMP
RESOURCES ACROSS. THE STATE.
FAIRS THE BUDGET INCLUDES FORTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS ONLY TO STATE
AGENCY FAIRS EVEN CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY FOUR COUNTY FAIRS WITH
NO SUPPORT THE MAY REVISE ALSO
DELETE THE EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE WAS
ORIGINALLY INCLUDED IN JANUARY
BUDGET THIS IS A FUNDING
GENERATED BY FAIRS AND DESIGNED
TO BENEFIT. ALL FAIRS IN THE
NETWORK. MY CONCERN WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IS IT TAKES FROM ALL
THAT ALL WHO PROVIDE THE
ASSISTANCE AND GIVE IT TO A
FEW. NGUYEN CAO FIRE NEEDS A
FAIR GROUNDS FOR BASE CAMP
DURING FIRE SEASON IT DOESN'T
ASK IF THE PROPERTY IS A COUNTY
FAIR OR STATE AGENCY FAIR. THE
BUDGET SHOULD BE ALTERED TO
INCLUDE THE ORIGINAL ALLOCATION
OF EIGHTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
IN SELF GENERATED FUNDS FOR
FAIRS. IN ADDITION TO THE
PROPOSED FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION WHICH SHOULD BE A
AVAILABLE TO ALL FAIRS FINALLY
THAT TIME WHEN ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE COULD BE.
NOT COULD NOT BE MORE CREEK
CRITICAL THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
PROP FIFTY FIFTY SIX PROVIDER
RATE WILL BE DEVASTATING FOR
RURAL COMMUNITIES. THESE VOTER
APPROVED RATES HAVE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE IN
ELIMINATION OF THIS FUNDING
WILL EXACT RATE THE RULE
HEALTHCARE CRISIS. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHY WAS THE DECISION
MADE TO LIMIT THE FORTY POINT
THREE MILLION ALLOCATION TO
STATE AID AGENCY FAIRS AT THE
EXPENSE OF OUR COUNTY FAIRS
WHEN ALL FAIRS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE MURDERS HE RESPONSE. SO
THE FOR THE FORTY POINT THREE
MILLION IS ACTUALLY FOR A VERY
SPECIFIC PURPOSE- BECAUSE
FAIRS- ARE NOT GOING TO BE.
ABLE TO OPERATE IN AND DO THE
NORMAL- AND REVENUE GENERATING
THEY'RE IN A POSITION OF
NEEDING TO IMMEDIATELY START
TO. LAY OFF STAFF- THOSE FAIR
EMPLOYEES OUR STATE STAFF- AND
SO THERE IS A PROCESS THAT THAT
THEY MUST GO THROUGH. AND SO
INSTEAD OF LEAVING THE FAIRS
WITH A SHORTAGE OF MONEY TO AT
LEAST CONTINUE THE PAYROLL
UNTIL ALL OF THEN THE
NOTIFICATIONS IN THE PROCESS
GOES GOES THROUGH. AND THAT
MONEY WAS PROVIDED- AND ADD IT
AND THOSE ARE FOR ALL OF THE
FAIRS THAT HAVE- STATE
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU SO IN
CLOSING SUPPORTING FIRE
PREPAREDNESS AND HEALTH CARE OR
WHERE WE SHOULD BE PLACED IN
OUR PRIORITIES. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER GLORIA THAN
MISTER SANTIAGO. MR BIGELOW IN
THE MISTER FALL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST OF
QUESTION FOR FINANCE CURIOUS
WHEN- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MUST TAKE ACTION ORDER TO AVOID
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRIGGER
CUTS IN THIS BUDGET. WHAT DATE.
SORRY THE WAY THE TRIGGER IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED- THE
REDUCTIONS WOULD GO INTO EFFECT
ON JULY ONE. AND LAST THERE ARE
FEDERAL FUNDS- THERE'S A
PROJECT PROVISION IF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS- COME IN LATER
THIS SUMMER- THEY THOSE THOSE
CUTS COULD BE REVERSED- BUT AND
THAT'S AND THAT'S HOW THEY
WOULD GO. THE SECOND QUESTION
YOU PRESENTATION THE BUDGET THE
PROPOSES UTILIZING THE RAINY
DAY FUND TO HELP. BALANCE THE
BUDGET DOES THIS BOOK BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR SEAT MAKING ANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR RESERVES
IN THIS FISCAL YEAR. IT DOES
NOT OKAY IT DOES NOT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH QUESTION I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THE VICE CHAIR AS WELL THE
DEPRECIATION DOOR GOVERNOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP. A TO OUR
SPEAKER FOR THIS A HISTORIC
CONVENING- OF COURSE TO THE
COMMITTEE- IT STAFF AND INTO
OUR LA WHO DOES A MASTERFUL JOB
IN HELPING TO TAKE COMPLEX
SUBJECTS TO MAKE IT RELATABLE
EVEN TO THOSE OF US THAT ARE
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND THEM. I WANT
TO JUST POINT OUT THAT I
STARTED MY ELECTED SERVICE
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION I
RECOGNIZE THE BOUNCING A
BUDGET. DURING AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS WILL NOT BE EASY NOR
WILL BE PAINLESS- FROM SPENDING
REDUCTIONS TO PAY CUTS TO
REVENUE HIKES YOU THE OPTIONS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
OUR ATTRACTIVE. I WORRY THAT
THIS PROPOSED BUDGET LEAVES A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT DEPLETES THE
RAINY DAY FUND INCREASES DEBT
AND OTHER LONG TERM OBLIGATIONS
AND LEAVES FUTURE LEGISLATORS
WITH EVEN WORSE OPTIONS TO
CHOOSE FROM. IN THE YEARS TO
COME. AS WE CONSIDER HOW THE
STATE WILL EXPAND ITS LIMITED
RESOURCES I THINK THAT WE WOULD
DO OURSELVES AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS A GREAT SERVICE IF
THIS BUDGET IS PAIRED WITH A
ROBUST STATE STIMULUS PLAN.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE NEED TO GET
CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK WE
MUST EXPLAIN HOW OUR ACTIONS.
IN THE BUDGET AND OUTSIDE OF IT
WILL HELP PUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIANS ON THE JOB GET
BUSINESS IS A COMMUNITIES GOING
AGAIN AND GROW THE REVENUES
THAT WE NEED TO PROPERLY
SERVICE ARE FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS. FIRST WE MUST WILL
PROBABLY MUST BE MUST BE THE
PROPER FUNDING OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION. THIS IS NOT ONLY AN
IMPERATIVE FOR PARENTS LOOKING
TO RETURN TO WORK BUT IS
CRITICAL FOR TRAINING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO COMPETE IN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY. THEY ARE OF COURSE OUR
FUTURE TAXPAYERS. I SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF OUR LARGE URBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
QUESTIONED THE EDUCATIONAL
FUNDING DECISIONS IN THIS
BUDGET AND HOPE THAT THEY WILL
BE ADDRESSED. I THINK THAT'S
ALSO TRUE FOR THE UTILIZATION
OF POP SIXTY FIFTY SIX MONTHS
PARTICULARLY AS THEY RELATE TO
WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE. SECONDLY
I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED BY THE
NIMBLE ACTION OF STATE AGENCIES
TO INNOVATE DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES IN PARTICULAR
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL. ALT OFFICES
WHO ARE SUPPORTING LOCAL
BUSINESSES BY AUTHORIZING TAKE
AWAY COCKTAILS AND HOW DOOR
DINING RIGHT NOW I JUST GIVE A
SHOUT. OUT TO TAKE WE COCKED
DOES DO NOT TAKE THEM BACK.
THAT IS NOT GONNA BE RECEIVE.
WHAT OTHER THAN NO IN LOW COST.
CAN AGING. AND NOW. RIGHT NOW
TO BUSINESS AND CAL. GAY TO
WORK WHAT. CAN BE. FOR CRITICAL
EDUCATE HEALTH AND SAFETY. I
GREW SUCH REGULAR RELIEF. NOW
NOT LATER. THIRD INTEREST
INVEST HAS ALL BEEN A- ME OF I
CAN. STATE HOW CAN STATE FUNNY
BE USED TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF PROJECTS THAT CAN BE BUILT
DID IN THIS BUDGET YEAR. HOW
CAN WE BE SURE GAS TAX REVENUES
ARE FULLY EMPLOYED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IMPROVE CITIES.
AND EMPLOY MORE CALIFORNIANS.
CAN FINALLY MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
WILL SURELY DEFEAT COVE IN
NINETEEN. OF THIS I HAVE NO
DOUBT. BUT WE LET'S NOT FORGET
THE BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC THE
MOST URGENT ISSUE FACING THE
STATE WAS OUR HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING CRISIS. IT WAS A
PROBLEM BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN.
IT'LL BE AN EVEN BIGGER ONE
AFTER. LET'S CRAFTED BUDGET.
AND AN ASSOCIATED STIMULUS
PLAN. THAT WILL MAKE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THESE
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES. IN
CLOSING I WAN TO JUST REMIND
OF BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IN MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS. AS
A HOST OF REQUEST THAT ARE
PENDING BEFORE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. I POINT OUT THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAS RESEARCH SURVIVE
DEPENDENT BEFORE. WE AIM TO
SURVIVE THIS ONE AGAIN BUT WE
HOPE TO DO WITH THE SOCIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LOUDEST
DEFEAT THE LAST ONE. AND THERE
ARE MANY FUNDING REQUEST
PENDING. TRY I TRY TO JUST
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THANK YOU CAN
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN MISTER SPEAKER. I YOUR-
SURE THIS AND PUT. THANK YOU
MISTER SAUCIER. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
THE WORK THE AND OTHERS A
TOGETHER KIND OF CRAFT
FRAMEWORK BUT BUT I WHAT'S OF
WHAT'S WHAT'S MY PRONOUNCED NOW
IS THAT THE INCOME A THAT HAS
BEEN OVER THE YEARS IS NOW MORE
PROFOUND FELT WITH THOSE WHO
DON'T DON'T HAVE SO YOU DIDN'T
HAVE HEALTH. IT JUST GOT OF A
LOT WORSE IT YOU DON'T HAVE. IF
YOU DID HAS VISION BORDER. JUST
GOT A LOT WORSE IF YOU'RE
<c.magenta>IVING ON THE STREETS RESOURCES</c>
DRIED UP. SO WE- WERE YOU ARE.
ON THAT LOWER ECONOMIC SCALE
YOUR HURT MUCH WORSE TODAY THAN
YOU HAVE EVER PART. I WANT TO
RAISE UP THE USUAL HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND SOME OF US HAVE MENTIONED
THE MILLER- TWO BILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST SOME OF US TO JUST
MENTION HOMELESS AS AN ISSUE.
EVEN THEN IF WE WERE TO PUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S STILL
LESS. OR ABOUT 1% OF THE STATE
BUDGET. THIS IS ASSUMING THAT
THIS IS ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THOSE WERE
MOST VULNERABLE WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE RENTERS. ON
THE LOWER ECONOMIC SCALE WE'VE
GOT MUCH WORK TO DO FOR RENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND EVEN
THOSE WHO ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY
NOW. OR BEFORE OF LOSING THEIR
MORTGAGE. WE TALK ABOUT THE
MOST VULNERABLE WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES. THE BEST A HARD TO
GET WORK BEFORE. AND IF IT WAS
HARD TO PAY RENT BEFORE. IT IS
MUCH HARDER TODAY AND YES THEY
PAY TAXES. WE'RE PROPOSING TO
LET YOU KNOW CAUCUS. THAT THAT
IF YOU THOUGHT THAT IF YOU HAD
NINETEEN NUMBER YOUR PREPARE
AND YOU FALL TAXES THAT YEAH
YOU SHOULD RECEIVE ON. BENEFITS
YEAH YOU SHOULD WE SHOULD
EXPAND THE IDC CARE THE I CC
PROGRAM. TO THOSE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED. WE'VE GOT MUCH
MORE WORK TO DO WHEN IT COMES
TO UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
THAT'S NOT TO MENTION OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OR THE
PROPOSED CHANGE IN THE IN
MANAGE HEALTHCARE THAT WOULD
DEPRIVE EVEN LA COUNTY ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLIONS MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THAT IS ALREADY AN
ADEQUATE FOR MANY WHO THOSE.
HORNS WERE IN GREAT NEED.
THAT'S NOT TO MENTION THAT-
DIGITAL DIVIDE. SO IF YOU'RE IN
AN URBAN AREA IN DIDN'T HAVE.
GOOD CONDUCTIVITY WELL NOW YOU
HAVE. NO SCHOOLING IF YOU CAN'T
CONNECT TO THE INTERNET IF YOU
HAVE NO TABLETS. IF YOU COULD
IF YOU DON'T HAVE HEALTH CARE
BEFORE AND IT WAS HARD.
TELEHEALTH IS WANTED POTENTIAL
SOLUTION. PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE WHO CAN'T SHOW UP. I TO A
CLINIC TO A OSPITAL OR TO
VISIT A REGULAR DOCTOR. THERE
ARE SOLUTIONS ON THE TABLE THAT
WE CAN TAKE. NOBODY HERE I
BELIEVE ONCE DID YOU ANY CUTS.
BASED ON WHAT I'VE HEARD ALL OF
US LAMENTED THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN WITH A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT. AND
EVEN IF IT'S BACK BILL BY
FEDERAL FUNDS WE STILL LACK. A
SOCIAL MATT. WE STILL LACK THE
ABILITY TO FULFILL THOSE THINGS
THAT WE VERY MUCH CARE ABOUT.
EVERYONE HERE STATED. THAT WE
NEEDED TO PRESERVE PROGRAMS
THAT WE LAMENTED CUTS. BUT
THAT'S ONLY IF WE ACCEPT THE
STATUS QUO AND DON'T THINK
ABOUT SOLUTIONS. AND THE WAY TO
INCREASE REVENUE. I DON'T THINK
IT'S A SECRET THAT PAST
GOVERNORS AND LEGISLATURES. AND
COALITIONS HAVE AFTER VOTERS TO
CONSIDER RAISING REVENUE VOTERS
CAN DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S A THAT'S
A FAIR SOLUTION. AND I DON'T I
LOOK AT IT ONE OF THE 1% JUMP
ON A PRIVATE JET GO TO THE
LUXURY OF A TWENTY SECONDS THE
QUARANTINE THE REST OF THE 99%
AS HARTNETT HOME. GETTING MORE
SICK AND SEEN THE NUMBERS DRIVE
UP AN ILLNESS AN INFECTION RATE
THE CALL THE NINETEEN. I MEAN I
PUT ON THE TABLE. MAYBE WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT A WEALTH TAX.
BUT SOME PEOPLE ARE DOING
JUSTICE COMFORTABLE TODAY. AS
THEY WERE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
AND IN FACT SOME MIGHT ARGUE
THAT THEY'RE EVEN DOING BETTER
TODAY. THAN THEY WERE BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. I THINK WE SHOULD
PUT ALL THOSE THINGS ON THE
TABLE. AND TALK ABOUT. HAVING
THEM PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER. THANK
YOU ANOTHER BEST BIGELOW. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'D LIKE
TO COMPLIMENT YOU AND THE VICE
CHAIR I'M PUTTING TOGETHER A
WONDERFUL HEARING HERE FOR US
TODAY IT'S GONE A LITTLE BIT
LONG BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION OF THE ALEJO.
SIR CLEARLY TODAY WE HEARD IN
OVER. WELL MAKING A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED A
LOT OF GOOD COMMENTS A LOT OF
CONCERNS RAISED. EACH OF THESE
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS RAISED.
REALLY REVOLVED WITH ONE THREAD.
THE LACK OF OR THE MISSING
COMPONENT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE ITSELF.
ANY OF THE QUESTIONS IN TODAY'S
PRESENTATION ON THE LAST PAGE
OF YOUR DOCUMENT OF YOUR
PRESENTATIONS YOU'D AT RAISE
THE ISSUE OF THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES TO PROPOSE
SIGNIFICANT POLICY CHANGES
SUBMIT SEVERAL PROPOSALS
SIDELINE THE LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY WITH THE GOVERNOR
HAVING- SIDESTEPPED OR
OVERSTAFFED ON NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED LAWS COULD YOU
ELABORATE ON YOUR COMMENT THERE
REACHING ARCH. WE THINK THAT
THE- PROPOSALS FOR SOME OF THE
COVE IT NINETEEN RELATED
SPENDING IN PARTICULAR USING
THE CONTROL SECTION PROCESS.
COULD BE DONE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY AND AT THIS POINT- IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE IF WE THINK BACK
ABOUT YOU KNOW AT THE TIME WHEN
THIS FIRST HAPPENED IN THE
LEGISLATURE WAS GOING ON RECESS
THAT THE THERE WAS A NEED FOR A
NIMBLE RESPONSE BY THE STATE
BUT I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
DEMONSTRATED ITS ABILITY TO ACT
SWIFTLY AT THAT TIME TO PASS
LEGISLATION AND I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE-
GRANTS. UNUSUAL LEVEL OF
DISCRETION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW TO RE
RE DIRECT FUNDS OR TO ALLOCATE
FUNDS TO ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED CODE RELATED FOR
EXAMPLE AND SO YOU KNOW WE JUST
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD AS A BODY WOULD
WANT TO REVIEW AND CONSIDER
MAKING SOME AMENDMENTS TO IN
ORDER TO PROTECT YOUR OVERSIGHT
CAPACITY. THANK YOU- WITH THAT
SAID COULD YOU- PLEASE OUTLINE
IN WRITING WHAT SOME OF THOSE
ARE IN DETAIL SO THAT WE CAN
FOCUS ON THEM AS A BODY- IN
MORE DETAIL SO THAT WE CAN
DIGEST THAT AND- TAKE ACTION ON
PROTECTING THOSE. MISTER CHAIR
WITH RESPECT TO- THE REST OF MY
COMMENTS I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE SPEAKER FOR HIS
ACTIONS OF PULLING TOGETHER
THIS ENTIRE HEARING AS WELL.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT WE COULD
ALSO MAKE SURE WE FOCUS ON NOT
GIVING AWAY AREN'T SORTIE AND
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES HERE I
WOULD. ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GOVERNOR TAKING HIS ACTIONS WE
DID SO AS A BODY IN THE
BEGINNING. GIVE IT LIKE THE LA-
SAID GIVEN THAT SAID WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE JUST AS IT WAS SAID
TODAY BY THE GOVERNOR OF THE
STATE IN NEW YORK. A LOT OF
BAD- DECISIONS WERE MADE A LOT
OF MISTAKES WERE MADE. BASED
UPON THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
GIVEN AT THE TIME. SO WE'VE ALL
LEARNED AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS LET'S ALL AGREE
THAT WE CAN ALL DO BETTER. AND
WORK TOGETHER IN A L. MORE
STRUCTURED WAY I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE CAN BE MOST SUCCESSFUL-
BUT I DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER
REACHING AND GOING ANY FARTHER.
BECAUSE TOO MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HURT THROUGH THIS PROCESS
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER HERE TODAY. SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU FOR THE AND IF IT BE OKAY.
IF THE L. L. COULD ADDRESS.
THAT RESPONSE TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE RATHER THAN JUST-
MY COLLEAGUE THAT BE GREAT.
THANK YOU IF THAT'S OKAY WITH
YOU MISTER FALL. I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS-
FIRST WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS- THE PROPOSED TRANSFER
FUNDS FROM THE STATE HIGHWAY
COUNT- TO THE GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF ITS ATTENDED PROMISE
PURPOSE THAT WAS MENTIONED BY-
I NEVER MY COLLEAGUES AND
SECONDLY- FUNDING FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL REMAINS
CONSPICUOUSLY UNAFFECTED GIVING
IT RECEIVED A CONTINUES
ALLOCATION 25% OF CAP AND TRADE
AUCTION PROCEEDS DESPITE
SITTING ON A TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OR WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS TO HIGH SPEED RAIL
REVENUES IN ORDER TO FUND
EDUCATION OR HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING. THIS FALL I WILL SAY
THAT WE MUST ADJUST OUR
PRIORITIES REFLECT OUR NEEDS AT
THIS TIME AND BREAKING PROMISES
BY SHIFTING TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS AND NOT ADJUSTING HIGH
SPEED RAIL FOR REVENUES TO FUND
OTHER PRIORITIES SUCH AS
EDUCATION DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
ME AND SO AS THIS WITH A
MISTRESS HAS SAID TIME AND TIME
AGAIN OUR BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF OUR PRIORITIES
HOWEVER IN THIS BUDGET WE I
BELIEVE WE ARE NOT PUTTING OUR
RESOURCES WHERE THEY ARE NEEDED
MOST AND I WOULD LIKE TO. HEAR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. YES ON THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL. THOSE MONIES
THOSE CAP AND TRADE MONIES THAT
ARE AT THAT HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED
TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL- THOSE
ARE THOSE WILL BE SPENT ON ON
COMPLETING THAT THE- THE- SECT.
THE SECTION OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND THEY THE FEDERAL FUNDING-
WORK THERE WAS A TIME LIMIT ON
SPENDING THAT SO THAT'S THE
MONEY THAT'S BEING SPENT FIRST-
THERE ARE NO PROPOSED CHANGES
TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THIS
BUDGET. AND THAT BUDGET WE
TALKED A LOT TODAY ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE IMPORTANT
EVENT AT PORTENTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AS ONE WAY THAT
GOVERNMENT CAN ACTUALLY SPUR
AND ADD JOBS. AND THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS ADDED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- AND WILL
CONTINUE TO OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS AS THE-
CONSTRUCTION CONTINUES TO RAMP
UP- SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING NOW. SO TO STOP THAT
WOULD BE REALLY DETRIMENTAL TO
THAT TO THAT EFFORT THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON- AND THEN I KNOW I
KNOW THAT YOU HAD ANOTHER
QUESTION AT THE BEGINNING THEN
I GOT IT JUST LIKE THEY KNOW
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
TRANSFER. OF FILES THAT I TO
THE STATE OUR ACCOUNTS OF THE
STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT THE
MONIES THAT WERE TRANSFERRED
AND AGAIN. LOOKING ALL ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENT AND ALL
DIFFERENT AREAS FROM FUNDS THAT
COULD BE BORROWED OR
TRANSFERRED AND WE IN THAT AND
THAT IS. NOT IDEAL- BUT GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS CRISIS WE
THINK THAT SOME INTERNAL
BORROWING AS NECESSARY. TO
REALLY AVOID THE HARSHEST CUTS-
IN SO THAT THAT- STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT THOSE OUR INTEREST
EARNINGS AND THAT THE IDEA IS
THAT THOSE WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
TRANSFERRED. TO THE GENERAL
FUND. IT JUST IT WAS JUST OF
ART ARE NOT PROTECTED UNDER THE
THAT I'M ARTICLE NINETEEN OF
THE CONSTITUTION. I SEE THAT
THERE'S THE SEMANTICS THERE BUT
I WOULD JUST LIKE THE I MEAN I
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
IS NO INTENT BY DEMONSTRATION
TO BACK FILL ANY OF THOSE FUNDS
ARE TRANSFERRED. SO THAT WOULD
BE TRANSPLANT OUR TRANSFERS ARE
TRANSFERS LOANS OR LOANS AND
LOANS WOULD BE REPAID WITH
INTEREST. SO THIS IS SO IT
WOULD OPENING WOULD BE THIS ONE
IS MY AND- MY UNDERSTANDING. IS
INTEREST EARNINGS THAT WOULD BE.
AND NOT PAID BACK AND NOT BE
BACK THANK YOU. OKAY I'M NOT
SEEING ANY MORE. MICROPHONES I
WAS GOING TO GO TO- ARE VICE
CHAIR FOR A CLOSING COMMENT ON
MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT AND WILL.
WE WILL. MONITOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WHAT LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
HERE I THINK THIS IS BEEN A
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL HEARING
WANTED TO GIVE A SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO MISS BOSNE- THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE STAFF.
MISTER PECK AND- LEGISLATIVE IN
ALL STAFF I THINK BOTH OF YOU
HAVING BEEN HERE'S MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE I THINK IT'S BEEN
VERY HELPFUL ALSO TO ALL OF OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF I KNOW THE
HOURS LATE I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND SUPPORTING US. AND
ESPECIALLY TO ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY WHO'VE SPOKEN BY
THIS AFTERNOON I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR JUST HOW COMMITTED
AND HOW PASSIONATE ALL OF YOU
ARE ON THIS TOPIC. AND I THINK
THAT IT ALSO ILLUSTRATES
HOWEVER THE A LONG WAYS THAT WE
HAVE TO GO IN CRAFTING. THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL SO
MISTER SHARP LOOKING FORWARD TO
DOING THAT WITH YOU IN THE
NEXT. COUPLE OF WEEKS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR FOR ALL THE- CLOSING
COMMENTS AGAIN JUST THANK YOU
TO. ALL THE STAFF WE STARTED
WITH THE STAFF IN THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE THE- ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE THE SERGEANTS. AGAIN
OF MY BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
ALL THE FOLKS WHO WENT. AND
HELPED. PUT THIS COMMITTEE THE
WHOLE ON TOGETHER. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. I AGAIN WANT TO
ECHO- MY ICE CHAIRS ARE
PRESSURES COMMENTS AND JUST
THINK- MISS BASEL ARE FOR
SPENDING- FIVE FIVE HOURS WITH
THE HOUSE AND VERY MUCH FIVE
AND A HALF HOURS I GUESS. VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
ESPECIALLY. DURING BUDGET SEE
THAT IT'S A VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT. BUT
HOPEFULLY YOU YOU GET
UNDERSTANDING- FROM THE BODY OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES. WILL
PEOPLE THINKING FOR AND I THINK
WHAT YOU. WHEN YOU HEARD TODAY.
WAS A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
WORK. WITH THE GOVERNOR THAT.
EVERYONE IN THE BODY REALLY
WANTS TO WORK. WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND TO GO FORWARD
TOGETHER. AND THERE'S OUTLINES
OF DIFFERENT THINGS OUR
CONCERNS. BUT OVERALL I THINK
THERE WAS. A MESSAGE TO ME THAT
AS A STATE WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
TODAY AND ALL YOUR- ALL YOUR
EFFORT ALSO TO MR PADDOCK AND
LA I'LL- REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE- ALL THE TIME YOU SPENT BUT
ALSO YOUR STAFF. AND ALL THE
GUIDANCE THEY'RE THEY'RE ALWAYS
VERY CRITICAL PART OF THE
BUDGET. PROCESS AND- THEY'VE
BEEN EVEN MORE CRITICAL. THIS
TIME BECAUSE OF THE VERY SHORT
TIME FRAME THAT WE'VE HAD TO.
REALLY ANALYZE THINGS AND TAKE
A LOOK SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP. WORSE OFF. AND
AGAIN JUST THANK I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS FOR ALL THEIR.
PARTICIPATION TODAY WE HAD.
HUGE NUMBER MEMBER TO ONE OF.
ONE JUST. ONE X. THEIR CAN. AND
SHARE. A SURE THEIR THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE BUDGET VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. WE KNOW WE HAVE A
FEW WEEKS TO PUT THIS BUDGET
TOGETHER I'M VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE PASSING A
BALANCED. ON TIME BUDGET BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT PROCESS SO I
IMAGINE THE NEXT TIME WILL BE
HERE. WILL BE ACTUALLY TO BE
DISCUSSED OUR BUDGET- I AM VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. WITH WITH
WELL WHAT I WOULD RECOGNIZE
MISTER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR RECOGNIZING
FROM MY MOTION I MOVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE DO NOW
RISE AND REPORT BACK TO THE
ASSEMBLY. SO SECOND. THAT IS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THREE THE
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON
SECONDED BY MISTER OBERNOLTE WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE I THINK
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT
AND VOTING ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE HI ALL OF THE POSTS
THEY KNOW. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
MOTION CARRIES WE ARE NOW BACK
IN REGULAR SESSION MISTER
SPEAKER. EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT THAT THE TESTIMONY FROM
THE COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE BE
PRINTED AN APPENDIX IN APPENDIX
TO THE JOURNAL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. WE TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SEVENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
TWENTY EIGHTH CHECK IN SESSION.
SINGER FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MISTER OBERNOLTE SECONDS. THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UPON CALL OF THE SPEAKER IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.